if we all can take a seat please
good morning good morning again hi i'm
peter carmichael
member of the history department at
gettysburg college
i'm also the director of the civil war
institute
it is my pleasure this morning
to introduce to you patrick breen
who is an associate professor in history
and classics at providence college
i should note he is also the father of
one of our
high school scholarship recipients from
last year correct she came here and
enjoyed herself i'm sure
uh patrick
is the author of
the land shall be deluged in blood
a new history of nat turner's revolt
published by oxford university press
i can say to you
that it is one of the finest books that
i've read in southern history in a very
long time
it is a book that i assigned
to my undergraduates this spring and as
we all know
undergraduates they're tough customers
when it comes to books they absolutely
enjoyed
mr breen scholarship and especially his
writing
it is a bold book it is an important
book
and one of the things that patrick and i
talked about
that is just uh
it's just a shame
that one can go to southampton county
today
where turner's revolt took place
you'll see some state signage
but you will have no way
of taking a driving tour
to see the sites
related to that important revolt it
truly is shocking i know patrick is
trying to do his part
and trying to bring more awareness and
attention
so that audiences like us
who go to battlefields and i suspect if
we had the opportunity we would take a
bus down to southampton county
to be able to look at that historic
landscape that has changed radically i
don't believe and patrick can speak to
this later that there is a single
building that still survives
from the revolt is that true is there
any homes that are left at all there are
some okay good idea i wasn't aware of
that
so
it is a real pleasure
to have patrick here at civil war
institute and he of course will be
speaking about his book
about nat turner's revolt patrick breen
[Applause]
thank you peter uh and thank you all for
coming this is a real honor and a
pleasure to be here
um
coming to talk to to you guys at the
civil war institute's a real honor and
i'm really pleased to do it um i also
want to make a special welcome to the
to the young people the high school
students who are here as peter
carmichael said my daughter actually
applied and got into it last year had a
great great experience
i want to encourage you because if i
well there's two things one my daughter
wants to thank you peter for not
inviting me last year
which is fair
and second
i want to tell you guys what i would
tell my daughter but i wouldn't tell my
daughter this because she's not going to
listen to me you guys are at a great age
you're going to be looking at colleges
you're going to be doing things
really reach out to people
this is a great opportunity for you guys
to learn
about the life of the mind and don't be
afraid of people who have pulitzer
prizes and who've written 30 books and
i mean i'm allowed to be scared of them
but you guys not so much not so much
and if you are scared don't come talk to
me but get in the habit of talking to
these people find out what you're
interested in this is a really really
great opportunity peter you run and i i
think it's a fabulous thing and i want
you guys to get in the habit because
when you get to college you could be the
person who's in the front row in college
who goes up and meets the speaker
afterwards and we love that the people
who come to speak love the students who
are engaged
and so i want to get you guys in the
habit of it it's an unbelievable
opportunity
anyway today i'm going to be talking
about nat turner of course not turner
didn't happen in gettysburg in 1863.
here i am talking at gettysburg how do i
get you guys back
to 1831. well gettysburg as you know
um
is you know
central battle i mean this is place of
the most important battle that happened
in american history
um
it's also the place of
the gettysburg address
right this is a place where history's
happened
you know so people come here unlike
southampton county where history
happened too but people don't come
we don't have a woodstock for nat turner
this is great i love this thing
civil war woodstock this is awesome
we don't have that
well i guess we do it's like when me and
ken greenberg get together for drinks
it's like
it's not the same anyway how do i get
you guys back there it's not i'm not
like i'm going to tell you about 1863
more than you already know
well let me let me start let me start
with this
abraham lincoln
now it's not his gettysburg address but
it's his cooper union address in 1860
one of the most important speeches he
makes
and this is
when he's a candidate that's this that
picture of him from matthew brady has
taken the same day as the cooper's union
address
has anyone ever aged as much in five
years i don't know
anyway abraham lincoln gets up and one
of the things he does is he's sitting
there and in this address he starts
talking about southampton county
and he asks his audience of new yorkers
what induced
the southampton insurrection
28 years ago in which at least three
times as many lives were lost as at
harper's ferry
what happened now why is he asking this
i think it's pretty simple to understand
why he's asking this the republicans are
getting blamed for john brown
and lincoln's saying it's not john brown
that started slave insurrections in fact
john brown slave insurrection is a
complete fiasco
if you want to look at a real slave
insurrection look at southampton county
and why did they
revolt wasn't because of the republicans
there were no republicans
so what is it so what is it that made
the slaves revolt in southampton county
i think it's a good question and one
that does bear on people who are
studying the civil war when you guys
those guys who are really diving into
this should think about
that's one i'll talk about i think for
the next 45 minutes or so
so we're going back back to 1831.
not 1832 near gettysburg college was
founded
1831.
it's not lincoln who's president it's
jackson
that guy who's on the 20 for at least
another 10 years i hear
economics
i want to set
this economically
when we look at the civil war many
historians who know a lot more about
civil war actually you guys know more
about civil war than i do but you know
one of the things we look at the civil
war is we say boy this is one of those
wars where railroads matter
right from the very first battle we get
manassas we get troops getting delivered
by rails like oh it's a modern war we've
got railroads
well we got railroads
or rail road i think
in 1830 there it is the tom thumb
18
1830. it's exactly a year before nat
turner's revolt
okay
so we're not in the world of railroads
matt turner's world is not that world
i was supposed to do that
okay here's a map
of railroad
railroad construction in the united
states by decade
1830 there's nothing
i mean there's like three dots there's a
dot there by dc there's a dot
by south carol uh by charleston there's
two dots in pennsylvania so you know
that shows how advanced pennsylvania is
they're no
railroads there's no railroads
so that is now we want to remember that
there's there's there's a good deal more
isolation now of course by 1860 we're
going to have about 1850 but by 1860 the
nation's going to be crossed by
railroads well not crossed all the way
but 1867 it's going to be crossed all
the way railroad railroad construction
is going to explode
after nat turner but they don't know
that's coming
they don't know that that's coming
what they do have a sense that's coming
is cotton revolution
okay
obviously it's been cotton produced
forever okay but
in 1793 there's going to be a tremendous
increase in the availability of cotton
as we move from
just being able to produce
long staple cotton which can grow
basically in the sea isles of georgia
to being able to produce short staple
cotton which is going to open up cotton
production throughout the hinterland of
the south
and so cotton production is going to
boom
here's a map of cotton production top
one is
cotton production in 1820
bottom one is cotton production in 1860.
there's a tremendous amount of expansion
of cotton production and i mean just
keep in mind the 1790 picture of cotton
production is just some orange or red
right along the coast of south carolina
and georgia so there's been an
incredible expansion of cotton
now of course with the cotton production
hold on
with the cotton production sorry about
that with the cotton production
is going to come
slavery an incredible
i don't know what happened to myself i'm
going to jump ahead
okay i don't know where it is
this is what happens when you play with
your slides late at night
i'm just happy it's here you know i'm
sitting here saying okay got all these
nice slides hope they show up
okay
with cotton production we're going to
see an expansion of slaver and i'll show
you a map later on i think we'll see
what's in the slideshow later on you and
me both
we're going to see a slideshow we're
going to see the slideshow later on
showing how
the slave population is very much going
to follow
the
cotton production in america right i
mean we have the industrial revolution
happening
cotton is going to become the central
ingredient of it slavery is going to be
the main way that the staple of the
industrial revolution is produced
okay
so what does that mean well it means
something really important for slavery
okay
in
seven in the 1780s and 1790s slavery is
in retreat there's no doubt about it
right i mean pennsylvania is a free
state why because they abolish slavery
1780
someone help me here
80 or 81
80. okay there we go 80.
what
1833 what's 1833
no no no no no that's britain that's
britain um so
we're going to see massachusetts
pennsylvania of course the first one
that's going to abolish the slave trades
where's vermont
why is vermont the first one to abolish
the slave trade because they're a bunch
of pirates okay they're up in vermont
and they they want to make sure the new
yorkers who actually have slaves don't
bring their slaves on to establish their
claims to the land which are actually
much more solid claims to land
you know whatever anyway the point is
slavery is under which it's in retreat
and there's no doubt about this we're
going to say the great accomplishment of
the articles of confederation right
which couldn't figure out how to tax the
country it did figure out one thing
which was how to keep slaves out of the
northwest territories
right
you also have a constitution approved
that's going to end the slave trade in
america 20 years after its adoption
they didn't do it immediately that's
unfortunate but they did do it 20 years
later okay slavery is under but remember
1780s slavery isn't attractive in the
1780s you're going to see virginia
moving away from slavery it's going to
free up amen
manumission laws making it easier for
virginia to have
for virginia slaveholders to free their
slaves there's a movement away from
slavery and it makes sense in a way
because there is an insatiable demand
for slavery
with the cotton gym with the expansion
of the south is going to become
insatiable demand
and what you're going to see is you're
going to see a retreat in anti-slavery
right
here we have the
one of the great institutions of america
and i say that i don't know with italics
or quotes or whatever the american slave
the american colonization society think
about it we're not talking about ending
slavery we're talking about sending free
blacks away
manumitting blacks and sending them away
maybe it'll end up freeing slaves but
what is it mostly going to do the main
goal is a racist goal of trying to get
blacks out of the country
this is this is not
this is not anti-slavery
we of course have the missouri
compromise slavery appears on the
national stage what do we get
we get
slavery in missouri
right
yes there's a promise that slavery won't
go past 3630 but slavery's there
it's balanced slavery is part of
the country it's part of the world
and it's growing
now that's not to say that there aren't
opponents of slavery oh
one more thing the new york emancipation
law i mean think about this new york new
york can't even figure out how to
emancipate its own slaves it ends it
passes an emancipation law
as does new jersey
places with more slaves pass
emancipation laws that are gradual
places like massachusetts that are
poorer and don't have as many slaves
actually do and do things like get rid
of slavery immediately
but places like
new york which actually has a
small but significant slave population
is going to get rid of slavery by
abolishing it gradually which means
everyone born after 1800 is going to be
free when they're 21 or 25 right
but what about the people who was born
in 1799
going to be slaves forever
well forever for them for their whole
lives i mean after all as when when the
civil war starts new jersey is a slave
state right
there are still slaves in new jersey in
the 18
1860 census why because they never came
back and abolished slavery permanently
here we have new what is new york pass
it passes an emancipation law that says
in 1827
those people who were born before 1800
are going to be free
think about how small a step that is and
that's in new york this is not in
richmond this is not in charleston
this is not the kind of place where
slavery which did look threatened
everywhere
with the french revolution the haitian
revolution what was going on elsewhere
it looked really threatened in the 1780s
and 1790s by the 1820s
it seems like it's there to stay
it's stable
well that of course is going to lead
many people especially many black people
to go out and try to start up what we
now think of modern abolition you're
going to see the freedoms journal the
first black newspaper published in
america
published in new york published in the
united states published in new york
you're going to see david walker's
appeal
1829 calling for slaves to
fight for their freedom
of course in 1831 you're going to see
william lloyd's
william lloyd garrison's the liberator
okay so we see this movement
this movement to start abolition to
start realizing that there's got to be
something done to stop this institution
you know to get rid of it actively it's
not just going to wither and weigh and
die
slavery is something that seems to be
re-established and more firmly
established
even though we are in this age of
progress in this age of enlightenment
all right so that's 1831 that's 1831.
now
1833 in in england
abolitionism is having much more success
keep that in mind now this
reflects in part
english slavery is
is sli is sugar based not cotton based
it also reflects the fact that england
is not is is freeing slaves in its
colonies
um
primarily jamaica
so but
the thing i want you to keep in mind is
as there's movement against abel as
there's movement against slavery and as
there's abolition it doesn't happen
everywhere
and in america in southampton county
slavery seems strong
slavery seems strong and strong in ways
that i think maybe we don't always
imagine yes these things are happening
yes william lloyd garrison's printing up
his liberator they don't know about it
this stuff is starting up
but it's not it's slavery seems and
feels
permanent
and you can see this i think very well
in the average price of a slave over the
years before the civil war
what does this chart show
this chart shows
panics
panic uh uh booms and busts right there
you got the
i think this works
maybe it works maybe i don't know how to
use it
whatever but you see the peaks that's
1819 1837. these are the panics that
happen in the world economy it's you
know american economy but what do you
see the panics happen but slavery is
there and in fact if anything the price
of slaves are growing as you guys well
know the price of slaves in 1860 is
really at an all-time high in new
orleans
this is not an institution that seems
like it's going to leave
okay
well so point one slavery seems strong
point two what about southampton county
where is southampton county in this
growing world
well briefly
well where is southampton county
physically it's right there
on the map
you know about the bottom sort of south
of petersburg between petersburg and
norfolk on the north carolina border
here's a map and i'm not sure how well
it appears
it's sort of
hard to see um
this is uh this is the united states in
1830 and this shows the slave population
places in red
the red dots are roughly 50 or sort of
orange dots the middle one which is
south hampton county are roughly 50
percent slave
so there it is
here's the world okay we have lots of
slaves and you have to remember virginia
is a heart of slavery the cotton
expansion's happening and the cotton
boom's happening and the biggest
plantations which had been in south
carolina are going to move to places
like mississippi and alabama
mississippi more than alabama louisiana
and mississippi these these plantations
um don't ever change the fact that
virginia's the largest slave holding
state in the country in 1860
right
virginia's got an enormous slave
population
well if you're going to start a
rebellion you need to know something
about the demographics what are the
demographics in virginia
in virginia
whites outnumber slaves three to two
not propitious for slave revolt how
often does slavervolt succeed by the way
never is an okay answer haiti okay
haiti's full credit it doesn't happen it
doesn't it's very hard for a slave
revolt to succeed in history
is it going to succeed in virginia three
to two
boy that's that's going to be tough
that's going to be really really tough
but what about southampton county
southampton county actually has more
slaves than whites
so it's not
you know like
six guys it's not like the high
schoolers here are gonna like hey we're
gonna revolt and take over this thing
cwi it's us although that'd be sort of
cool i think i don't know um
no i mean it's it's there's there are a
lot of slaves in southampton county
there's a lot of slaves in southampton
county
um
i also want to go back to this map of
the cotton production
in 1820 you'll see the cotton production
actually this map shows the slight
cotton production actually extends up
into south hampton county which is true
it does there's slight cotton production
in southampton county not much but when
we see where it's going we know where
the slave production is going it's going
to go into the black belt it's going to
go along the mississippi river okay well
this is also going to play an important
role in the revolt why
well we're going to see the shift of the
slave population basically from the
coast
which is where it is in the 1830 map to
the mississippi river area
okay that's without
without taking the slave population away
from
the
from virginia virginia still has its
slave population it's just the growth in
the slave population happens in
in the west i mean important thing thing
you can't see what's the number of
slaves in the country in 1830 2 million
what's the number of slaves in the
country in 1860
4 million okay so there's been an
enormous growth in the slave population
in the country
but notice this
in southampton
the slaves
the sloth m
i don't want to get my numbers reversed
and i can't see it so that's okay um
southampton county's population is going
to go down why
because this is not a centerplace of
this is not a centerpiece of economic
growth remember cotton production is
going to be moving away
from southampton county
the whites are moving away but the
blacks are moving away even faster
how is that happening
it's the slave trade
okay now think about if the slave
population of southampton grew at the
same rate the slave population grew
elsewhere in the world what would happen
to the slave population between 1830 and
1860
it would double
so that 30 percent decline is
astonishing
it's really more like a it's really more
like a 65 percent decline
relative to the growth in the nation
states where is that population growth
going
it's going to mississippi louisiana and
georgia
it's going south okay important things
to keep in mind why
what induced the slaves to rebel
well one thing that may have induced
this well what induced the slaves to
rudolph
um
this may be one of the things
uh this is not my research and doesn't
even make it into my book but a guy
named david almandinger wrote a really
long book
um which had a great great provocative
question he asked so why did this uh why
what what happened why did they do it he
said one thing he found out was that the
day the week before nat turner announced
this revolt to his closest associates
his son
had been mortgaged
okay
now david allmendinger says well that
obviously proves that not turner did it
because he knew his son had been
mortgaged and
this was a response that
we don't know that
i think that's pretty darn reasonable i
think it's the right reading
you know that things happen for lots of
reasons but
you know might you revolt if you find
out that your son's been mortgaged a
deadbeat has mortgaged your son
and he's going to get sold away
you're never going to see him again
seems to me
not a bad reason to rebel
even even if it is against impossible
odds
all right
keep that in mind
keep that in mind now nat turner never
speaks about that and what i want to
talk about today
is not
these reasons you know not not not the
demographics and the continent which is
just i think the context for it but i
want to explore why the slaves are
rebelling
what induced the southampton
insurrection
at least as we see it in the record
follow the evidence and see what that
says
well
what induced the slaves to rebel matt
turner
who is nat turner
yeah
white's thought that nat turner was
crazy
he was a complete fanatic or places
parts more that most admirably says
thomas r gray and the confessions the
man who wrote down
matt turner's confessions which are
again to the high school students and to
any of you readily available online and
i encourage you to read it
one of the things my book does and i'm
not going to talk about this today is it
takes the confessions much more
seriously than anyone has the last 50
years
i make arguments about the reliability
of these confessions and my argument you
can read it if you want is that they're
actually they actually are what they say
they are which is basically what net
turner said
which makes them a really remarkable
remarkable source
and you can read them in about an hour
so
if you ever want to find out why not
turn around you don't actually just have
to listen to me you can go read it
online
anyway
thomas r gray thought he was a complete
fanatic newspaper reports said the same
thing
he's a preacher and a pretend prophet
this is who it is now of course this
fits in with a model of understanding
the slave revolts that has lasted it's
been an important part of our way of
understanding slave revolts
i mean when we look at
william styrens the confessions of nat
turner which came out in 1967 i expect
many people here have read
you know there he is he's still a
fanatic he's still a little crazy
you know that's that's who it is um
you know i i think there's a way in
which this has been one way of
understanding nat turner's revolt is by
saying it's just this crazy thing that
happened and that turner's sort of like
a jim jones figure
i don't think that's true i don't think
that's true and i don't think the
evidence actually supports i think the
evidence that thomas gray wrote
actually doesn't support that and i
don't think actually
i don't know if thomas r gray actually
believes it
so here we are we've got this how do we
understand that turner well if the one
view is that he's a fanatic the other
one is he's this heroic figure right
we see this in the if you've anyone seen
the new nat turner movie which again ken
greenberg and i saw together so that
may have been the entire audience i'm
not sure um birth of a nation did not do
well um in the theaters but it's a new
imagine it's a new understanding of what
happened in that turner's revolt
and it's sort of sort of he's completely
heroic right you know nat turner's the
hero he's the man who does great things
and this is not new in 2016. it goes
back here he is being the great preacher
and and the and the slaves are
enthralled
by nat turner's leadership
well that's not how it went down
and i want to tell you a little bit
about how it went down and just make a
couple comments along the way
to talk about how we have to rethink
about non-eternal rebellion because it
might actually make us rethink a little
bit
about how we think about slaves in this
civil war
all right unlike the last picture this
one's actually a little more accurate
the first deck is the conspiracy
what happens well
on 12 february 1831 there's the clips of
the sun which you can go
there's great websites you can actually
see the path of the eclipse of the sun
which basically almost goes through
southampton county
so it's a really awesome eclipse
and nat turner says in the confessions
and on the appearance of this uh the and
immediately the sign appearing in the
heavens the seal was removed from my
lips and was commun and i communicated a
great work laid out for me to do to four
in whom i am the greatest confidence
henry hark nelson and sam
here we are we got the eclipse
but the thing i find interesting about
this is
who did not turner tell when the seals
loosed from his lips
four
why four four's not a really great
number starter rebellion i think
i think more like 40 times four or four
million times four is a little better
why for
well
it's pretty clear
in the newspaper article investigating
this after the revolt found the rebels
decided not to tell more people because
the word always leaked out
now
raises an interesting question how did
they study the history of this and i
wish i knew
what are they thinking about i don't
know
but they did know their history enough
to know
that slave revolts are hard because what
do you have to do you have to have one
person get right what does ben franklin
say about a secret
like
three can keep a secret as long as one's
dead something like that you know i mean
this is not
this is not an easy thing to do a slave
rebellion's dangerous because all you
have to do is have one person get a
little bit queasy just like oh but
you're the one nice person i like just
don't hang around next sunday oh why not
boom okay
so slave rebellions are hard
now
do fanatics sit there and say hey i'm
only going to tell four people
now people who think about it
they're the ones he's being cagey he's
being smart
abraham lincoln knew abraham lincoln
knew as much at his at his cooper union
address
he said the same thing
the word leaks out
so is he a fanatic
well i mean if by fanatic you mean
religious person yeah maybe i guess
okay
but you know i'm not sure he's fanatic
in the sense that i think the sense when
people say fanatic they mean a lot more
than that
so here he is with his four
comments telling them about the plan
let's set up a plan how do you set up a
slave revolt okay given
let's start with the two premises i have
one is he's not crazy okay and two is uh
slaves are out of whites outnumber
slaves three to two in virginia how do
you do a slave revolt hmm by the way if
you can answer this please come to the
microphone at the end and tell us and
you're not allowed to use zombies in
your answer
yeah it's hard it's hard it's not
obvious i mean i've got a phd i've
thought about it i don't know how you do
it it's not clear
of course i have a phd means i probably
couldn't start a slave revolt even if i
wanted to hey guys
talk to the hand no there's a there's a
there's a
you know what are they going to do well
one thing is they came up with the idea
of starting on july 4th i think another
really meaningful moment
why july 4th
july 3rd is a great day
july 15th gives you nine more days to
plan why july 4th
wasn't it obvious
july 4th is a meaningful date
it's a date there was a document that
was signed sort of famously i don't know
if you guys have heard of it
announces that all men are created equal
just remember that's not the
constitution that's the declaration of
independence you'll get full credit in
college
okay
all men are created equal it's political
now but i find this really interesting
right how many people are involved in
the revolt at this point
five
okay what are they doing
they're saying let's put we're thinking
about this revolt in political terms now
isn't that turner thinking about the
revolt in political terms
is he thinking about it like frederick
douglass does
no i don't think so
i think he is religious
right and in fact when they say july 4th
comes around what actually happens this
is this is what he says it was intended
by us to have begun the work of death on
july 4th last many were the plans formed
and rejected by us and it affected my
mind to such a degree that i fell sick
and the time passed without our coming
to any determination of how to commence
he got worried
okay again another sign he's not crazy
right okay we're going to go die why are
you going to die because god wants me to
die okay and so what are you going to do
you're going to start on july 4th
not so sure
he wasn't confident oh i get that you
want me to join a slave rebellion not
going to do it
like hold on i got a 401k
no not doing it
they don't have the same things but they
have the same worries
at least one of the same words they're
going to die
now
do you want to die no do you want to die
in this political war
no
okay well this is i think really
meaningful moment why because nat turner
doesn't see it in a political term a
world
in a political framework he sees in a
religious framework which is fine i
don't have a problem with that
but what does that mean his group is
expanded to five people total and
they're already looking at the revolt
differently
some people are seeing this like like
um frederick douglass
some people are seeing this as a
political move
and this is i think one of the really
important lessons that we need to pass
along to the civil war to the civil war
scholars and the civil war and the
students of the civil war is it you know
people do things for different reasons
okay
and it doesn't mean
you know you don't want to sit there and
say they did it for one reason they did
it for another reason
that means they didn't they like slave
or something stupid like that you don't
want to say that but you do want to be
open to the differences in views of
people
not turner's expanding it too what's the
other thing this means
if there's differences between five
people are these people following that
turner blindly
no they've got their own interpretations
yeah they're going to join the revolt
why because they want to
well
what did give comp nat turner the
confidence that it was time to begin a
new sign
what was the sign
the sun appeared blue
okay now i'm not one who's sort of into
reading harbingers in the skies but i
mean i must say that would make me think
twice
okay yeah
all right that's a little weird
and now if you are everyone must have
done look this is time to begin all
right so the revolt begins what do they
do
here's the map of the area of st luke's
parish where the revolt is going to take
place they're going to start at joseph
travis's house joseph travis is the man
who is nat turner's owner um not his
owner his
guardian of his owner his onion's a
six-year-old
anyway and they're going to set out and
follow this path to
towards jerusalem
okay
so what did they do
they start squabbling in the yard of
joseph travis about who's gonna who's
gonna hit first nat turner said you guys
are all talking about how you guys are
gonna cut people's heads off time to
begin let's go do it they're like
you begin first why
well because they didn't trust him
they didn't trust they didn't they
wanted to make sure he couldn't walk
away and wash his hands and say i didn't
i don't know what they're talking about
those guys are crazy
if you take a swing
everyone knows that you're gonna die
okay
again these people weren't following
that turner blindly
they weren't his disciples
so what do they do
they go in and they kill
the travis family
and then they jump um slay theo francis
and these pictures some of these
pictures are from the wpa which are the
actual pictures from a hundred years
later of the farms and this is slathio
fans francis's farm which is just really
a shack
here it is they knock on the door they
say hey come on out we got a message for
you
grab him kill him
so the revolt begins initially taking
advantage of surprise
then
in the morning they start going quickly
they get horses and they start moving
this is on the swing back
okay they go to katherine whitehead's
house and
peter edwards and richard porter's and
on their way to new terraces
there's nine by this point in the
morning there's nine on horseback and
six are walking
and they're making their way back
towards jerusalem
when they get to catherine whitehead's
plantation which is a bigger plantation
that turner's going to end up killing
the only person he kills
which is margaret whitehead
there's lots been made of this as this
graphic novel picture makes and william
styron made a tremendous amount of this
i think the explanation for this is a
little simpler
matt turner was just
that turner was riding in the back like
a general and he saw margaret whitehead
escape and he had a little sword and his
sword didn't kill anyone and he tried to
kill her with it so he took a fence post
and bludgeoned her to death
but then
so they're going as fast as they can
killing as many people as they can and
then in the morning on monday morning
they realize that they'd been discovered
so what do they do they re nat turner
reassembles the group
he sits there and says i've got two
divided wings which makes sense if
you're going as fast as possible the
ones on horseback are going faster than
the ones at foot
and then he says oh we've been detected
let's bring them together so that we're
going to be able to to fight back
against whatever response comes in for
us
so once they realize the word has spread
once they come to plantations that have
been abandoned
they come together and they come
together at the harris plantation
and they're up to about 40 slaves at
this point
and they're all excited about what is
happening
um
as they make their way towards rich uh
richmond towards jerusalem they're going
to have a um
they're going to have they're going to
attack a schoolhouse which is on levi
waller's farm and they're going to kill
women and children actually the men on
the farm levi waller and the school
teacher escape
which of course will be a big thing as
people look
and tell the stories about the brutality
ultimately they make it to about a mile
away from jerusalem to uh
parker's gate where they have a battle
here's a still of the battle from birth
of a nation the 2016 movie
the battle doesn't have i should say the
battle doesn't actually happen anything
like this it's just complete mess up i
mean you guys who do civil war know this
stuff better than i do i mean imagine
this it's a battle between two sides
none of whom know anything about what
they're doing
right everything goes wrong it's a it's
a complete disaster and in fact nat
turner doesn't even know what happened
when he's captured a couple months later
he still doesn't know what happened that
day the revolt has taken place but as it
turns out
nat turner's army which was about 40
guys drinking ends up
beating chasing off the field a small
group of about a dozen whites who had
who had sort of happened upon them but
they ran into another group of whites
who heard the sounds of the battle and
they
dispersed nat turner and his men
the next day the revolt falls apart
people disperse it's just a mess and
there's going to be tremendous amounts
of um
uh you know this the the county is going
to be up in arms what happens to nat
turner though
that turner escapes
and for the next two months nat turner
is away
until mid-october now i want to just
draw you this i'm going to sort of close
with this but i want to draw your
attention to what happens here when he's
discovered i think this is one of the
underappreciated lines that happens in
the confessions
um two negroes having started to go
hunting past the way where his cave was
and the dog came out again to the place
the dog a couple days before had found
some food that nat turner had hidden in
his in his hiding space
and having gone to walk about and
discovered me and barking i spoke to
them to beg concealment on making myself
known they fled from me it's a really
sort of astonishing moment
what happens here
well that turner's ned turner's like
okay some blacks are out hunting with
their dog in the middle of the night and
i'm like hold on blacks are out hunting
in southampton on october 15th
less than two months what's going on
this doesn't make sense
after the revolt the revolt was quickly
put down and in fact the immediately
after the revolt the whites in charge
realized that the great danger was not
from the blacks who were put who were
put down in about a day or two the great
danger to the slaveholders was from the
whites because there was nothing they
could do
if regular whites decided that they
wanted to kill all the blacks they came
across
and so martial law was passed to
southampton counter it or it was ordered
in southampton county and
uh the the the county was really
the the um the fighting was really um
the the repercussions against the black
community was really much much less than
people had thought
now so
why why well because the slaveholders
needed to protect their property
that's what happened so now turner's
found he's discovered the black he knows
immediately that these are blacks who
are not going to
hide him but are going to betray him and
he's eventually going to lead a couple
more weeks of hiding out but they're
chasing him at this point they know
where he is and they discover him
when he's finally captured
and then gives what is one of the great
documents in american history the
confessions of nat turner now
that's a really quick telling of a thing
that i wrote a little longer book but
what do i want to tell you guys about it
i mean i think one thing we got to do is
we gotta be really careful about
thinking about sort of slavery as this
you know
simple answer
slavery is a very complex institution
okay and it's going to lead people to
respond to it in different ways and the
ending of slavery is going to be a very
complex event
in the civil war and people are going to
respond to it in different ways some
people are immediately going to be like
frederick douglass going to be political
some people are going to be worried
about their families some people are
going to be worried about are going to
see this in a religious framework
some people are going to be worried
about their lives
right there's going to be lots of
different responses
and and we need to be aware in the way
that the historical moment creates
opportunities last night at gary
gallagher's talk which was a great talk
gary gallery was like you know we got to
remember freedom follows the union army
and i think that's a really important
point because you want to think about
the relationship of
events to moments and one thing you
notice within the slave community is
people there are not a lot
of
slaves who are going out and saying well
this you know i'm going to do this no
matter what i mean there are certainly
some of those
but what you have is a lot of people
making decisions based on what they
think is the best way going forward
not knowing what the future is going to
bring
and that's how nat turner worked and
that's sort of the story i tried to tell
my book
thank you
so we have time for questions i think
the way it works here is if anyone has a
question they can come up to a
microphone
hi kurt carlson from illinois question
for you is
do you think or to what degree do you
think that
the
fear
of
the slaves among white southerners
how that played into their
fighting in the civil war and the
post-war
um
anti-reconstruction you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah
a great question um
i i think the
[Music]
well first i think the fear i mean i
think the fear is overrated just the
idea that slave holders are immediately
afraid
it doesn't i mean you know when i see
evidence that blacks are out hunting two
months after slavery in the middle of
the night blacks are out
probably not with guns probably with
dogs but
out hunting i mean that's astonishing
and so i don't want to just immediately
turn to the fear because there's
i think fear is a very powerful emotion
and it's certainly one that a lot of
people were afraid after nat turner's
revolt uh a lot of the people were
afraid that the leaders who declared
martial law and prohibited whites from
killing
blacks indiscriminately the slaveholders
who did that a lot of whites in
southampton county were upset at that
decision
and so they sent
a
letter
to
andrew jackson saying we actually need
support these guys here aren't taking
this seriously enough don't you realize
that every house has one of these
potential killers in it right all these
houses with slaves they're slave holders
every there's slaves everywhere
who could be killed who could just you
know
kill us any time we want we're
completely defenseless against this type
of attack
so there are people who are afraid but
there are also people whose fear is
different and i think for the
slaveholders and i think
in in the civil war and certainly in
reconstruction one of the fears the
slaveholders have is not the fear that
they're going to get their heads cut off
in the middle of night i mean obviously
some people have that
but one fear they have is that they're
not going to be able to control the
black population
they have complete control of the black
population under slavery and you're
going to see
the you know they're like hold on what
do we need to do to control the black
population now the interesting thing is
in reconstruction the fear of blacks
plays into social control right they
drum up oh a black's raping a white
woman and then they go out and kill a
bunch of blacks and sort of make sure
that blacks stay in their place or don't
vote or do whatever
in
matt turner's world the fear isn't done
the fear doesn't work that way the fear
of uh
of the slaveholders is that if we get so
afraid of people of blacks killing
whites there's nothing that can be done
i mean think about this what do you do
if you go up and shoot a black person in
1831 yeah i'm scared
okay so they take you to they take you
to the channel and they indict you
indict you for murder which you can get
you can get indicted for murdering a
slave
okay and then you go what to a grand
jury
i said well i thought he was a slave i
thought it was nat turner he's lost you
know
there's no way you're getting there's no
way you're getting convicted so the fear
the slave holders have is that they're
going to lose control of slave property
and i think that that's something we
have to keep in mind i think the
emotional stuff is very easily used
and very easy to document and talk about
but i think there's a way that we have
to think about how
there's a fear of um there's a fear of
losing social control
thank you
al mackey from mechanicsburg
pennsylvania uh what we have for
for the confessions real is nat turner
as
interpreted to us through gray how do
you
as a historian filter out
gray's point of view
so that you can get to
nat turner
well great question actually when the
project began
uh basically my start was to say
this is a this is a
all these historians who've been working
the last 50 years say nat turner gray
messes it up somehow and we don't know
where and we don't know how and then you
get historians saying things like well i
hear nat turner's voice here like what
how do you know that and so i was gonna
just be more methodical and say this is
all gray until we hear otherwise
and then as i pushed on it and pushed on
it i began to realize that there's a lot
in the confessions that suggest that
it's not great i mean one of the things
is gray puts in introductory things
where he tells his point of view he also
puts in parenthetical comments where he
tells his point of view so you can see
where their viewpoints are different and
gray's viewpoints of the revolt are
different from nat turner's and you know
and so one of the things it
there's many reasons but i've come to
see this as a more reliable account the
part in the middle that would be in
quotes i don't think it's an exact
translation but i think it's pretty
close
it's so um
you know that's something one of the
reasons why there was a great explosion
of scholarship on that turner after
william styron's uh
novel came out in 1967
and basically everyone would grab
uh whatever they wanted from the
confessions and use it willy-nilly to
support their position sort of ignoring
that that question about the reliability
of it and and then when that burnt
itself out no one wanted to touch the
confessions
and i i think that when i came back to
it the idea is i think you can basically
read it as not a production of thomas r
gray i mean it's pretty clear he's
written this within three days of the
capture of nat turner it's also pretty
clear that he hadn't written it before
nat turner had been captured
and i mean ultimately yeah he's going to
put editorials in he's going to mess up
but it's basic and he might use language
differently i don't know i mean we don't
it's not a video recording but
i think it's a fairly accurate account
of nat turner's confessions and i think
it's well worth listening to the voice
of nat turner in it
hi riley neubauer from new york city i
was wondering
what the extent was the extent to which
the killing of women and children
influenced the negative feelings of
turner because it seems to be one thing
to kill like people but another thing to
attack an innocent schoolhouse it just
seems much more violent there's a great
story and thank you for that question
there's a great story about this
obviously this is a bridge too far and
it's still a bridge too far you've got a
law professor still writing about well
okay it makes sense he's a slave you
know it's you're justified and and
fighting back and to fight back you're
gonna kill people and okay but you know
there's this moment where at the first
house they go back and they slay an
infant sleeping in the cradle
that infant wasn't gonna get up and go
sound the alarm
okay i mean that's you know so it's like
really and this was actually something i
think it's fairly clear that they talked
about
the rebel rebels and there was one point
of view which is like we should kill
everyone and just scare the jesus out of
the whites
and
show the blacks that we're not we're
really we're not afraid of anything
and another point of view and i think
this is probably not turner's point of
view which is well we should probably
kill the men and maybe we have to kill
the women too because they can actually
run even if they're not going to fight
but
you know nat turner
but nat turner loses that that argument
i think i'm not sure about that i'm not
sure which side he's on in it but they
go out and kill women and children and
women and children then becomes this
huge rallying cry as you saw from that
cartoon oh the women and children these
guys are savages of course no one's
thinking about the way that slaveholders
treat women and children in slavery you
know not not it's not there but
admit it even leaving that to the side
it becomes a great rallying cry after
the revolt people who are pushing
against slavery and this is another
thing i don't talk about in nearly
enough in the book but other scholars
have
after the revolt virginia is seriously
talking about ending slavery right they
have it they have a there are proposals
at the virginia legislature that gets
serious consideration that they should
adopt gradual emancipation remember that
wave of emancipation that had stopped
you know around 1804 in new jersey
there's a movement to get that wave of
emancipation going again and so there's
a debate and during that debate
there are petitions from women and
children
saying well we don't want to become
involved in politics because that's not
our role but this is a political
question that connects to our very
safety and so we want slavery to end and
so there's actually a series of three
petitions that had been written by women
and one was written by a man
who
signed it as a woman and then had the
women of augusta county sign it in the
voice of women saying protect us now it
didn't ultimately succeed the ab the
people who are moving for gradual
emancipation virginia lost but it's
really a powerful moment and the
supporters of gradual emancipation
thought that they could use it to
support their argument against slavery
two last questions thank you
good morning sir my name is tobin brown
i'm from cape cod massachusetts so my
question is
in related to malcolm x actually during
the civil rights movement so because the
south hardened down um on slavery and
restricted education religious freedom
and implemented harsher laws and slaves
in response to the aggressive slave
rebellion not turner's rebellion um how
do you think america would have
responded to malcolm x had he been more
successful in leading um more aggressive
revolts and perhaps even killing uh more
white people in the name of civil rights
instead of mlk's peaceful
approach to
um change right america
great great question i mean you know
malcolm x is really one of those um
endearing figures and you know what
would he think and i think one of the
things we got to be careful of is sort
of saying like we gotta really
historicize these things and quick
malcolm x is uh many different people i
mean you know if you look at the the the
relatively new biography of malcolm x
the reinvention of uh
reinventing a life
you see that these guys change over time
and you want to be careful not to sort
of say that there's one solid thing i
want to i want to contextualize and so
malcolm x there's points at which he's
really looking as he's really trying to
he is trying to scare people he is
talking a big game in terms of violence
and such um you know and there's also
times when he's going to be moving in
different directions and so you don't
want to i mean malcolm x had many
different positions on race and you
don't want to just assume that there's
one position and one thing you want to
sort of historicize it oh thank you
thank you last question
hi i'm pat aiken from the seattle
washington area
and my question is about the book
confessions of nat turner well way back
in 1960 i was a
young child a boy and my older brother
in high school and my mother were having
a discussion about whether or not the
book confesses that turner should be
assigned in high school or if high
school kids should read it or if it was
too controversial
and so i was always curious what was so
controversial about that look that
well it's pretty easy to answer the
controversy about it initially it went
out and won the pulitzer prize it got
great great um great initial notices the
there's a couple problems with it
that were brought up this is 1967 the
book is written one is it's a white
southerner writing the story of
america's most famous
black slave in the first person and he's
speaking for him and he's making him a
little crazy and making him flawed and
you know and he thinks william styron
argues he's humanizing him
but a lot of black power activists guys
not malcolm x he's he's dead by this
point but guys like stokely carmichael
are saying you can't do that
the other thing is that the center of
the story becomes the story of the
killing of margaret whitehead
and he and
william styron sees that as really
psychologically important he doesn't
think that he killed margaret whitehead
per chance he thinks it's really
meaningful that this is the only person
he killed and so what he ends up telling
the story is nat turner actually loved
and hated
margaret whitehead which is evoking a
hundred years of racist historiography
where we have the black rapist right nat
turner america's mo you know a hero
black hero is becoming uh someone who's
lusting after white women and that
becomes something that's a bridge too
far so those are the two
big issues that set off the debate in
the 60s all right thank you so much for
your attention
all right you all we have about 10
minutes we'll come back uh and i will be
speaking about a hoosier couple at war
see you just before 11 o'clock thank you
so
so
you're watching live coverage of the
gettysburg college civil war institute
summer conference here on c-span 3's
american history tv
after the break we'll be back with peter
carmichael every weekend on c-span 3.
to join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
next on american history tv
historian kenneth s greenberg discusses
historical portrayals of nat turner the
african-american leader of an 1831 slave
rebellion in virginia he describes the
competing accounts of turner's rebellion
discusses misconceptions about slavery
and looks at methods used by slaves to
resist their masters
mr greenberg also talks about the
consequences of the rebellion for other
slaves in the south
this event was part of the university of
mary washington's great lives lecture
series
so when it comes to tonight's subject
greenberg is the editor of nat turner a
slave rebellion in history and memory
and the editor of the confessions of nat
turner and related documents he was also
part of the team that wrote and produced
the pbs film nat turner a troublesome
property indeed so as i said you are in
very good hands tonight ladies and
gentlemen it's my pleasure to introduce
to you kenneth s greenberg
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's a great great pleasure to be
here when i left boston this morning it
was snowing my plane had to be de-iced
but
i arrived in paradise this is a lovely
place i've never been to the campus
before and you have an absolutely
gorgeous campus and
town is is wonderful as well the my
hosts have been extremely gracious so
this has been a completely pleasant
experience
and my subject matter is
about one of the most difficult subjects
in american history there's a
controversy every step of the way and uh
and battles every step of the way in
terms of all the people who have
tried to write about nat turner and what
i thought i would do tonight
is to
tell you well first i'm going to sort of
tell you about
my own history with writing about nat
turner and thinking about nat turner
and then
uh it covers actually a fair amount of
territory and then i want to uh just
zero in on a few areas in more detail
so let me begin by describing
a couple things well first of all when i
was in graduate school
i first encountered nat turner because
we had assigned in class a document
called the confessions of matt turner
i'm curious in this
group how many of you have read the
confessions of nat turner the original
confessions of nat turner not styron's
the original confessions 1831.
how many of you have read the styron
novel the confessions of nat turner oh
that's quite interesting okay but i'll
be talking about that as well
okay the original confessions of nat
turner styron took the same the same
title
so uh i'll describe the rebellion a
little later on in the talk but
basically after nat turner was captured
he eluded capture for about two months
and after he was captured he was briefly
in jail uh uh and tried very very
quickly uh and then uh during that
period of the trial a few days a man
named thomas r gray a white southerner
who was a lawyer not not turner's lawyer
but that another but had actually been a
lawyer for several of the other
defendants
interviewed him in his jail cell
and then after his execution a couple
weeks after his execution
gray published a document called the
confessions of nat turner
it's an amazing document we have nothing
like it
in all of american history because
people who were rebels against slavery
didn't get interviewed they didn't write
things right there's no record where you
can hear their voices directly now the
thing about the confessions of nat
turner is the 1831 confessions is
you can't hear nat turner's voice
directly either
it's thomas r gray who put it together
from the interviews okay so this makes
it one of the great puzzling documents
for historians it is both the only thing
we have like it which has somewhere in
it in that turner's voice on the other
hand it's filtered through thomas r gray
and that's the puzzle that's why
students have
thought about this and tried to figure
out how to sort out the two voices that
are in nat turner so that really piqued
my interest when i was in graduate
school and i said one day i would like
to
to get back to it and as you just heard
i'm the editor of that original
confessions of nat turner i put it
together with in that book with
newspaper accounts
with trial record uh and other documents
of the period to give people the sense
of uh of the whole rebellion basically
but the confessions is really the heart
of the matter and i wrote the
introduction to it where i've tried to
puzzle out you know how can you tell
what's nat turner's voice and what isn't
that turner's voice it's very very
difficult and by the way if you want to
describe a central issue that everybody
grapples with is matt turner it's the
question of voice how you how can you
reconstruct the voice of someone who was
so
buried so deeply obliterated by the
culture that that ended up hanging him
it's pretty extraordinary so that's
that's the puzzle that's sort of sitting
there
then when i was also in graduate school
uh i read the william styron novel uh
and as for those of you who don't know
styron wrote a novel he'd actually was
interested in writing the novel he's
from virginia and when he was in high
school he actually passed a little
roadside sign near cortland virginia
which
was the town of jerusalem became
cortland but
that's near where the rebellion took
place and he remembers being on the bus
uh seeing a roadside sign which made a
reference to the nat turner rebellion
and ultimately it sort of stuck in the
back of his head in the 1960s he decided
to come back to this topic and to write
a novel and uh in it's a very
interesting novel it's called the
confessions of nat turner and uh
what he said what he thought he was
going to do was to
since
so little is known about turner what he
said was i will follow the historical
record in my novel
and then where the record doesn't speak
to an issue i'm going to use my
imagination to fill in the blanks
so again
in an odd way it sort of replicates
another version of the thomas gray
situation where you have uh the voice of
a white writer trying to funnel nat
turner and it includes nat turner's
voice somewhere in there
that styron was trying to do that was
his intention at least and then um
[Music]
he imagined many things and understood
he was imagining many things which he
thought were plausible about slavery
that novel
was greeted
uh by the by the general public and by
the critics like few american novels
ever got greeted i mean the the the the
the reviews go back and read the reviews
if you want you want to see something
amazing writer after writer reviewer
after reviewer famous american writer
write about this as the great american
novel finally written this was in 1967
and uh and siren won the pulitzer prize
for writing that novel
but almost from the beginning
there were black critics and some white
critics as well who understood the novel
as deeply flawed and ultimately racist
at its core
and they began to write each other john
henrik clarke was the leader of the
group of black writers who were in touch
with each other
and um ultimately they wrote a
collection of essays 10 essays basically
published by bricon press and it was
called william styron's nat turner 10
black writers respond and what they did
was they looked at the novel and they
pointed out the ways in which it got
history wrong that turned that uh styron
wasn't right about the history but also
its its deep racism now what kinds of
things did they point to
uh things like um
the in the confessions of nat turner nat
turner makes reference to his
grandmother his father
uh and uh
and they're simply left out of this this
novel uh uh also there's a scene where
nat turner's mother is raped again this
is styron's invention but she seems to
enjoy the rape by a white overseer uh
this this caught caught the eye of the
critics
and then and that turner is full of
hatred of of blacks in the you know he
had sort of adopted some of the ideas
that he was getting from the white
community and uh makes references that
are nasty references to
african-americans enslaved but i think
the heart of the thing which the the
black critics pointed to was the fact
that
matt turner lusts after a young and
beautiful white teenager a woman named
margaret whitehead we know from the
historical record that nat turner
personally killed only one person in the
rebellion margaret whitehead
that's all we know that that that
killing was the case what styron did was
he imagined and thought he could
legitimately imagine well who was
margaret whitehead
what was their relationship why was she
the one person that nat turner killed
and so he he imagined this relationship
but it was full of lust he he has rape
fantasies about margaret whitehead
ultimately he kills her with a sword and
a fence rail which is described in the
confessions briefly that way
um
and so the black critic said what's this
all about you know in the history of
race in america the fantasy that black
men
are out or lusting after white women is
one of the
terrible fantasies it's a white fantasy
it's actually
a flip of the reality which was it was
white men in slavery raping black women
that was the heart of what was going on
but but especially after the civil war
uh there are these fantasies that whites
have that blacks are threatening white
women and that's the heart of what what
lynching is all about we have these
terrible lynchings all over the south of
black men accused of
raping white women
most of which were simply non-existent
whatsoever but then terrible public
lynchings
as you know that we have lots of
photographs that get taken people
are whites are have have postcards made
they have postcards made of themselves
next to a
a blinch african-american
and they would send these postcards to
their friends it was an amazing moment
in the culture all centered around black
men lusting after white women and all of
a sudden here you have
this
nat turner who by the way the historical
record has no reference to this
whatsoever this is completely coming
from william styron's imagination and
the black critic says what's this all
about you're taking a black hero and
turning him into something that we know
is a white
fantasy so that that was an object of
tremendous amount of criticism and then
there was uh styron made another choice
too he decided to tell his story in the
voice of nat turner
so
uh you know the original confessions
actually has two voices in it there's
thomas r gray and then there's also
uh nat turner's voice now again
reporting to be north nat turner's voice
okay those two things are in there
so what happened was this is a really
interesting side note to this story but
james baldwin one of the great
african-american thinkers of the 1960s
was became a friend of william styrens
styron actually invited baldwin he knew
baldwin was a struggling writer at that
time needed a place to stay styron had a
place uh in western uh connecticut
westin massachusetts the town of roxbury
and it was a small rural house and next
to it was a converted
barn which was a studio he invited james
baldwin to live there and baldwin would
do his writing in the in the studio and
styron would do his writing in the house
and at night they would come together
and get drunk together i mean they have
a grand old time and then styron would
invite in his his neighbors many of them
were white liberals from the community
and baldwin you know if you've ever seen
baldwin in action uh he's an
extraordinary man and his anger was
fiery uh and he was brilliant and he
frightened all of styron's friends but
nonetheless he liked styron and styron
liked him and so as
as siren was getting underway with
writing the confessions of nat turner it
was baldwin who said why don't you be
bold i write in the voice of white
people all the time and you should be
bold and write in the voice of this
black man. and styron said okay and he
would also he thought of it at least at
one point he thought of it as
complementary to to turner that he would
you know take turner seriously enough
and he's a great writer and so forth
well in the eyes of the black critics as
they looked at this they said you've
appropriated matt turner's voice
and you've taken the voice of a great
black leader and you've turned it
not into his voice but into your voice
and that became a tremendous object of
criticism so this became
one of the great racial controversies of
its time in some ways at the among
intellectuals but but even extending
beyond that this was
like the o.j simson case of a later time
where whites and blacks and it largely
broke down in terms of whites and blacks
but not totally uh
nonetheless
they all looked at this and styren uh
siren's novel
was under attack and i got to know
styron later on and i can tell you that
this controversy he he always felt
misunderstood i never felt appreciated
and uh and the black critics who i also
got to know when i did my film we
interviewed styron and interviewed the
black critics as well
and
i was interviewing them in the year 2000
they were referring back to events that
happened in 1967.
i can tell you when you listen to every
one of them it's as if it happened the
day before the anger was as intense as
it was in 1967
uh the miss
and the clash and by the way i got to
tell you my own opinion styron was a
perfectly nice guy he never understood
however
the
the race issue that he was dealing with
you know this was the time in the late
1960s when black power was coming into
uh into the four and uh here nat turner
was one of the heroes uh of one of the
black heroes that that that
african-americans who were the most
militant would would point to uh as a
great leader and
styron simply many of them said you've
emasculated a great a great man there
was there was a lot of anger and the
anger persisted that never healed
uh
you know styron's now dead a few years
but it never healed for styron it never
healed for the black critics either so
anyway that's another piece of
my connection to nat turner reading that
reading the controversy getting immersed
in it and then later on when i did a
film about matt turner which i'll come
come back to in a little bit but uh i uh
i got to meet all the people involved
and got to know them all quite well and
a lot of
great intellectuals involved in this in
this movement baldwin himself by the way
he was invited to become one of the 10
black writers
it was going to be 12 black writers at
one point and baldwin said
no i don't want to do it. and in fact if
you pick up the novel today styron's
novel there is only one blurb on the
back of that novel and it's from james
baldwin and it says he has
written the
begun to write the common history hours
that's a paraphrasing basically but he
saw it as a great intellect racial novel
but i know he he was friendly with all
the black critics and knowing baldwin's
intellect he understood the nature of
their criticism
and he simply didn't want to publicly
ever come out to criticize his friend
william styron so that's a complicated
story
okay and then um
the next time i came across nat turner
now it's a long period of connections
was i wrote a book called honor and
slavery it's the book with a very very
very long subtitle that you you heard
and it was about southern honor that's a
whole other story which is an amazing
story about
southern gentlemen thought of themselves
as having honor they thought of
african-american enslaved people as
not having honor basically there's a lot
of things that go along with with what
southern honor meant
but just a small piece of that i was
interested in the way dead bodies were
treated you know when someone died who
was considered to be a man of honor the
body itself was honored in various ways
and so i
i
as part of a larger argument i looked at
two examples of the way dead bodies were
treated one was john brown
i tried to pick actually was john brown
and nat turner two people okay i asked
myself the question okay what happened
to their bodies how were they treated
exactly
and here's something amazing that i
discovered at that point
uh there was a kind of uh of course john
brown who led the
that was an attempt to lead a slave
rebellion and led the raid on harper's
ferry was deeply hated by white
southerners as another person who was
going to lead a slave rebellion just
before the the civil war broke out so he
was clearly a hated figure but i got to
tell you if you read
the words of white southerners as they
discuss brown
is very common underneath the surface a
grudging kind of admiration
every once in a while they'd say things
like you know lunatic maniac and so
forth but here's a guy
who knew how to die here's a guy who
wasn't afraid to die so there are
descriptions often that he's holding one
dying child in an arm and he's got a gun
in the other and he's fighting to the
end or there were descriptions of his
execution edmund ruffin a white
southerner who wanted to to watch the
execution actually he was a
uh an
elderly gentleman by the by that period
of time but he
got uh got his friends who were cadets
in the
in the military to admit him and he wore
you know a uniform and got in there and
could watch the execution and you read
his description of john brown's death
and he admires the man he said the guy
went bravely to his death he's d didn't
twitch as he was dying you could that's
the language you would use for someone
who was a man of honor and i'm not
saying they thought brown was a man of
honor they hated brown
but they had kind words somehow mixed in
in kind imagery
now what happened to nat turner's body
well if you read
the newspaper accounts of the period
they're they're very sparse there's only
two accounts but one of them says
that
he sold matt turner sold his body
uh
for ginger cakes in exchange for ginger
cakes he sold his body to the doctors
for dissection
he did it for ginger cakes
so when i first read that i said what
what is that all about you know i i deal
in a world but you can't trust anything
you read
okay
uh
and uh so i figured what's going on so
here's a guy after all matt turner
didn't own his body when he was alive
why would someone pay him in ginger
cakes to have possession of his body
which he didn't own
after he died what's that all about
exactly this is some white writer the
only explanation is some white writer
who wants to insult matt turner it's the
same writer who said hardly anybody came
to his execution as if it wasn't an
important event i can tell you this was
the most important event in virginia
history up until the civil war there
were mobs outside the courthouse during
the trial for example and you had to
call the militia out to control the mobs
so the fact that this same writer who
says he sold his body for ginger cakes
that can't possibly be the case and it
also is the same guy who says hardly
anybody was at his execution of course
this is all speculation it's true but
that's my world welcome
but he was certainly dissected in fact
in 1900
william s drury who was a white
southerner who wrote wrote about nat
turner uh and he was a professional
historian it's the sort of the
beginnings of professional history going
on
but he was also uh
from southampton county so he he
actually interviewed people who were
alive at the time of nat turner who had
memories and also their children as well
he had a lot of knowledge
but it was a deeply racist description
of nat turner that he gave but in 1900
here's what he wrote that turner's body
was delivered to the doctors who skinned
it and made grease of the flesh
his skeleton was for many years in the
possession of dr massenburg but has
since been misplaced
that's another one which should give you
pause
misplacing that turner skeleton what's
that about exactly i don't know what
it's about okay you can you can take
that one
all right but it doesn't seem likely to
me
but this um
uh then there were rumors in the county
after
after 1900 even before that his skin
when he was skinned was turned into a
money purse
and uh when i did my film about
the nat turner rebellion i spent a lot
of time in southampton county and i got
to tell you this is a place where of
course i saw no body parts okay
but everybody was talking about
just like uh massenburg did you know
someone else has these body parts and so
forth and there was even one person said
that
oh yeah there's somebody down the street
who has a lampshade
made of nat turner's skin
so because whenever i tried to find this
it you know disappeared somehow and also
this was after world war ii you know
lampshades were connected to the
extermination of jews and turning their
skin into lampshades there were stories
like that that came out of world war ii
and there was no story like that before
so i figured they just they're talking
about nat turner body parts whether or
not they actually exist this is
as gruesome as it gets and it's the
epicenter of
the evil of race relations in america
well
uh i also met a man there who's a
wonderful man he's the keeper of the i
describe him as the keeper of the
african-american folk memory of the
rebellion and a scholar of the rebellion
as well even though not formally trained
as a historian
and his name is james mcgee in fact when
you buy my book about nat turner the
edited book he did the painting on the
cover of that of that book it's a
wonderful painting you'll see
but anyway he told me that he has a
memory from 1949
he was a school kid at that time
but he said that time was the
uh
300th anniversary i think of the
founding of of southampton county and
they had a big celebration in 49 this is
the height of the era of segregation and
he said that
it was a segregated event so that black
kids other african americans watched the
celebration from outside the gates of
the local high school and they could
look in to see what was going on and he
has a memory of this and then i checked
it out and everything that i was able to
cr find he was corroborated by written
sources so they had a whole pageant
which showed the history of the county
it's a pageant with no mention of
slavery and no mention of nat turner
it's all about
other
other achievements it's about indians
and so forth it's about the land growing
and people are becoming more prosperous
but he said at that event at that
pageant there was a table outside of
artifacts and on one of them
there was an artifact said that this was
a money purse made from the skin of matt
turner
now again it's all murky right was it
really a money purse and so forth but
either way right it's a little
little disturbing a lot disturbing to
have something somebody saying that this
is the money purse mcgee was sure it was
the money person given the fact that we
hear mention of this of him being
uh
this from 1900 and then from the time of
the rebellion itself uh there's body
parts going around we know there's a
history of this nat turner's skull how
many of you have read about nat turner's
skull
okay so you know that um
well i know that there are multiple
sightings of nat turner's head
that whatever happens to his body is is
not so clear the rest of his body but
something purporting to be nat turner's
skull
turns up in various places
it's sometimes in virginia in worcester
ohio
there's a college in ohio the college of
worcester where on display in the museum
they have something which is labeled the
skull
of nat turner uh elkhart indiana has had
one
as well as norfolk virginia uh so uh and
then it turns out now i you'd think that
we're talking about the distant past
right this is some thing
right which has got to have faded from
the scene
well you know it doesn't seem to have
so the the skull that was found in
elkhart indiana was actually given to
the to the mayor of gary indiana mayor
richard gordon hatcher who founded
something called the national civil
rights hall of fame and they gave him
the skull
to have in the hall of fame and i
remember reading about this when it
happened i said what are they doing
they're they're trading the skull how do
you display a human skull in a museum
what what are people thinking it's quite
unbelievable
and it turns out that they've had that
skull since then and only recently was
the skull given to people who believe
that they're the family of nat turner
who then have given it to the
smithsonian and right now as we speak as
far as i know the smithsonian is
analyzing the dna of that family and the
dna of the skull to try to match the two
and the intention is to give nat
turner's part of his body a proper
burial
so
whoa
you know
as i sort of stumbled across this i
realize no matter where i look this is
you want to talk about the epicenter of
nasty race relations in america it's the
nat turner story that produces it over
and over and over again
um
let me
have way more than i can possibly tell
you here
but let me keep my eye on the time
um
so when i began to do the film about nat
turner this was interesting
i happened to connect with one of the
great african-american directors it's a
guy named charles burnett if you've
never seen a charles burnett film you
should see it he's not nearly as famous
as someone like spike lee for example
because he never had a mega hit but if
you see his movies you see how carefully
done they are he first came to feign
with a film called killer of sheep
and this was a film about a black family
living in los angeles and he did his
film you know when uh in the era of
shaft and movies about cool african
americans involved in various criminal
activities
and this was a film about a real afr was
based on a real african-american family
trying to live their lives into
difficult circumstances it's a great
film he did a film with danny glover
called to sleep with anger about
african-american culture
he did a film in fact if you want to see
one film on slavery that's a great film
it's a disney film believe it or not
it's called night john it's based on a
children's book and it's about a little
girl who's taught to read by someone who
comes to the plantation another
african-american who comes to the
plantation
um he directed halle berry in a film
called the wedding for tv so it was
wonderful to connect with him because he
and another guy named frank christopher
a documentary filmmaker uh
the the the they came to me
and they tried to talk to everybody who
knew about nat turner in the country
we hit it off and i agreed to join them
and agreed to join them for several
reasons i've never met a group of
filmmakers or anybody really who was as
ethical
as they were as gentle as kind as they
were and who had we were an interracial
group so we had amazing conversations
about race what we did was we went out
and went across the country including
styron as well in part to talk to
anybody who had anything to say about
nat turner it included the people around
the styron novel it included every
historian we've we have some amazing
footage and in the end
we had we decided we were going to do a
film we got money from the national
endowment for the humanities
one of their largest grants really and
we were able to do the film and i
remember at an early meeting
charles burnett said
let's tell the story of nat turner
just the simple he's a he's a simple
clear guy right let's get it right let's
tell the story
and i looked at him and i said
what story that story has been so buried
and destroyed you'd have to make it up
and if we made it up we were going to
sound like everybody else has tried to
make up the nat turner story that road
lies madness so we talked about this and
talked about this and talked about this
and we had an education in american race
by talking to all these people all over
the country
and uh in the end what we decided to do
was no no no we wouldn't tell the story
of nat turner we would tell the stories
of the story of nat turner
that is to say we would try to let
people know here is what people have
said about nat turner
we tell every one of them we were going
to tell the styron story for example let
that we were going to tell the thomas
gray story as well whatever we knew
about it and we were going to depict
things
the way the storytellers
told it and then we decided okay well an
audience just doesn't want to hear
talking heads you know in a film if it's
a documentary film the last thing you
want to see in a documentary film
especially it's pre-photography right so
there's no video footage there are no
photographs there's nothing to actually
show so what are we going to show in the
film that would hold people's interest
and i'll give you one example what we
decided to do was we have many people
angry at william styron's novel
there has never been a film about that
novel 20th century fox bought the rights
to the film they almost made the film
and they never did make the film around
1970 or so that's a whole other story
okay
but when they didn't make uh make the
film so there's no footage right you if
you've how many of you have seen the
recent birth of a nation film
not so many it didn't do well at the box
office
but uh but there was nothing before this
right so there was no no footage we
could draw and if you look at images if
you look on the internet images of nat
turner and the rebellion
those are all they come many years later
they're just made up like everything
else is made up about matt turner so we
said okay we're going to show people
angry about something like
that turner lusting after margaret
whitehead
okay let's show the audience and so we
hired actors we recreated the scene all
the several scenes from the novel that
was the most irritating because then
when we have voices talking about it you
can see if you want to see it in all its
power you can see what people were
reading in an odd way it was a dangerous
thing to do in fact our goal was not to
interpret nat turner but to to
tell it as exactly as we could the
people who were telling stories about
nat turner to tell their stories do what
they were doing so i remember we did
something which was very dangerous we
were filming in virginia okay but we
actually
uh recreate the scene of nat turner
killing margaret whitehead
and uh
you know siren in the novel does things
like he describes the dress margaret
whitehead is wearing he describes the
weapons that that turner was using
as well and we said let's just get it
right
just the way not the this isn't us okay
we're not we don't believe a word of
this it didn't happen this way
this is the way styron thought and now
we can show why people were angry it's
tiring then i did something which in
retrospect i got to tell you it was one
of the stupidest things i've ever done
we said okay if we got it right we were
about to film it we said let's invite
styron down
now the reason why that was stupid is
what if he said it's not the way i
imagined it that's what we were trying
to do so we ran out of money you know
you just can't you can't reject it okay
so it was it was a crazy thing to do
and he was ill at that time and we got
him a trailer it was air conditioned we
brought him down
he was very patient we knew him quite
well by then
and uh when it came time for the killing
of margaret whitehead from his novel he
came out watched the scene and he turned
to me and said it's exactly as i
imagined it
we dodged that one
um
and we had in in that film if you look
at it you have to look carefully we had
five different actors play matt turner
we weren't going to show nat turner as
he really was even thomas gray's nat
turner we had an actor who was different
from the actor who was the executed nat
turner which comes from a newspaper
article
so there are five nat turners in there
and the audience gets the sense of this
is a very elusive person to try to
re-recreate
um
okay and then most recently you know i
went to the so for the birth of a nation
film now for those of you who haven't
seen it let me tell you about it
although it has the name the same name
as the film which is considered to have
given birth to hollywood the 1915 film
it's the first american feature film dw
griffith directed it it was the first
film shown at the white house woodrow
wilson saw it
and
said it was history written with
lightning he loved it and then
as it began to appear that 1915 film
that has nothing to do with nat turner
that's about the civil war
reconstruction and not only is it the
film that gave birth to hollywood it's
also one of the great
used great and quotes american racist
films at its heart is
the uh
um
black men
lusting after white women attempting to
rape white women and the heroes of the
film becomes the ku klux klan and in
fact as a result of that film the clan
which had died out pretty much by 1915
was revived by 1920 there were a hundred
thousand klansmen
not wearing their masks even not ashamed
about it but being marching on
washington uh by that year so
[Music]
when nate parker decides to call his
film birth of a nation that evokes that
other world and in a sense what the 1915
film was about was the birth of a white
nation
what the
196 but what the 2016 film was about was
the birth of a black nation that's what
matt turner appears in there so i when i
knew this was coming out i decided i
ought to go i ought to see this opening
moment and i went to the sundance film
festival i got to tell you this is one
of the hardest things i've ever done in
my life getting a ticket at the sundance
festival for this particular film
because i don't know if you remember
about a year ago
no blacks were nominated for academy
awards no no african-american actors
were nominated for academy awards and
there was a large outcry basically how
could this possibly be there were so
many great african-american
actors around and then when he came out
with this film
many many people said this is the moment
for the next year
uh that uh
that that
which is the the year now basically that
uh we have the chance for an
african-american to win nate parker was
the director the producer
the writer and the lead actor in that
film so i went there and i got to tell
you the reaction in the audience at
sundance was electric
multiple standing ovations
it was amazing you'd never i've never
seen a reaction like that to any film
and none of that it won the prize the
top prize at sundance which is an
extremely difficult thing to happen and
then it sold for the most money ever
paid for a independent film from
sundance basically uh
fox searchlight films films bought it
so
uh now i'm not i can't linger over this
i'm actually writing something longer
about that film because i have a lot to
say about it and it's really complex you
know
here's something i came to realize in
doing my own film
you cannot apply the standards of
written history to history on film
it's just a different kind of thing
so let me give you an example okay if
i'm a writer and i want to describe a
historian and i want to describe a house
okay
but
you know i know some features of the
house but i don't know what the door
looks like i don't have to talk about
the door or if you have nat turner
sitting in a jail cell for example
you know what what does that look like
exactly you gotta we have not no no
record about it so in films you can't
have blank space
right i can't show a house and if i know
nothing about the door i just have it
empty okay you fill in the door well
this is true for everything about film
and it's what writers do in novels as
well this is what you want writers to do
especially for african-american history
you know
tony morrison who wrote the great novel
beloved
that's about a real historical incident
about margaret garner
and her she kills her children in this
in the film or a child uh and and and
toni morrison write the novel about it
well tony morrison has to make it all up
as we get inside margaret garner's mind
and margaret garner's world okay you
want writers to do that because
otherwise the re the record which often
destroys the lives of african americans
in the past that simply gets lost if you
don't if you don't have imaginative
readers writers who are good and
sympathetic to recreate that world
then you that world is lost so i've come
to expect and i have a different
standard when i look at a film i've come
to expect films
to
deviate from what i would do as a
historian i don't want them to duplicate
what i do what siren was trying to do he
did i think he did it poorly but what he
was trying to do is what you want
writers to do to go where historians
can't go and you go inside the mind so
in if you see nate parker's film you
will see
uh there's uh
uh there's dialogue that's created you
have to write all the dialogue right you
for every historical film that's the
case right we don't know what they and
if we even if it was written down you
wouldn't want to duplicate it in a film
it would still be pretty
pretty boring
so
um
you have to invent characters and so
forth and that's what the nate parker
film is about
i have a more complicated criticism of
the film because of the things it
invents and doesn't envelop but i don't
have time to do that
now
[Music]
so all this now think of what i've just
told you okay this is about my
experience with matt turner what a
complicated world multiple voices racial
controversy and hatred it's it's the
it's the epicenter of american race
relations in a way
um
and uh and that was so then i became
fascinated with turner and i've been
really working on turner in different
ways
but i think i only have maybe 20 minutes
or so
left
but
i think one mistake that people make
when they try to historians especially
when they try to describe nat turner is
they begin by talking about nat turner
this may seem weird okay
but you'd think hey if you want to learn
about turner why don't you talk about
turner that's because there's another
story
which we don't have good records of in
fact if you if you look at the
confessions of nat turner at one point
gray
at thomas gray the white lawyer asks
matt turner you know you tell us about
your master and he says oh my master was
a good master
so if you read that and then you see the
enormous bloodshed that follows and he
kills his master or one of his people
one of his hench people kills his master
with an axe you wonder
what what's that all about exactly okay
well i what i think you need to do is
when you start with a subject like matt
turner is to talk about slavery
we don't have the specific evidence in
that turner's case but slavery is an
evil institution and anybody who was
enslaved experiences that evil
institution so before you begin to talk
about nat turner let's talk about some
things let me just take five minutes to
point out some things which you all know
about slavery somehow but these are
details i think which will
resonate you should have them in your
head for example obviously you know this
physical punishment like whipping and so
forth and slavery is the most extreme
form of unfree labor there are other
kinds as well and you can be sold or
inherited you're a piece of property and
so forth but these are some other
features okay
there are many good people in the world
some of them are masters
and you know uh and you can see
instances and we know that the whites
write about it black's right about it as
well it's possible to encounter people
in an evil institution who treat each
other
as well as is possible under that evil
institution okay
the problem of slavery of course the
heart of it is you don't get to pick
your master
suppose you were lucky enough to have
had a master who
you know
gave you decent treatment which again
that could happen okay but you could be
sold to a sadist
you could be sold to a murderer
you know the you're you're vulnerable
every step of the way even when you're
not at immediate risk you're vulnerable
masters die estates are sold and so
forth another feature there's no
institution of marriage and slavery you
know we talk about enslaved people
having
wives and husbands and so forth well
that's not the legal institution of
marriage that's customary institution if
masters want to permit that to happen
and they have reasons to do that they do
that sort of thing but they could just
as easily break people apart
and many times especially in virginia
where there are small farms you couldn't
even if you had a love relationship with
someone you rarely live with that person
they lived on a neighboring farm and so
forth
here's another feature of slavery there
is no crime of rape rape is not a crime
when white men are raping black women
that's why i say you know this strange
reversal after slavery that is black men
lusting after white women
rape is built into the institution of
slavery i know this is disturbing it's
of course not written about openly not
widely shared and so forth but think
about living in a world where it's not a
crime not only is it not a crime but
since the children
of black women become the property of
their masters if a master rapes a black
woman not only is there no danger of
being imprisoned about or going to jail
over something like that but you
increase your property as a result
you can be sure that rape was central to
the institution of slavery so when that
turner and you read the confessions you
know is it what what's going on what
what where are the grievances exactly
you can assume that rape was there and
again this is dangerous territory for a
historian to operate in
another thing literacy okay this is an
institution that tries to prevent the
people who are enslaved from learning to
read
now why is that the case well it's
multiple reasons first
there's literature around there are
newspapers their northerners are trying
to send literature down but even in
within southern writings themselves if
you were an enslaved person and could
read you could read things which would
undermine the institution of slavery you
could even read the bible on your own
and well there's plenty of there to
support slavery there's plenty in there
to attack slavery as well so uh
they so you know probably under five
percent of people who are enslaved learn
to read there's some amazing stories of
learning to read
religion you know masters want the
slaves to learn a certain religion
uh the ability to testify in court
that's another one okay
so you can see how if if enslaved people
were allowed to testify in court in
cases involving whites it would
undermine the institution of slavery
because the slave might accuse the
master of something and they'd go to
court you know
you committed some atrocity and so forth
so therefore the words of enslaved
people and this is part of the whole
dishonoring of enslaved people okay but
the words of enslaved people are not
considered appropriate because they
can't be believed in a courtroom now
sometimes this leads to crazy results
for example
if a white man is murdered by another
white man
in front of a hundred people
and those hundred people are slaves
there are no witnesses to that murder
think about that
uh slaves have no property they can't
give gifts now sometimes
everybody pretends that they can give
they can give gifts but in actuality
it's whatever the slave has is owned by
the master right so they can't give
gifts and you i'm sure you've all read
stories or heard stories about
an enslaved person who buys their
freedom
right you've all heard that okay that
does happen occasionally but guess what
what is that that is the master
permitting an enslaved person to buy
their freedom because an enslaved person
has no property even if you've saved
you know suppose you've saved enough
money to buy your freedom and you come
to your master and you say you've agreed
to give me my freedom if i gave you this
money the master can say that's not your
money it's mine
again if they if they don't say that
then they're just giving your freedom as
a gift that's why by the way when
slavery ended
and the the question is well how does
slavery end how do you get freedom in
the end okay
there are all these images we have them
in boston and they're all over the
country of of abraham lincoln
uh freeing the slaves you know breaking
the chains of slavery
okay that duplicates the idea that
slavery that
freedom is given as a gift by whites to
black people
right that that just re recapitulates
that that old idea
but within the institution of slavery
there is no way
the only way you could get your own
freedom now think about this okay is
forget the gift stuff forget trying to
buy your own freedom you could run away
or you could be a rebel like nat turner
was so this is a tremendous threat to to
slavery
okay
let me talk about the ways in which you
can resist slavery and i probably have
just enough time to talk about this and
by the way you'll notice i haven't said
much about nat turner right
just like i got a lot you know i could
you could keep me here for three days
and i'd go on and on and on okay to get
into it but let's think about this for a
second okay
if you were an enslaved person how would
you resist slavery how could you resist
slavery exactly
so
rebellion of course is the most extreme
form
uh
and this is what nat turner uh
nat turner engaged in
uh
one question is well how common was
rebellion among enslaved people in the
united states
well you see
the old south had a myth that the
enslaved people were happy with slavery
right you've seen that old myth about
the
the old south in some ways it's the myth
that's in gamut the wind uh the the film
and uh so that there was just happiness
and that's of course very comforting if
you're a slave master before the civil
war you want to believe in the happiness
the fact that there's a slave rebellion
and it doesn't take much by the way
because when that turner rises up
okay every master wonders
whoa we weren't expecting that
maybe i've got a nat turner on my farm
and they begin to look differently so
matt turner's rebellion and other slave
rebellions
carry a lot of weight well beyond what
the actual numbers are you know there
are 55 white people killed in the
rebellion there the estimates of the
number of of enslaved people involved
varies that it's gone from as high as
70. the latest figure by a very careful
historian was probably 40
people actively involved in the
rebellion but that's that's it and it
lasts one day
and by the way by world historical
standards this is small potatoes
you know in uh
in haiti you have a rebellion which
fights napoleon's army and creates the
first uh african-americans african state
really african origin state in the in
the western hemisphere um or in uh in
in russia where they have serfdom you
have surf rebellions of hundreds of
thousands of people or in brazil you
have columbo's uh which are independent
communities of people who are able
african americans who can create
separate lives hidden in the jungles uh
there and they go on for years and years
and years so those are big rebellions
this is among the biggest not the
biggest but among the biggest nat turner
rebellion um
now
so so sometimes some early historians
used this idea about rebellions to say
that well this fits into the idea well
there wasn't that much unrest okay but
they're misreading a lot of things
so
if you wanted to resist slavery think of
the things you could do the many other
forms
engaging in a rebellion was suicide
everybody who did it was killed and you
know in other famous rebellions like
gabriel's rebellion and visas rebellion
they weren't they didn't even rebel
these were conspiracies which were
caught and they killed lots of people
and in that turner rebellion not only
did they kill the people who were
involved in the rebellion but there was
widespread slaughter in the black
community by whites after the rebellion
as well so uh it you know where you had
places uh where rebellions were more
successful they were near swamps or
areas where you could run to and hide
and hold out there some people thought
think that nat turner might have been
heading towards toward the dismal swamp
it's not clear whether that was really
the case but anyway rebellion
you know if if they're not huge in
number not happening every day it's
because that it is the same as suicide
uh it's very hard to resist in the case
of nat turner's rebellion there were
three thousand militia troops on the way
to southampton county when the rebellion
breaks out within that 24-hour period
it's put down by the local militia but
there were three thousand coming there
are 40 rebels
you tell me what chance they had from
the very very beginning so what could
you do well here's what you could do you
could slow down the pace of work
you know whites who looked at that said
oh the slave population the enslaved
people are lazy that's what they saw
okay but not the case at all
they're seeing resistance and they don't
know it's resistance if you were going
to resist that'd be a great way to
resist you could break tools
you know they say oh they're slaves
you know they they're so clumsy they
don't know things uh you could lie in
different ways you could sneak away at
night just to visit a neighboring
plantation that's happened all the time
or uh or you could use fire you know
southern cities burn down all the time
who burned them down
sometimes it's enslaved people fighting
the way they can and live to see another
day you could put ground glass in your
master's oatmeal
you could
learn to read now this is an interesting
one okay but that's a form of resistance
it's against the law to learn how to
read and you get whites who get punished
for teaching people how to read but
learning how to read becomes a form of
resistance in fact you could think of
marriage loyalty to a spouse as a form
of resistance
music to the extent that
african-americans can carve out areas of
resistance in the institution of slavery
they're all forms of resistance
being loyal to friends for example
running away to the north
uh you know
or even just into the woods for a while
so the institution of slavery is full of
resistance every step of the way every
step of the way
and rebellions are just one small form
of it but they go a long way that one
rebellion once in a while puts fear in
the in the hearts of whites
so i i want to leave a lot of time for
comments and i it's 8 27 is this am i
running out of time
please
here here we go
could you tell us
how old a hole was that turner 31.
so why why did he have a rebellion and
why did people join we didn't
seem to get that so you're right so
i had another hour's worth of comments
here but uh i will address your comment
directly okay why not turner so so
first the only source into nat turner's
mind there are two two sources really
one is
the confessions of nat turner and you've
got to be careful when you use that and
the other is what whites are saying
about him we have some statements from
the trial records and there are trial
records they're skimpy and sparse they
don't tell you that much about nat
turner personally but he actually says a
lot because there are a lot of things
which are in those confessions which
couldn't possibly come from thomas gray
so we know for example he talks about
his childhood his parents from an early
age told him he was a special child
they saw marks on his body which they
said this comes from an african
tradition
they said marked him as a special person
both whites and blacks
talked about his intelligence his master
even said
you're not destined to be a slave
uh he had memories which his family and
others told him of things that occurred
before he was born and they all saw
these as signs of miraculous something
miraculous
and then he learned to read now if you
read the confessions he there are two
ways in which he which is described in
the confessions one is he said he just
learned to read easily he doesn't even
know how he did it and he amazed
everybody that he knew the alphabet when
he knew the alphabet he says that as if
it's a kind of miraculous thing
in thomas gray's voice gray says he
knows how to read and his parents taught
him
by the way neither one of those
appears in the birth of a nation film
nate parker could have grabbed one of
those and he didn't he invented another
one which is how
frederick douglass learned how to read
but that's another story
um
so then he read the bible
he lives near the town of jerusalem
imagine if you're an enslaved person and
you live near a place called jerusalem
and you read the bible through that lens
and then the bible is full of all kinds
of things and he he has visions he has
not only does he read the bible but he
has religious visions he has a vision
that says a voice says him
seek ye the kingdom of god and all
things shall be added unto you
he he sees blood on the corn as if it
came from the heavens he sees the body
of christ laid out across the heavens
uh
so he he gets these visions and their
apocalyptic visions
and that's the the core of his thought
basically the end of the world is near
and then he has a moment when he says
christ has laid down the yoke
he has assumed for the sins of men and
he believes he is the one who's
responsible for picking it up basically
to fight against slavery so i would say
at the bottom line is the sense of being
special and then reading the bible and
interpreting the bible in these
apocalyptic terms and taking action of
slavery but that's why i thought i ought
to mention to you the horrors of slavery
because all that is sitting there
he's got all that okay all this stuff is
added to that
stuff
and some people look at that look at nat
turner's thinking about this and they
say
and and styron actually since i know he
told this to me he said he was a nut
now my answer to that is
every religion seems crazy from the
outside
think about your own religions okay and
imagine how someone from another
religion would look at them you know
what they do in that crazy religion
every religion is crazy so nat turner's
is no different from any others and he
reads about people in the bible who have
visions
god speaks to them all the time so
that's his world
and i wouldn't dismiss it as oh the work
of a nut unless you want to dismiss
moses as a nut
so you're asking a deeper question in a
way which is well what what did it
matter exactly
so we know the following which is that
as soon as the rebellion took place
again
african-american voices are stilled no
southern african-american sits down and
writes i'm moved by what turner did they
can't write anyway right so you don't
see that but you do get hints of it when
the civil war ended by the way and
african-americans are holding i think
it's a religious meeting
in virginia after the civil war i think
it was 1866
and
the delegation from southampton county
which is turner's county comes in the
door
they're cheered we welcome them from
southampton county because they all know
about the rebellion and what that meant
to be from south hampton county in the
north
uh
black abolitionists and boston was at
the center of african-american
abolitionism in fact it african
americans began abolitionism the real
attack on slavery in boston
uh just a few blocks from my from my
school but they point in that turner and
and many of them come to admire turner
and you see turner being spoken of in
the literature right up to the civil war
uh we do know that as a result of the
rebellion there's repression in the
south that's the immediate result
uh and uh you know there's the killing
of blacks in the community
there's uh
uh the the colonization society
makes it possible they go to into south
hampton county and they want to play pay
for free blacks to be sent back to
africa and many of them find it so
comfortable uncomfortable to live there
that they go back to africa so it's got
those
those consequences as well
but you know
but
the fact that nat turner can stand there
and remains until the present moment
as a heroic symbol of resistance
so that no one can say
the african-americans who were enslaved
were docile in the face of slavery
in what year did this uh rebellion take
place
in what year what
and what year did he have his rebellion
one year was a rebellion
what year did not turn rebel 1831.
now by the way one other consequence of
the rebellion i should have mentioned
was this is the most amazing thing of
all okay the virginia legislature
was so petrified well very white
virginian was so petrified by the
rebellion that the legislature including
petitions from many counties including
women petitioning at being coming
southern women becoming active in
politics was extremely rare during those
days they wrote
their legislators in richmond and said
we have to get rid of slavery we can't
live knowing that there are possible nat
turners on our farms and so in 1832
virginia legislature had an open debate
about abolishing slavery
and they ultimately
uh turn it down but that would have been
amazing right that as a result of nat
turner's rebellion long after he's dead
the white southerners get rid of slavery
because he creates such fear didn't
happen but
it was that that was seriously debated
is an amazing thing
[Music]
how did matt turner organize the
rebellion how did he conduct it
uh and for how long
and what you can tell us about the
actual rebellion so
nat turner himself uh was inspired by
these religious divisions in the in the
1820s probably as early as 1826 or so
and uh he both thought that god had told
him and he himself realized that he
couldn't talk about it with anybody so
he was a
kind of a lay preacher and clearly won
the respect of the community that he was
with but he didn't talk to anybody about
it until he thought the time was right
now there's a long history of this
because we know other rebellions were
betrayed
enough people get involved and someone's
gonna because after all if you if you're
involved and if you don't betray the
rebellion
you die
you know it's a very dangerous thing so
there are many people who will betray
the rebellion it only takes one person
to do that that's what happened to
gabriel's rebellion we know so um
so uh
so the so it was all in his head
and then the day before the rebellion he
calls together six people who he trusts
and they meet in the woods and he tells
them about the plans of the rebellion
and they all agree to join the rebellion
and the plan of the rebellion is to move
from farm to farm
to kill every man woman and child who
they encounter
everyone
that includes infants
that includes children that includes
women in fact
it's largely women and children that get
killed in the rebellion as they go from
farm to farm but that's their plan and
the idea is to strike terror in the
community and you can see it actually
has that effect there are some people in
the militia who come across these farms
of dead people and they say i gotta go
back and take care of my family and so
forth but the rebellion itself lasts 24
hours the local militia mobilizes and
puts down the rebellion three thousand
are on the way as i say and
that's the rebellion
what i gathered about your film
[Music]
it seems to me that uh some people may
receive that as you corroborating the
false stories that
that others had told
so um
[Music]
how do you think that that was perceived
when by people that want to believe what
they want to believe and you know are
quoting you
against what you wanted to um put out
there
so
it's a good comment i'll let me repeat
it okay because it's a an important
point which is that okay if we tell
these false stories
then aren't we just spreading false
stories okay well of course in the
context of the film we tell the audience
over and over again and when you see
five stories that can't all be true
exactly so we do whatever we can to
undermine the validity of all those
stories and then we have voices we have
william styron's uh portrayal of of nat
turner and then we have the black
critics criticizing so what you have is
these are american voices coming and
clashing with each other
and uh i hope it doesn't have the effect
of someone saying it's a false
you know we're spreading false stories
by the way i i should i got to say one
other thing though to be
my mind is still actually open about
this issue okay that's why it's an
interesting point you made
you know imagine this for a second okay
imagine if i showed you a picture of a
horse
up on the screen here right picture of a
horse
and it has the label on it dog
okay
so think about it for a second okay
would you call what i showed you a
mislabeled horse
or a mispictured dog
now i give this example to you because
you'll all recognize well you think of
it as a mislabeled horse okay that's the
power of the image because you could do
either one they're both equally valid
right
but the power of an image
is much more powerful than the power of
a word
and so
you're right that's why all those you
know when you see gone with the wind
once you've seen gone with the wind you
could read a hundred criticisms of gone
with the wind and that image of gone
with the wind stays with you so there is
the danger if you show false images on
the other hand
you gotta read history you gotta listen
carefully to the film
you know what otherwise we we we throw
away reason okay but that is you point
out a good danger
could you
advise us if the episcopal church had a
role
in
ned turner's life
as far as
being accepted into the church being not
accepted in the church the physical
church supporting
slavery
uh
during that time period so you know the
the roles of the churches are quite
interesting the it's the baptists and
the methodists who are anti-slavery and
for a certain period i think it's the
methodists that actually take a position
against slavery not the not the
episcopals as far as i know but those
are the that's those are the communities
that nat turner is rooted in really and
uh that's the religious community of the
masters as well and from the time of the
revolution that has a strong
anti-slavery streak to it so there's no
doubt in my mind that that was connected
to nat turner somehow
but we haven't got the connections
for sure
i just wanted to ask
and it could be a rhetorical question
for everybody in the audience
what kind of reaction do you get
or what have you heard of the reactions
of the audience members hearing about
net turner and i guess i was
really interested in whites because i'm
just curious if
they come with the you know
the rage of the past and then blacks are
coming with the rage of the past
has there been any shifting
in the
viewing of some character such as nat
turner from having listened
to your presentations where you attempt
to give context
is there anything more than just anger
and
and what's human which is protection but
is there any shifting to understand
nat turner as more than just
this
person who murdered i mean that's kind
of the stereotypical feeling i get as a
black person
so uh
[Music]
this is interesting you know because i
teach my students every year from year
to year as well and the problem with
talk
you know we're used to many good words
passing and many bad words as well but
culture is very resistant to change
doesn't change so easily with
conversation and talk it it is the route
that i choose to follow and many of you
choose to follow that's what
universities are all about
trying to affect change that way but it
doesn't happen so easily especially in a
world where conversation somehow is
becoming increasingly distrusted so um
no you know if if your question is well
do people listen to me and say now i
understand i've got it okay there are
some people who
clearly do react that way it's not huge
numbers but most people
when you leave here you go back and live
the rest of your lives and i don't
you know i'm not a preacher who's going
to convert you to something and that's
typically not the case with people who
give speeches
so i will continue to to do this
and i have a lot more to say about this
topic
and i think you know
race relations in america are as
deteriorated now as they were at any
time in my life
and it's it's a sad thing to see
would seem to be moving along nicely not
that things haven't changed they
certainly have but nonetheless that's
the case and one of the you know nat
turner is almost the
the person you can look at to say well
what are people saying about nat turner
at any one point in time and you can
sort of take the temperature of race
relations by by that so i'm not sure
that answers your question but
it's a few words in that direction
and i hope you let me thank dr greenberg
for her
[Applause]
and i want to remind you that this
thursday
here at great lives we have scott eiman
coming in to talk john wayne to us
so i'm going to do it is thursday night
at 7 30 right here dot thank you
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
to join every weekend on c-span 3
to join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
providence college history professor
patrick breen examines nat turner's life
and the 1831 slave rebellion he led and
compares the historical record to
betrayals in literature and film
he also describes the confusion and
uncertainty among both the black and
white populations of virginia after the
revolt due to conflicting or inflated
accounts
his book is titled the land shall be
deluged in blood and he spoke at the
virginia historical society
this is about an hour
on august 21st
1831 seven men launched what would
become known as the nat turner revolt
the rebels swept through southampton
county recruiting slaves to their ranks
and killing nearly five dozen white men
women and children more than had ever
been killed in any slave revolt in the
history of the united states
within two days whites re-established
control over southampton county
examining the terrible choices faced by
slaves and also the deep disagreements
among whites about how to respond to the
rebels today's speaker will discuss new
ways of thinking about nat turner his
revolt
southampton county and even american
slavery itself
patrick h breen is an associate
professor of history at providence
college in providence rhode island and
the author of the land shall be deluged
in blood a new history of the nat turner
revolt
he's published articles in the journal
of the early republic the virginia
magazine of history history and
biography and oxford
university presses anthology nat turner
a slave rebellion in history and memory
with the release of the movie birth of a
nation
how many of you seen birth of a nation
ah
oh the new version of birth of a nation
thank you
far fewer how many of you seen the old
version of birth of a nation
i still worry about you people sometimes
anyway with the release of the new
version of birth of a nation he has also
written more popular pieces in deadline
and for the smithsonian magazines
website which i encourage you to check
out when patrick is not busy writing and
researching that turner he's busy with
his five children
although this year is shaping up to be a
bit easier because he's only coaching
one of his children's basketball teams
so please let's give a warm vhs welcome
to patrick breen
i gotta silence my phone
or not
thanks for that kind kind introduction
it's idiomatic that you can't make a
silk purse out of a sow's ear but i
wonder if we just heard that saying
proved wrong
thanks also to the virginia historical
society to invite me to give this banner
lecture honoring charles f brian jr
uh thank you to the entire staff of the
virginia historical society liz ogleby
for promoting this talk i'd also like to
thank bill chapman from the virginia
forum who took some time away from
working on an upcoming forum with nate
parker to spread the word on this talk
and thank you for coming out to hear
this talk
um
for those of you who are golfers and
there might be one or two in the
audience i have to admit that this is
something of a mulligan for me
20 years ago or so i was awarded an
andrew w mellon fellowship that enabled
me to spend some time working at
virginia historical society's wonderful
research facilities
on that trip i got to read a letter from
an engineer at fort monroe who related
to his family the intelligence of a
revolt that had taken place in
southampton county
there were many instances of slaves
defending their masters and one poor
fellow from the inconsiderate and almost
unwarranted haste of whites
was sadly rewarded
assisted by his master and his son the
slave nobly fought with them against 20
of the blacks
after working for a week in the archives
finding nuggets like this i was supposed
to give a lecture on my research
and i was pretty nervous
i was a young graduate with student and
it wasn't a large lecture but it would
be in front of people including the
likes of nelson lankford and francis
pollard
people who knew virginia history knew
the archives and i think they would be
able to just smell if i had anything to
say about southampton that they didn't
already know
i hadn't given a lecture quite like this
before and the library of the virginia
historical society opens at 10 it still
does so i was there by no later than
1005 but when i walked in they looked at
me funny
weren't you supposed to give a research
talk to our staff i assured them i was
ready to do that but no
i was told
the talks had taken place
they happened at 9.
although i was sure i was sure that i
made the mistake and you can ask any of
my kids it's totally on me um
i never got to give the talk
so
when the time invite came to give the
banner lecture i can tell you
get that old paper out
ready to go
um
we'll see if i can tell you something
today about america's most famous and
most important slave rebellion
actually today i want to talk about
something different
uh about what
historians can bring to the topic
making arguments from the documents the
documents like the one i just referred
to that i found in the virginia
historical society
nat turner's revolt is a really
interesting event and it's gotten loads
of attention lately
america's most famous slave revolt it is
a historical event that somehow
strangely has escaped the fate of being
trapped in the history books
the way that most people encounter this
revolt was once through a novel
and more recently has become through a
movie for those who are older than me
you may remember william styrens 1967
the confessions of nat turner a book
that caught the attention of a
generation in no small part because it
ignited an enormous debate about slavery
for those younger than me
nate parker's current movie is a
touchstone although like styron's novel
birth of a nation has also engendered
its fair share of controversy
both the novel and the movie
uh offer dramatic portraits of matt
turner and his revolt
in both cases by filling in material
that is not in the sources they're able
to present engaging
although very different views of nat
turner and his revolt
for styron who tried to stay close to
the material that existed
but when there were gaps allowed himself
to imagine whatever he liked
turner was a deeply human and a deeply
flawed figure his religiosity gave him
ways to struggle with sexual urges that
pestered him
it was exactly this that styron had made
america's most famous slaver by
rebel something of a sexual misfit
bothered his critics actually was even
more than that
styron's returning to an old trope
he's imagining a black man not any black
man but nat turner lusting after a white
woman
styrens and ma imagined that turner was
attracted to margaret whitehead the one
person who he did kill with his own
hands during the revolt
and that
infatuation with margaret whitehead got
twisted and warped through his religious
inspiration into a slave revolt
well
infuriated by this appropriation
styron's critics lambasted him for
resorting to the same sexual language
that d.w griffith used when he made his
version of birth of a nation
in 1915 for using the same sexually
coded language that led to the deaths
of so many hundreds of black men and
boys through the years of jim crow
not surprisingly nate parker presents
his nat turner in the new film birth of
a nation in a remarkably different way
nate parker's turner is religious
but it is his religion that gave him the
opportunity to witness the full de brat
depravity of the slave system
as something of a slave circuit rider
turner is in position to witness the
sadistic tortures of black men and the
wanton sexual exploitation of black
women
ultimately the rapes of his wife and his
best friend's wife proved too much
parker's turner undertakes a war of
justifiable retribution against
southampton's depraved slave masters
parkers turner himself is the movie's
selfless hero and the way that turner's
final trip to jerusalem evokes both
jesus's own passion and death
and the surrender of william wallace in
braveheart a movie that clearly inspired
parker
unlike styron parker gave himself the
latitude to present things differently
from the way they were presented in
thomas r gray's compilation of nat
turner's confessions the trial records
or the newspaper articles that document
the revolt
but his overarching interpretation of
slavery
fits in well with the dominant ways that
historians
and the broader public understand
slavery
given that do we really need someone to
spend the months in the archives
reading sources that offer no more than
an admittedly incomplete and imperfect
view of what happened on the ground in
southampton county
as the graduate student who once took
that project on
my answer is yes
and the rest of the talk i want to
explain to you why
and what history offers us
let me begin
as any historian should
with sources
the sources connected to the revolt are
problematic if for no other reason than
that no source survives that was written
about the revolt
by someone sympathetic to the rebels
whites who hated the revolt wrote all
the contemporary accounts of the revolt
so there's good reason to ask if the
racism of the authors corrupted the
sources
moreover there was as is not surprising
a great deal of uncertainty and
confusion about the revolt
no one knew exactly what was going on
so much of what was written immediately
after the revolt
was a little more than speculation or
rumor
a newspaper account written shortly
after the revolt
described the eruption of 150 or 200
runaway slaves from the dismal swamp
which was a location about
40 or 50 miles west of
where the revolt began
another early report described about how
250 negroes from a camp meeting about
the dismal swamp
set on a marauding
excursion
when a newspaper man from richmond
arrived in southampton county
he observed that rumors had infinitely
exaggerated the
first swelling the number of negroes to
a thousand or twelve hundred men and
representing its ramifications as
embracing several of the adjacent
counties particularly isle of wight and
grenville greenville
newspaper editors who were inundated
with confused panicked and contradictory
reports realized that all these stories
couldn't be true at the same time
the revolt could not be both limited to
maroons who had been in the dismal swamp
and involved thousands of blacks from
three counties
recognizing immediately the enormous
problems with the reports that were
making their way to towns like richmond
petersburg and norfolk newspaper editors
complained
the editor of the richmond inquirer
grumbled nothing is known with certainty
a rival richmond editor added there are
reports in abundance but where are the
facts to be relied on
a thing is stated at one moment
the next it is confirmed
and then again
it is contradicted
the editor of the petersburg
intelligence intelligentsia carpet the
rumors have been so numerous and
contradictory that we are unable to
state to our readers at present the
precise state of affairs in southampton
county
when john hampton pleasance the editor
of the richmond whig
returned to richmond from southampton he
observed we have been astonished in
reading over the mass of exchange papers
accumulated in our absence to see the
number of false
absurd and idle rumors circulated by the
press touching the insurrection in the
country
editors seem to have applied themselves
to the task of alarming the public mind
as much as possible by persuading the
slaves to entertain high opinion of
their strength
and consequences
in september of uh 1831 on september
17th a letter a letter was penned in
southampton county sometimes this letter
is wrongly attributed to thomas r gray
the man who would eventually take down
that turner's confession
he in this letter whoever it is and we
don't know who it is uh likewise mocked
what he understood to be groundless
rumors
for men for example there are rumors of
his turners having been from home
many days at a time
preaching in richmond petersburg
brunswick
there are however these are however
entirely without foundation
the truth truth is i've never heard of
his preaching anywhere
he exhorted
and sung at the neighborhood meeting
but no farther
later he noted it is really amusing to
trace to their sources many of the
rumors which circulate through our
country and which have fixed public
opinion
leaving out the view of the exaggerated
arms being found at branton
many more this and that and the other
place
nat preaching in petersburg brunswick
and richmond not a word of which
am i able to believe
though i have sought to have it
corroborated from every respectable
source
after turner was captured in october
thomas r gray the man who published
turner's confessions began his address
to the public with a simple assertion
the late insurrection in southampton has
greatly excited the public mind and led
to a thousand idle exaggerated and
mischievous reports
for pleasants
for the unidentified author of the
september 17th letter and for thomas r
gray
the ubiquity of unreliable reports
led them to produce more reliable
accounts of what happened in southampton
county
after complaining about the widespread
rumors pleasance noted that the truth is
always the best policy
and the best remedy
pleasance was not the only one to commit
himself to making reliable
reliable reports
in the september 17th letter from
southampton
the author noted that there are so many
rumors afloat and so many misstatements
in the public press
that a sacred duty to my country demands
a correct view of this tragedy
to get the correct view
this unnamed correspondent just as this
unnamed correspondent described it the
writer described getting testimony from
multiple sources supported by collateral
circumstances
even thomas r gray
who's
published the confessions which he
claimed to be turner's full and free
confront confession with little or no
variation from his own words
now many scholars have questioned the
reliability of gray's account how
reliable was he at taking down nat
turner's own words
and i spent an entire chapter in my book
taking on that very question my
conclusion and it's not only my
conclusion another recent book on matt
turner by david allmendinger reaches
much the same point of view is that he
did what he said he was doing which is
pretty much writing down what nat turner
told him it makes it one of the most
remarkable documents in american history
here is the confessions of america's
most famous slave rebel
while there was a conscientious effort
by several people to produce more
reliable accounts of the revolt
this was not because the men producing
the accounts
were motivated by humanity wanting to be
fair to turner and his men they didn't
care about that
they were not motivated by cleo the muse
of history imagining that nearly 200
years after the revolt people would
gather in this lovely theater with the
hope of finding out what really happened
instead their accounts emerged because
there was an enormous split among whites
in southampton after the revolt
in the accounts each of the authors
refers somewhat condescendingly to the
public
by which they meant other whites people
with few slaves
the notes or view of any slaves
the notes that the public mind was
variously excited full of doubts and
misinformed by rumors and at this point
i'm reading over this and i'm thinking
i've heard this split before about the
people who don't know and the people who
do
is it a newspaper no it's actually
my paper but
following the killing of white men women
and children
popular passions raged against blacks
the public wanted revenge
some calling for the indiscriminate
slaughter of blacks who were suspected
ellen lewis who had spoken with several
gentlemen who had visited southampton
described it even more clearly
should the blacks attempt to rise there
again
they will be
exterminated
the excitement is that great
lewis was not the only person who
alluded to a possible massacre of
southampton slaves
although richmond lawyer john wickham
claimed that he had no apprehensions
himself he's not worried
he noted that quote the excitement was
so strong among the more ignorant that
there was reason to have apprehend a
reaction which if once begun
might be carried to dreadful lengths
william henry broadnax who was in charge
of virginia's militia in southampton
county took pride in the work that he
did to contain the anti-black response
but he also clearly sensed that if the
events at southampton were repeated he
would be unable to do anything
the whole black race
will be swept from
among us
john hampton pleasance the newspaper
reporter who traveled to southampton had
much the same impression
let not the facts be doubted
by those whom it concerns he wrote that
another insurrection will be the signal
for the
extermination of the whole
black population in the quarter of the
state where it occurs
slave holding petitioners from hanover
county i don't need to tell you where
that is
called on the legislature to act
will you wait until the land shall be
deluged in blood
and look alone to the final catastrophe
the extinction of the black races by
force
as the only remedy
given the danger of the public
overreacting in response to an
exaggerated sense of the threat posed by
blacks
slaveholders in southampton turned to
the careful collection of evidence
as a way to secure their property
by thoroughly documenting the actual
scale of the revolt the leaders of
southampton hoped to
as gray claimed in the confessions to
remove doubt and conjectures from the
public mind which otherwise
must have remained removing doubts would
lead to a certain way of understanding
the revolt
and that way of understanding the revolt
that it was small that it was limited
that it was uh
not that dangerous
would ultimately lead to the securing of
slave property
the efforts to reassure
non-slave holding whites
by showing that the slave rebels hadn't
posed a significant danger
were remarkably successful
and it really does not matter what kind
of records one uses you can look at the
tax records you can look at the trial
records you can look at the newspaper
accounts
they all agree the number of the black
of blacks killed without trials after
the revolt was somewhere in the 30s
it took longer to establish confidence
in the public mind that most blacks were
not involved in the revolt
but within a few years it is clear that
in the places where
where white non-slave holders had the
most sway and i look at this in my book
in the region's baptist churches
and where the slaveholders had not made
the same concerted efforts to get beyond
the most exaggerated rumors and i'm here
referring to court cases in sussex
county virginia
people ultimately white people
ultimately accepted the southampton that
the southampton courts got it right the
revolt they believed was a small affair
that posed a relatively minor threat
based upon their understanding of the
nat turner revolt
there was no need to kill all the blacks
to colonize all the slaves in liberia
or as the virginia legislature debated
the following year to abolish slavery
virginia was not on the cusp of another
haitian revolution
and that's absolutely critical that they
the virginians saw that because if they
had believed that the white virginians
might have done something differently
the fact that the way they got people to
realize the situation in southampton was
based on making a concerted effort to
accurately represent what happened in
august of 1831 means that the sources
about the revolt especially the letters
i've referred to but i'll also add here
the trials and even the petitions that
the virginia library has just this month
crowdsourced to put online
means that the evidence about the revolt
is among the most remarkable caches that
we have
in terms of sources on slavery
for so many sources the rhetorical
agenda of the authors ultimately make
the sources less useful to a historian
now maybe a slaveholder will sit there
and say oh the slaves all love slavery
well that's not very helpful
um you know maybe uh maybe an
abolitionist will say slavery is awful
again they've got a goal it's not so
helpful
but it's the
here it's exactly the rhetorical agenda
where one author saw a sacred duty to my
country to properly resent represent
what happened means that we have a
series of incredibly useful sources
that i think historians have not taken
advantage of and tapped as they should
so with the time i have left let me tell
you some stories
about what these sources reveal
and let me tell you a couple vignettes
focusing on some of the people who were
caught up in the revolt
i'll begin with hubbard's story
when the rebels arrived at katherine
whitehead's plantation on the morning
of monday 22nd august 1831 they caught
the family and the family's slaves
completely by surprise
the rebels killed richard whitehead
outside the house and then killed
catherine and several of her daughters
margaret whitehead who was the only
person turner killed
was among the dead
by the time that the greenville militia
arrived on the plantation
they found the bodies and and the white
heads
uh the whitehead's family
slaves the slaves told the whites that
they had remained loyal to the white
heads
but one local white identified him as a
rebel who he had seen at the battle
the troops from greenville shot him
he fell dead near the remains of his
mistress
the other slaves who remained on the
plantation also proclaimed their loyalty
to the whites their innocence
wallace an old negro man
claimed that he had shown the most
incredible loyalty to katherine
whitehead
when will one of the rebels grabbed
whitehead wallace begged the rebel to
spare the life of his mistress
the plea had no effect on will the man
nat turner would call my executioner
after killing whitehead the rebels
threatened wallace
who reportedly answered that he cared
not to live now that she was dead
well
i don't need to tell you whites were
skeptical of wallace's claims
but they were even more skeptical of the
claims of of the story of hubbard
according to him harriet whitehead one
of katherine whitehead's daughters had
survived the revolt in large part
because of his efforts
harriet had hidden between the mattress
next to the spot where her own sister
had been killed
and the rebels never found her
once the rebels left the plantation
hubbard and some of the other slaves
decided to secrete harriet away from the
house in case the rebels returned again
as it turned out the decision was
prudent
after some of the rebels uh after some
time after the rebels left the whitehead
plantation they realized they hadn't
killed everyone there they realized that
harriet was still alive recognizing
their oversight the rebels sent two
unnamed men back to the whitehead
plantation to kill harriet
while the assassins were walking back to
the whitehead house two slaves were
trying to help
the slaves were trying to help harriet
and they had placed her in a disguise
and were carrying her away from the
house
when they saw the two rebels returning
some of the whitehead slaves went
immediately to meet them and to convince
them by some means to turn their course
the rebels assigned to kill the last
whitehead were delayed and misdirected
until the other slaves could get harriet
to a swamp near the house
foiled by the slaves at the whitehead
plantation
the rebels never found harriet the only
white member of her house who survived
the revolt
the story was a good one and i'm sure he
told it to the militia who was
bare asking them what he had done during
the revolt
but whites remained suspicious of
hubbard
especially since the story implied that
harriet should have been able to confirm
the story
but she was not around
in part because she was scared too
she had narrowly escaped both the
initial assault and the assassination
squad that the rebels had sent to the
plantation
even if these men had stopped looking
for her the rebel army that had killed
her entire family was still at large she
didn't want to be found
an account of her escape written decades
after the revolt suggests that her
uncertainty was more profound than just
an unjust understandable fear of the
rebels
she apparently feared the slaves who
saved her life
according to this account harriet
wondered if the slaves who had twice
already saved her life would keep her
safe
maybe they would change her their mind
and turn her over to the rebels
harriet decided that the risk was too
great so she moved from the spot where
hubbard had hidden her and when hubbard
returned to the spot
she was gone
understandably perplexed by her
disappearance hubbard incorrectly
concluded that she had been killed by
the rebels
and there was no one there to confirm
his story of loyalty
harriet's harriet whitehead's doubts and
hubbard's confusions almost had a fatal
result because the men in the greenville
militia were unwilling to believe what
the slaves had told them
they decided to execute hubbard
as one of the murderers
when harriet whitehead heard this she
ran out and saved him by relating the
circumstances of his convict his conduct
in aid to save her life
as the person in best position to
convince the vengeful whites that
hubbard deserved to be spared
harriet saved his life
no less certainly than he had saved hers
consider the case of thomas hathcock
thomas hathcock was a free black who was
at home when jack and andrew two young
slaves who fled the whitehead plantation
when the rebels appeared
showed up the rebels had left word that
jack and andrew should join them and
jack and andrew were young and they
didn't know what they should do
they went to thomas hathcock a nearby
free black's house and asked them
what they should do
they asked
heythcock which they must do whether
they must go or not
hithcock's response was unambiguous
they must go
he added
that he would go with them as soon as he
could get something to eat
thomas hathcock then told his wife to
make haste
and get him something to eat i just see
him sitting there
get me a sandwich woman i got a war to
fight
thomas hathcock's unnamed white may have
fed her husband but not before she told
him what she thought of his plan
she entreated him not to go but her
pleas fell on deaf ears thomas hathcock
went off with jack and andrew in pursuit
of the rebels
at some point in the 24 hours after the
encounter at parker's farm the battle
where the rebels were first defeated
heathcock found nat turner and the
rebels
they told him what had happened
including that nat and the company had a
fight with the white people
following the rebels defeat turner
himself was making his way west towards
belfield which would take him back to
the neighborhood where the rebels had
been
hathcock was charged with finding out if
there was anyone at benjamin edwards
farm who would be willing to join
the army that turner was trying to
reassemble
despite this evidence against hathcock
all of which came from investigations
into him and
and the slave trials he was acquitted
he appears on the 1832 tax list although
by the time the tax collector came by i
will add thomas heathcock did not live
on the same farm as his wife
and his daughter
both of whom had testified against him
consider the clash between burwell and
exum artist immediately after the revolt
whites were too scared to communicate
directly so they sent slaves between
farms as messengers bowling barrett had
sent the slave burwell to lemwell
stories james stories and william vicks
to request them with their families to
go to mrs gurley's to keep guard
burwell delivered the message
but not without incident
he later testified that when he arrived
at vixx the free black exum artist
interrupted him
artists attempt to cut the whites line
of communication failed but when burwell
told anderson not to interfere with him
artists inability to convince burwell to
stop helping the whites in the middle of
a slave revolt made artist
very mad that's a quote
when burwell headed back to mrs gurley's
as he had been instructed artists
followed him and threatened him with a
pistol
the clash between the slave burwell and
the free black exum artist embodied the
dramatic differences that existed in the
black community as some including
artists decided to support the revolt
while others
elected to support the whites but
perhaps the most interesting and i think
perhaps the most representative
characters in this episode
were the unnamed blacks that witnessed
the escalating fight
between burwell and artist
when other artists caught up to burwell
he began yelling threatening burwell as
burwell recalled artists made some
considerable noise
at this point the blacks at mrs gurley's
farm told artists to quiet down they
told him if he kept such a noise the
whites would come and shoot them
or carry them to jail
much like the white response to the
uncertainty the larger black community
adopted pragmatic response to the revolt
they focused on surviving
to accomplish this most blacks thought
that the best way to stay alive was
avoid to do to avoid doing anything that
might draw attention to themselves
let me end with the story of j
fitzhugh's drew's excuse me jay drew
fitzhugh's unnamed slave the story that
robert e lee referred to in the letter i
found at the virginia historical society
archives
on wednesday it's right upstairs
on wednesday august 24th after the
revolt had been suppressed but before
the whites had any idea that they had
won
two captured slaves
told the whites that the rebels were
intending to rally and revenge their
defeat from the morning at samuel
blunt's plantation
based on this intelligence whites
decided to reinforce the men already at
the plantation
alexander p pete the man who led the
first group of white militia men who
encountered the rebels
took about 10 men to go to blunt's home
and defend it should it be attacked so
there's this rumor that the blacks are
going to rally and attack this
plantation
these reinforcements brought the total
number of whites defending blunts
plantation to 16
not counting the plantations
owner this force was significantly
stronger than the one that had repelled
the rebels the day before it was six
whites in the plantation house when the
rebels actually had made their first
raid they had come down looking for for
allies and they didn't realize that the
house had been occupied by whites and so
they got they got bushwhacked they got
they got ambushed
perhaps drawing on their experience from
the first attack at blunt's plantation
the whites did one more thing to prepare
themselves for the attack
they decided to arm blunt's slaves
although the light whites would later
use evid the events at blunt's
plantation to tout the loyalty of the
slaves during the revolt the whites saw
black support as uncertain at best
blacks on the plantation swore fidelity
to whites but whites at the time
thought this loyalty was conditional
and while concerns with black loyalty
were not enough to prevent the whites
from arming the slaves and i think it's
a fair sign of the confusion and
uncertainty that a day after the whites
had defeated the rebel army whites were
still so afraid of the slaves that they
armed the slaves that they armed slaves
they didn't trust completely
but whites were not oblivious to the
possibility that blunt slaves would join
the rebellion
after the whites handed them guns
to reduce the opportunity for armed
slaves to defect whites restricted the
black access to guns to those times when
they thought an attack was about to
happen
at the other times
the whites kept the arms that they had
set to the side they had set to the side
for the slaves under a guard
near the door
the rebel army never returned to blunt's
plantation
but that did not mean that the guns
remained neatly stacked through the
night
several times the word came that the
rebels were near
in response
whites armed the slaves and waited
now the rebels didn't have an army at
this point so nothing ever happened
and when the whites became satisfied
that their fears of an
impending attack were unfounded they
went back and collected the slaves
weapons
and put the put them under the guard at
the door
early morning wednesday
just before dawn the alarm sounded again
the blacks on the plantation went to
pick up their guns
and it was at this point that one of the
whites
a young man by the name of harris
spotted a slave belonging to jade drew
fitzhugh with a gun in his hand
harris shot
and killed
fitzhugh's slave
the story of the southampton slave
rebellion produced an incredible amount
of detail about what was happening and
in it we can see the way that the revolt
divided southampton county
both the whites and the blacks were
divided in very understandable ways
they were divided in ways that
ultimately showed the weakness the
difficulty of organizing a slave revolt
it's often thought that a slave revolt
is fairly easy to organize but it isn't
they usually fail with the exception of
the haitian revolution it's very unusual
to see a slave revolt fail and one of
the things we forget when we watch the
movies
so we think it's easy it's not
people are thinking a lot of different
things at the same time slave revolts
are hard
at the same time we can see the
confusion and uncertainty in the white
community the white community was deeply
divided in response to the revolt not
because they were divided about the
slave revolt although there are some
indications of pros uh of anti-slavery
sentiment among whites in southampton
county
but they were deeply divided
just as the blacks were they were deeply
divided about what should be done
and the ultimate story of the nat turner
revolt is the story about how the elites
were able to stop
the
and we have a word for it but they
didn't but the genocidal impulses
that were sweeping through southampton
county in august and september of 1831.
[Music]
[Music]
i believe that i've why we have time for
some questions so if anyone has
questions about the
net turner slave revolt i'll be glad to
take them yeah interesting uh
interesting talk
you spoke
about documents and archives
but when you're doing that particularly
in in the slave period
what sort of documents and archives are
firsthand
that capture the perspective of the
slates themselves
well i i i mean none that's that's the
big problem is that there aren't any
sort i mean the only sources that the
best sources to catch the perspective of
slaves remains slave narratives
the the story is written but mainly by
slaves who escape slavery
there are also stories
told in the wpa interviews
that were recorded in the 1930s but
they're very very few of these documents
and the documents that do exist are
really precious
so
we don't have first-person accounts
except for nat turner's of what was
happening in the black community and i
want to point out that the confessions
what was happening he saw in the in the
confessions was completely compatible
with what um with what these other
accounts were describing a deeply
divided black community a deeply divided
well he doesn't have as much information
on the white community
but
how do we get the stories of the splits
between burwell and artists
these are stories that come up in
sources that are written down by whites
but i think that we can really see what
burwell's doing and we can see what
artist is doing you know think about the
story of the unnamed slave who dies why
was he defending why was he defending
his masters who really didn't trust him
i mean that's the important thing the
masters you know that whole idea that
there's this you know this no
during the slave revolt whites are
really scared of their slaves but
they're even more scared of the rebels
but why would drew
a lie with the whites
in that case i think this i mean can we
understand it well there's no one and
asked him of course he's dead so we
don't know
but
his family was on that plantation
was he afraid that if the rebels took
this plantation the whites would come in
and kill
did he have a child who he was afraid
might get swept up in the rebellion
willingly or unwillingly
and if that happened that child would be
executed i don't know we don't know this
but we have to go through and try to
piece together their point of view from
these white sources and what i'm trying
to argue or one of the things i try to
argue is these sources are much better
than we realize for doing just that i
think we can see the richness
we can see what hubbard's up to we can
see what these people are doing even if
we don't have their own autobiography
i will point out there is one other
source the trial records are very thin
but blacks are allowed to testify
many people know that blacks aren't
allowed to testify against whites during
slavery
but blacks are allowed to testify
against other blacks so that would be
another situation where we are actually
able to get
black's own accounts of what happens
i remember at the time of the
publication of siren's novel that
it was a great
critical and commercial success
but it also prompted uh several black
critics to speak out and there was
actually a book published as i recall
called ten black writers respond right i
was
i'm interested what was the nature of
their criticism and did siren respond to
them oh yeah it was a it was a it was a
it was a cat fight for about
five years one of the reason why i don't
think there's been as much work done on
that turner was because of the huge
everyone was so upset after these fights
that no one wanted to touch it and so it
took a scholar i mean one of the things
i i came up after that so i i did i
missed that first hand experience
yeah no there's a huge fight and i think
that there's sort of two problems
uh the easy one
uh which i think is it was too easy and
too cheap i didn't think it worked
really well but the easy one was that he
made mistakes
right there were some things that he got
wrong and the most important of those is
that nat turner had a wife and he missed
the source that says nat turner has a
wife so he got some things wrong but
that's not really the complaint and i
don't think that they were able they
they were so upset at so much that came
at him and this is at the height of
black power that this white
southern author sort of spoke in that
turner's voice and represented it
that drove them crazy but what
especially drove them crazy i think
was the fact that nat turner had to make
his novel work
put the black rapist at the heart of it
exactly as the original birth of a
nation had and that was really really
problematic for a lot of people who saw
this as a political thing what are we
doing we're reinvoking the stereotypes
that have been used to hurt so hurt and
kill so many blacks over such a long
period of time and so that that was a
that was the thing that i think really i
don't think anyone sort of put it that
tightly but i think that that was the
most infuriating part of the of the of
the book um for the critics most of whom
were black and thought that this book
was just out of balance
there's a book called the southampton
insurrection
and i that was written by william jury
yep and he supposedly interviewed
survivors
and i i just thought it's been many many
years since i've read it but it did have
very detailed information at the back of
the trials who who was executed who
wasn't a list of of the
whites who were killed and i just
thought that was a a good source that's
a great source um and now it's
problematic as i mean it's this is
published in 1900 uh as a dissertation
and then a book
drewery's p drury is a family member of
people who he was from southampton
county and he said so he's going up to
do a dissertation what are you going to
do it on how about the slave rebellion
that took place so it's the first sort
of academic history of the revolt
it's deeply problematic because he and
this is very common in 1900 but he
thought slavery was basically a good
benign institution
the one thing about the book that
doesn't make a lot of sense is why did
they rebel
because it's so nice he called them the
happiest laboring he called it he called
them the happiest laboring class in the
world and it's like
the book just doesn't make sense now um
you know anyway uh so it's problematic
and historians have uh have really had
huge problems with it
that said its footnotes are fabulous
because he will sit there and he'll sit
make an assertion and then he'll quote
lavonia francis one of the survivors who
he interviews and so you have these sort
of first person accounts of what
happened written 60 years later now you
gotta handle that carefully but those i
mean you know we don't have as much
information as we like so that is a
really interesting but problematic
source but it's a good one to point out
to everyone
in in your research did you come across
a close encounter with
george thomas's family and the slave
revolt yeah and as it gets later it gets
closer um
the rebels uh
had report after the battle at parker's
plantation what happened is there's a
battle and and
both sides basically scatter
uh and in fact
i mean no one's been involved in a
battle before either the slaves or the
planters i mean they're just like well
ah so everyone you know they start they
see each other with guns and they like
run um the uh
the first group of whites who come to
the thing uh bolt after the first shot
is fired because they turn it because
the shot brings the black's attention
and all the blacks with guns are looking
at them and so they s they scatter
turner and his men go and follow the um
running whites trying to you know sort
of destroy this white force
when
lo and behold another force that had
heard the shots had created an ambush
line and when the rebels hit that ambush
line
they scattered and at that point
the rebels go in every different
direction
so
southampton that afternoon is going to
have rebel rebel forces running around
trying to reconstitute
well some of them aren't going to be
trying to reconcile some of them are
going to say time to get out of here but
um some of them are gonna be re
reconstituting it's at that time they go
by george thomas's house and and in the
in the sort of
mythology george thomas's house is you
know it's barely escapes and all that
stuff but at that point in the revolt no
more whites are getting killed anywhere
so it doesn't seem like it was really a
close encounter or like a you know that
close to being killed um but he
certainly was he was there um this is
you know uh the rocket chicken
chickamauga um union general um he ends
up going to west point five years later
and becoming a union an army officer and
then eventually stays in the union
um much to the chagrin of his family who
stays in the south
yes do you consider nat turner a highly
educated man
as presented in william styron's book
and also in this current birth of a
nation
the um
one of the most interesting lines in the
confessions of nat turner thomas r gray
who's taking it down obviously hates
matt turner i mean he's the white lawyer
writing down his writing down his
account and he says at one point you
know i the blood my blood curdled when i
looked on him you know he didn't like
him but one of the things he comments on
is he goes he's as intelligent as anyone
i've ever met
it's like what now this is this is sort
of this unsympathetic white audience you
go in and you talk to this guy for a few
hours and he seems really smart
um and in fact i think he's smarter than
either styron or um nate parker presents
him
nate parker's
matt turner's a little bit slow actually
it takes a lot of the violence and
awfulness of slavery to make him
recognize eventually slavery's a bad
system he's sort of oblivious and nate
parker takes him through this it's not
like when he when he fights back he's
really really smart i mean there's not i
don't see yet um william styrens is sort
of a smart conflicted intellectual um
but i think when you look at his
strategies and what he decides to do
he's always he's not playing checkers
he's playing chess i mean they've been
thinking about this revolt for a long
time and the one reason we know about
nat turner's revolt is because it
happened
and why did it happen when all the other
plots didn't
one of the reasons why because he
recognized the dangers in the black
community
you know if the word got out and too
many people heard about it someone was
going to tell their master mistress or
friend or whatever
you know by the way you shouldn't be in
town this weekend i know at that point
the whites are going to find out about
it
and that's one of the reasons why there
aren't a lot of slave revolts so nat
turner did something that was really
dangerous i mean this was a long shot
slave revolts are long shots but he said
you know what we're going to start with
no one
we're just going to start with seven of
us
no weapons no anything and then we're
going to just we're going to be we're
going to make such a scene that blacks
are going to join us and it's a bet that
didn't work but no one had ever tried
that before no one had ever said hey you
know what will the black community do
when
a slave rebel army appears in the middle
of the south
and it was worth i mean you know he
thought that was worth a try and frankly
if you're trying to think of how you
know you put yourself in the point of
view of a slave you're like i decided i
want to resist how are you going to do
it
there's not many better plans
so he he and er you know he's constantly
doing things that make sense until you
get to the very end
uh at which point there's no army left
at that point his decisions there's no
good options but before that he's just
doing stuff like he's bringing the army
together and he's breaking it apart he
recognizes what's going he's very quick
at seeing what's happening
um and and you know and that is and you
know and i think that that's got to be
part of his story i don't think you know
thomas gray is not making him seem
really smart because he admires this guy
or he wants to puff him up
you know he's really he he actually is a
really smart guy i don't think there's a
doubt about that
do you think that uh nat turner's
rebellion had a great bearing on
virginia succeeding from the union
30 years later well
um
my argument is it almost had a great
relation to it not succeeding from the
union 30 years later
if the slave owners weren't able to
convince themselves that slave property
that slave property was safe
you know that slave property wouldn't
kill you
eventually
virginia would enact a gradual
emancipation scheme as they discussed
in the immediate aftermath of the revolt
in 1832 they discussed a gradual
emancipation scheme now if virginia is
doing gradual emancipation
in 1830
the largest slave-holding state in 1861
isn't the largest slave-holding state in
1861 anymore
the civil war at that point becomes
south carolina and it's just completely
different
history is extraordinarily contingent i
believe that and i think one of the
things that happens is we want to draw
these direct lines uh nat turner's
revolt almost led to uh virginia
adopting gradual emancipation it wasn't
that close it was like 60 40 was the
vote but that's
that's 60 40 voting against their most
valuable form of property can you
imagine a vote in our congress 60 40
against
iras
not going to happen i mean
you know bernie sanders says yeah i
think we should get rid of him and
everyone else says no i mean it's just
you know that is um that's that's a
different that's a different uh uh
that's a different world so it is
clearly connected and if the
slaveholders weren't able to convince
themselves that slavery was sustainable
long term
you're not going to have the same civil
war so we have one more question all
right
thank you that was a terrific talk um i
have a question about um
nat turner's religion yes that is it's
always been hard to understand why
he killed so many women and children
um is there a way of reading this uh
rebellion as something inspired by
turner's uh interpretation of his faith
as opposed to
a more strictly secular
reading of this as a rebellion against
slavery one of the things that thank you
that one of the things the movie handles
well is look i mean if your old
testament if you believe the old
testament and jesus you know and god
comes in and takes out
you know one-tenth of the egyptians
you know it's not that hard to get your
head around the idea that god would
command you to do something like this
you know if you're just the new
testament jesus stuff that's that's a
little bit harder
maybe you throw paul in it gets a little
easier you know it's tough it's tough um
but there's no doubt he sees it in
religious terms he believes god told him
to do this i mean he thinks god talks to
him in the world and he's not alone in
that this is actually my smithsonian
piece is on this um but so he sees this
in completely religious terms and he and
he doesn't have a hard time
understanding it the bible would tell
you to do something like that actually
makes sense to him
what is the issue is
well why would they kill women and
children why didn't god just tell him to
kill the men
and that i think is actually one of the
strategy that he came up with and the
rebels came up with that was actually
pretty insightful
they hadn't done recruiting so how are
they going to get noticed
by the other slaves what can they do
that's so outlandish and it was killing
women and children they killed they hit
a school and they killed 10 kids at the
school um you know that's they think
they're going to show the blacks in the
area you can stand up to whites
now no one had tried recruiting like
that but there was you know this this
level of you know how are you going to
get people to very quickly see that the
whites are a paper tiger
and attacking their most vulnerable
points attacking the women and children
was one of it now this is also clear the
black you know the rebels aren't a rebel
force that all agrees with each other
um they debate this you know when they
there's a debate about when they they
realize that they left a sleeping child
at the first house a baby and they're
like well should we go back
and then someone says well we agreed
we're going to kill everyone
up to a point
after they secured some sort of
position they had secured an army and
some land
then they weren't going to kill women
and children anymore and that's also
perfectly clear from the evidence so
this was a this was a tactic this was
something that he was doing temporarily
and he didn't have any problems with it
because the bible certainly if you're a
religious person gives you grounds of
sort of pursuing this kind of policy um
so i think it was completely religious
i you know he's he's clearly sees it as
religion and i don't think it's very
hard for a smart person to square it
with with with the bible and i think the
strategy actually makes as much sense as
anything else
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
each week american history tv sits in on
a lecture with one of the nation's
college professors you can watch the
classes here every saturday evening at 8
pm and midnight eastern
next mercer university professor douglas
thompson talks about religion and its
impact on the relationship between
slaves and their owners during the
antebellum period he cites nat turner's
1831 slave rebellion and frederick
douglass's 1845 memoir recounting his
early life as a slave as examples of how
whites and blacks interpreted biblical
passages on slavery this class is about
an hour
okay so remember that we spent the last
couple of days working on
the way that pro-slavery defenses were
used but in our particular case the way
that they were being used using the
bible to make those arguments
and so we talked about these texts
already i'm i'm i'm pointing you to them
again to highlight why they mattered but
also to uh pick up on the last one um
fileman as a way to talk about something
that's going to happen within uh
african-american experience particularly
as they will read scripture
for themselves
and so the genesis 9 account is the is
what is generally referred to as the
curse of ham uh it's actually
the curse that's placed on kanan um and
we talked we ended the class last period
talking about the conflated story the
mark of cain
and the curse of ham
we didn't talk about because the reader
doesn't pull those texts together
something that's known as the
great dispersion
the tower of babel text is often used to
talk about why you have different races
of people
and so the genus i'm adding that one in
the genesis 11 account
and the tower of babel is an example of
a way that you can uh understand uh
difference uh
the different races that exist
the ephesians text
which is actually in a whole household
uh code uh both for men and women or
what husbands and wives and children but
included in that is slaves and what was
most often used is the idea of slaves
being obedient to their masters
the first timothy passage is similar
these slave codes the idea of how to be
a good slave
and then the exodus uh 21 exodus uh
chapter 21 sets out a whole
set of codes for how to treat slaves and
so in the argument
if if slavery is being talked about then
clearly it's being defended right
god if god didn't want slavery to exist
slavery would have been removed or
condemned it wouldn't be morally
reprehensible which is what
abolitionists were arguing
they would often use philemon as an
example of this and so we talked about
it in a thin way on uh monday
so i wanted to come back to it to start
for what we're doing next so in this
letter paul has a slave who has come to
him run away from his master in fact
it's a great letter in a lot of ways
because the slave has actually taken
stuff from the master okay
and so the slave has run away has come
to paul oneismus is his name
paul writes the letter back letter to
philemon and sends it with onisimus back
to
the slave holder
often the way this letter is used is to
say if paul had seen slavery as morally
reprehensible the slave has run to him
just keep him right don't send him back
to the slave owner
what happens in the text is interesting
that's why i wanted you to turn to it
then why we're starting here if you go
to verse 15 i want you to hear this
paul writes perhaps this is the reason
he separated from you for a while the
idea of running away
so that you might have him back forever
verse 16 says no longer as a slave but
more than a slave a beloved brother
especially to me
but how much more to you both in the
flesh and in the lord
the reason why i want you to pay
attention to those two verses is that
how you read the text in
has to do with how you're experiencing
this issue of slavery
so if you are a slave holder
you might put more emphasis on
so that you may have him back
forever
but if you're a slave what you might
hear is this part
no longer as a slave but more than a
slave a beloved brother
do you see how that one one passage can
actually work in two different
directions
except the person doing the interpreting
thinks the other direction's not right
right so a slaveholder says this clearly
points out that slavery should exist
paul doesn't get rid of it in fact he
takes a slave and sends him back to the
slaveholder so clearly
slavery is not morally reprehensible
generally speaking slaves will not use
this text as a defense
right
for why uh slavery should disappear but
i wanted you to hear that but not as a
slave
more than a slave a beloved brother
right so this passage or this text has
the ability to work in two different
directions
i'm highlighting this for you you read
it on for uh
class on monday but i want to go back to
it so and i'm not going to read the
whole thing what i want you to pay
attention to is the highlight
which is the bold part uh this mode of
reasoning that would uh uh perfectly
would be perfect perfectly fair excuse
me if the bible really taught nothing
directly about the subject of slavery so
this had been uh abolitionists were
arguing that the uh
the bible calls slavery morally
reprehensible but they argue not from a
biblical quote-unquote biblical
perspective
and so the writer that's an anonymous
writer of this article says that
the slave the bible does have something
to say about slavery right and the part
that's interesting is the no deduction
from general principles can make it
wrong
if the book is true
this idea of deduction from general
principles
is an important interpretive move
right and so here's how you would do
this
if you are making a general principle
argument about morally uh reprehens
slavery might be morally reprehensible
what you would do is emphasize
more than a slave in the text that makes
sense so what you're pointing to is that
the text doesn't say slavery should end
right get rid of it but what you would
argue is that paul actually makes an
argument
bigger right so no longer is oneismus a
slave he's a brother he's an equal and
in your that's a general principle so
this reduc by the way
slaveholders will argue no you're
playing with scripture
right that's not what is stated okay
all right the reason that's important is
that slaves became
a part
of a process within the evangelical
movement for why reading mattered
okay and so we're going to talk about
this some of it you already know
i'm i'm refreshing your memory and then
some of it i'm actually
pulling us forward a little bit
so
early on in the
18th century slave owners have an
uncomfortable relationship with
evangelical christianity right it's fine
if you want to say that they you somehow
christen them as babies but generally
speaking to talk about them as having a
born-again experience and for us or our
purposes it meant that you got a social
standing right you were given an
equality with your slave uh master if
you both have souls
so early slaveholders had had a hard
time with christianity or at least the
idea that their slaves could participate
in
in
evangelical movements
in that way
evangelicalism puts a strain on
christianity so i've given you examples
of this right in in small churches
baptist churches out in uh areas around
culpeper virginia in the 18th century
you have examples of slaves being able
to bring their slave masters up on
charges
uh that they were they had violated them
they had had done harm to them had asked
them to work on a sabbath which would be
a good charge to bring forward if i've
been asked to work on the sabbath
because the sabbath is a day of rest and
so it put
evangelicalism allowed for slaves to
stand on equal footing and this will put
a strain on slavery
that's a direct strain the indirect one
is coming mostly during the the
19th century
and it's about the power of reading
protestants put focus on
literacy
if the book matters you got to be able
to read it
right if the word is inspired if the
word is of god it's a important book and
in order to be able to understand it you
have to be able to
read it
okay
and what's
what's interesting the reason i use the
word inspired in the note is that the
holy spirit is actually
helping the reader understand the text
and what happens in this evangelical
move is that it descenders power so who
has control over what the bible says
the reader
because the reader is being inspired by
god through the holy spirit and so this
use of literacy the ability to read
mattered it was going to
cause great strain for
southerners in particular when slaves
were able to read the text and interpret
them
interpret it for themselves
which is why during the 19th century
you're going to see a whole series of
laws forbidding slaves from learning how
to read
right
that is connected the reason you want to
keep slaves from being able to read is
that they might be able to
one understand the idea of freedom uh
and language that they could read but
also in this particular case the way in
which uh they could interpret the bible
we talked about this before uh exodus
becomes a prime example of this right so
that slave owners during the 19th
century become uncomfortable with the
book remember on the previous slide you
have an example exodus 21 sets very
strict rules for how
uh how slaves are handled and so slave
owners used that to justify slavery see
how that worked
except slaves
saw a bigger picture here it's one we've
talked about in class but we're going to
talk about it again here right now
the bigger picture
is that
a group of slaves
people anointed by god called out by god
are
enslaved by an oppressive master
god calls out a leader
the leader comes to the master requiring
that the slaves be set free
and the slaves are instructed to
take from their egyptian neighbors
remember they do the golden calf how do
slaves end up with gold out in the
wilderness
they're taking it right
and so they end up out in the wilderness
uh and god apparently has chosen slaves
to side with
see why this is a problem so this is a
deductive argument right you read it in
big in
sort of in big terms and big uh story
big narrative and you understand it that
god has sided with slaves so if god
sides with slaves and we are slaves who
has god sided with
me
right as a slave
and so here's how that works one book
can be read or justified in two
different directions two different
groups can use it to make it make sense
of the world that they inhabit okay
the reason the deduction argument is
going to be important is that uh we're
going to turn to galatians
letter to the galatians and i'm going to
spend some time talking to you about the
way in which one particular verse is
going to become important for the
abolition movement remember i told you
the very beginning of class particularly
in the american south
if you want to win the argument using
the bible what do you got to be able to
do
you got to be able to read it but you
got to be able to line up
your
proof text right the number of texts and
if i have more texts that talk about
slavery and you don't have enough text
talking about not or about getting rid
of slavery who wins the argument
i do
or whoever's arguing for slavery
so here's the passage that i want you to
uh take a look at uh in galatians uh
chapter 3 it's verses 27 and 28.
i'm going to read all of it i want you
to follow along and then i'm going to
talk a little bit more about galatians
broadly
as many of you were baptized into christ
have clothed yourselves with christ
there is no longer jew or greek there is
no longer slave or free there is no
longer male and female for all of you
are one in christ
jesus
okay
um
so
here's an argument
for why slavery might be morally
reprehensible right
in christ there is no longer slave or
free
so it appears that paul is arguing that
the status that we share
jew greek slave free
even more profound male female all of
them disappear under this baptism okay
and so
if you want to work out of a from a
position of a deductive argument you
could point to this one part of one
passage you're not even talking about
the whole of the text
i'm going to talk a little bit more
about galatians
this is what you would have done in the
new testament class you'd spend a little
bit more time on it
and so i want you to see the context for
why that verse matters
so in the book of gala or the letter to
the galatians uh you have this very
interesting for those of you who have it
turn quickly to chapter one
uh paul and apostle sent neither by
human commission nor by human authority
but through jesus christ and god the
father who raised him from the dead and
all the members of god's family who are
with me by the way
in in the uh corpus of paul letters this
is a ugly opening
he is angry at them now on the surface
you can't really tell that but if you
were to read one of the other letters
particularly um
uh to the um
church at philippi he spends a lot of
time talking about how much he loves
them right and it's this long opening in
this letter he cuts to the chase and he
says i have been sent by no human
authorities jesus and god send me that
period okay why does that matter
um
you'll get a hint of this if you look
over in
the beginning of the chapter i pointed
you to chapter three
it opens with this you foolish galatians
it's actually a cuss word there um
what he's saying is that the church at
galatia has been caught in an
interesting
struggle between jews who want
christians to become jews in order to
become christians and paul if you've
been reading all of his letters who
argues that's not the case at all no one
is required to become a jew in order to
become
a christian right and so you have this
this struggle that's going on the church
at galatia apparently have a number of
people who have come and heard from
these what are known as judaizers have
heard from these judaizers and have
started to raise questions about paul's
authority right and so off the bat how
does he establish his authority
god sent me see how this works it's not
a flourishing opening he's not
the letter writing is a genre and so
he's going to follow the genre he opens
it but he opens it in a very direct
manner and so for the remainder of the
letter he's opening up this idea about
the way in which um
the uh
the way in which
faith
operates it actually starts to tear down
all the barriers that people put up
right
why is he making this case because there
are people attacking his authority using
barriers
right and so in the whole of the letter
he's pushing this idea about the way in
which faith uh moves us in a direction
in part
pulling us together this idea of unity
and so when you get to the 20 verses 26
and 27 or 27 28 excuse me what you're
getting is this build up to a moment
where he can make a claim
there is no longer slave or free
the slave holder
will not want that verse
being repeated
or and this is more likely the case the
slave holder will say this is not the
slavery that he's talking about
the important part for you is that's an
interpretive move
right the the interpreter the the person
making the interpretation is reading the
text and making it make sense to the
world they think they already understand
so the slave uh uh uh
a slave may read the text and say see
this is an example under christ we are
all equal and in fact early evangelicals
had made that same argument but by the
middle of the 19th century that argument
is no longer being made and so
that there's a change in the way the
text is being understood right
and so what you can do is take this one
to this is a deductive move this is what
dubose article is trying to argue
against you can take this one
passage and you can make a blanket moral
statement
and what dubose or slaveholders are
arguing is can't do that
can't do that at all in fact it's a
perversion of the word of god
see how that worked
if i if you make an argument in general
principle off of something that's not
being stated then you have done harm to
the text
the reason why i want you to understand
it is that
slaves generally had a different
experience
and their different experience suggested
that they were going to read the text in
a way differently from their slave
holding masters
okay
so
i'm going to give you a brief history
it's more historiography don't worry
about that word right now but it's a
brief historiography about the way in
which uh christianity and slave life has
been argued about or argued over so up
through the middle of the 20th century
for the most part uh
historians had argued that slaves simply
took on the european forms of
christianity that they encountered
right and so when they encountered
baptists they just took on the baptist
form when when they encountered a um
a uh methodist form they took on a
methodist forum when they encountered
catholicism they took on catholics
slaves played no role
in the faith that they were developing
okay
in the middle of the 20th century
a a sociologist more than a historian
but a guy named herzkovitz
argued that slaves had actually
brought significant types of religious
life out of west africa
into the slave experience
and that if you were paying close
attention to what they brought with them
you would start to see that they were
adapting christianity to their own image
that they were making changes even if
scholars prior to him had not noticed
them okay
and so
in the middle of the 20th century there
had been a move in the direction of
arguing for
uh slave life
in its full form
having this religious life come out of
west africa and but being planted into
north america in particular herschkovitz
argues this is all of the americas from
north america into south america and the
caribbean islands
for the most part we now talk about the
way in which this is a dialectic or a
conversation between those
experiences that came religious
experiences that came out of west africa
and how they form in
the slave culture that they are located
and so
today what you would do is you would
have people who argue still argue
forcefully that slaves did not take on
any form of christianity at all they
just sort of mimicked it or they
actually took it on so much that they
lost all of their you have those extreme
arguments folks are have become much
more comfortable with this narrow area
that is an adaptability that people in
an environment take on certain
characteristics but they shape them for
their own purposes and their own needs
uh so i'm going to give you an example
so what happens is the this idea of and
there are there are examples of slaves
who will mimic slave owners
the whole thing
slaves should be good and submissive
slaves there are slaves that say that uh
there are uh narrative essays uh that
that have been written um stories that
have come out i'm gonna tell you one
about john jasper about this idea that
slaves embodied everything that the
slave culture had given them they took
it on they held on to it
they didn't shape any part of it
however
there is a possibility that the molding
is very important and you got to pay
attention to the people individually and
how they're doing this so i'm giving you
two examples and uh if you'll turn to
revelation uh i'll give you an example
of how
the a text can be read in two different
ways even if their
experience is the same okay so slaves
here's the point slaves don't have all
the same experience across the board
okay
so john jasper i'm gonna give you some
background information on him uh he is a
preacher uh in the area just west of
richmond virginia uh he
uh is a slave um but he becomes famous
or notorious one or the other uh as a
funeral preacher
uh so in the middle of the 19th century
there's an uh an adaptation that's going
on so slaves actually if you were a
slave preacher you were able to move
between plantations fairly easily up
through
about 1830 so you could move from one
plantation to another you would probably
have to take some sort of
paperwork that said why you were doing
it but as a preacher you had that
flexibility you could move from place to
place okay
jasper actually grows up inside of that
kind of world
and he he adapts to the world that
changes when there are more restrictions
placed on him but jasper becomes an
important funeral preacher and so if you
ever encounter him most of you won't but
if you ever encounter him he is uh he is
noted because he preaches to white
audiences
that's the big deal
right so
an example of why slavery is not a bad
thing is that you have a slave preacher
who preaches to white audiences and in
good
evangelical mode he apparently had the
ability to slay people not literally
kill them but he could preach and they
would fall out
they were moved by the spirit here all
that revival language we've been using
up to
he apparently had it he had the ability
to preach
and his favorite passage
was for funeral uh purposes was uh out
of revelation chapter six
uh verses one and two then i saw the
lamb open one of the seven seals and i
heard one of the four living creatures
call out
as with a voice of thunder come
[Music]
i looked and there was a white horse its
rider had a bow a crown was given to him
and he came out conquering and to
conquer
so
here the text seems fairly
straightforward this is revelation we've
talked about this different periods have
used revelation in different ways
he was essentially preaching a funeral
sermon
based on the idea of resurrection right
what happens when the kingdom comes into
its full fold
jasper appears to have been very
comfortable within the uh slave system
now here's what's interesting about him
he lives to the 20th century 1901
and so you can actually trace out his
life uh into after slavery into
uh a free
period
even post
reconstruction period
he will continue to have this sort of
deferential response to slavery and
slave owners
okay
arguing often things like without
slavery i would not have encountered the
gospel of jesus christ
see how this works
historians would often talk about that
as a mimicking he just takes on what the
slave owner has argued for and therefore
has no role to play in the faith that he
is
he's shaped by okay
if that's the docile slave the other one
is a rebellious slave and that's nat
turner uh for most of you you may have
come across turner you probably none of
you have ever heard
about jasper
nat turner is also from virginia as a
slave and a slave preacher in virginia
and in the 1820s and 30s he has free
reign in a little county in the
southeast called southampton
virginia
and he's able to move around between
plantations
and in this ability
he pulls together a group of slaves who
agree
to throw off
their slave owners they are going to
rise up in rebellion
but he also is a evangelical preacher
and so we spent the last couple of weeks
talking about revivalism and the use of
visions and why those are important in
part to get you to turner
okay what turner argued was that
god through the holy spirit had given
him a vision about what life should be
like and it wasn't slavery in fact the
vision was to take up arms and to kill
slave owners
in particular his own
okay
and so
when matt turner read
revelation 6 6 1-2
he saw something different
so now look at the text again
what's he emphasizing if he's going to
talk about rebellion
go ahead and take a look at it
what does it look what is the emphasis
on
here
here the conqueror might actually be
him
right you take on the sword
to conquer and kill see how this works
one passage can go in different
directions based on how you are
appropriating the text or reading the
text for your circumstances and in fact
uh turner has this very in uh large
vision about the way in which uh an
uprising will occur uh it is not out of
the question uh haiti has already had a
revolution uh in 1803 uh in there is now
a black state right former slave state
in off the shores of uh
the united states and so the idea that a
a slave society could rise up and throw
off at slave masters
was
clearly a possibility for him
i'm going to
be careful for a moment
to talk about this as rebellion it is in
fact an
act of rebellion they do rise up he gets
roughly about uh 75 people accounts are
different it's it's one of the more
fascinating moments in history uh how
when he
supposedly confessed it was a white man
who wrote the lawyer who wrote down his
confession and so it's not clear that
it's turner's confession as much as it
is someone else writing for him what he
might have confessed right so you have
this
the numbers are probably closer to about
70 people participate in the rebellion
they do in fact kill turner's uh slave
master his wife and children
they go to a neighboring plantation they
do the exact same thing
all told it's somewhere in the
neighborhood it's under 20 people who
are who are killed
the effect of the natural rebellion is
long term the remainder
of the antebellum period this rebellion
stamps the american south and i'll point
out why that mattered real quick
the first thing that happened is that
slave preachers had greater restrictions
placed on them see what what happened if
you have the ability to move from
plantation plantation what might you be
able to do
get people together you can make a plan
you could keep it diffuse enough so that
the plan couldn't be discovered and then
you could rise up and you could okay
that was the first thing the second
thing it did so it limited the uh uh the
ability of slaves to move it's not like
they had a lot of freedom but slave
slave preachers in fact did
by the the near the uh
1850s 1855 1856 slave preachers do start
to take on
more
freedoms again but it's still limited in
a number of ways the second thing that
happens is that more than 150
uh slaves or
free people of color are executed for
the rebellion
there are in fact people in georgia
executed for the nat turner rebellion
they did not participate in this
okay
do you see how
what was happening is a fear
among antebellum
southern uh or plantation holders
that slaves might actually rise up and
if they could pull it off there and kill
their masters you had to make sure that
everybody understood that they were not
they could not do this right and so
there was an oppressive response so i
told you about this last week i'll
reinforce it here up through 1828 in the
commonwealth of virginia there were
bills being put forward for manumission
of slaves to end slavery within the
commonwealth of virginia
after 1831
there are no more bills being put
forward
so this
rebellion
shapes how
slavery during the rest of the
antebellum period is affected okay
all right
for today you would have read the
narrative life of frederick douglass um
and i'm i'm pointing him out here
because when we talk about the text on
monday there's some things i want you to
understand and pick up on uh slave
narratives are a genre they exist um
just like letter writing exists
when you all write emails there's a
you're following a formula even if you
don't think you are and so
uh slave narratives have the ability uh
to set up um
in the beginning you're gonna see in the
text an argument for this is written in
his own hand right the reason why you
want to make that claim by a white
person is that presumably a white person
might have written the text and given
credit to a slave or a former slave and
so you'll see that that genre had
already been put in place by the time
frederick douglass
has this uh piece published
uh but also uh slave narratives worked
hard to talk about how
horrible
the slave experience was
these uh
these uh
narratives were written and published
almost exclusively by abolitionists and
they were intended for abolitionist
audiences people who would have already
found uh slavery to be morally
reprehensible right but
douglas does some very interesting
things within that already set genre
and one of those is he spends an
enormous amount of time talking about a
woman who teaches him how to read
okay
and so when i talk about douglas's luck
he's actually not lucky
slavery doesn't make you lucky but he
does end up in baltimore which makes him
an urban slave in fact he has the
ability to
start to make money on his own these are
things you're going to read about he
starts to make money on his own
but what he gets
is this ability to read text
and his the mistress the one that
teaches him and she gets in trouble by
her husband for teaching him how to read
okay
but she teaches him how to read the
bible
and other texts right so he gets a
primer
or she allows for it let's put it that
way she allows for him to learn how to
read
this is his skill uh
douglas will tell you he's
i would say ingenious uh what he does is
he befriends a group of little school
boys white school boys and they all have
these grammars and so he becomes friends
with them and he gets one of them to
give him a grammar and so he actually
starts teaching himself how to read as
well right so it's both and
you're going to get more about the
narrative when you read it but it's this
idea about a slave who has access to
reading that allows him to change how
his life how he sees his life and more
importantly he will think of slavery in
opposition to freedom
uh which is something that has been
defined in the western hemisphere uh
well in europe as well but this idea of
freedom and so you're going to i want
you to pay attention when you're reading
the text
to see how he starts to define himself
as a man of letters about this idea of
being able to read to define who he is
what's going to be interesting for us in
the course of the class is actually this
appendix it comes it's in the first
edition of his narrative but it comes at
the very end depends what appendix is
comes at the end
and he makes a pretty uh important uh
statement about slave-holding
christianity
what he argues is that that it is
immoral in fact it's not even christian
so no matter how good a good christian
slaveholder was
they were not
christians
because they had not understood the
gospel
so
not not for general discussion but i
want you to think about it for a second
why do you make a claim that he doesn't
they don't they don't know how they
don't understand the gospel
right why would he make that kind of
claim
particularly when he has a slave owner
who presumably is pious and christian
who's helped him at some level to learn
how to read
what he argues is it didn't matter how
good she was she actually could not see
the system being turned upside down
right that the gospel was
supposed to
say there is no
slave or free see how he see what he's
emphasizing that this idea about the way
in which
a slave holder is beholden to
slavery
dictates how they're going to understand
scripture
or more importantly their christian
faith
and so in this particular case
douglas is going to lift up something
that we're not going to spend a whole
lot of time talking about in class but
if you were to take me in
african american history
history 363 or
the new south uh class that i teach we'd
spend a lot more time talking about it
which is this idea that white americans
have actually not ever really understand
stood christianity
they don't see it
they can't see it because their
experience is
not what
african-americans have seen or
experienced right and so he i i'm in the
appendix you're getting a small taste of
this you're going to see a way in which
uh a former slave makes an argument for
why
slaveholders could never see the
hypocrisy
and that's the last point hypocrisy
is often easy to see from the outside
right so so if you if you
encounter a hypocritical situation um
i.e a professor who uh takes images off
of a
website right
right and then claims credit for them
right that's a hypocrite because what do
we spend all of our time doing with you
guys
don't do that right don't do that
without that would become obviously
hypocritical but really the only way you
see it is from the outsider's
perspective and so it is
in fact douglas's appendix that's going
to get us closer to this idea about the
way in which slave holding whites
he also starts to argue that in a later
edition of the narrative that even
abolitionist whites can't see it
right but in this particular one that
you have that slave holding whites can't
understand the gospel
and they have failed to understand the
gospel okay
does that make sense
okay
okay
how does that work
well in this particular case
it works through the experience of
suffering
so we'll slow down a little bit because
this is this is how
the reading of scripture
uh forms
most african-american experience um
particularly with in relationship to
christianity
so
slaves could easily see their own story
inside of the biblical narrative
right the most obvious one we've already
talked about
exodus
right so that if you have uh a people
chosen by god uh there is an extra
burden on them uh but more importantly
that in that particular case god had
sided with the slaves and inciting with
the slaves they
themselves
were understood by god so the long
biblical narrative
was that you could ultimately
understand the slaves experience because
god understood it okay
what's interesting is the way in which
that exodus text and more importantly
the later sort of chosenness of the of
the nation of israel
is that that requires a greater burden
on the chosen
they actually will suffer more because
of this
you'll get hints of this even uh in
today uh this idea that um christians
are persecuted right they're being
persecuted for their faith that kind of
language but this is not about
individuals this is about a people
and that you have to recognize that
that's suffering that it
it is pervasive
and god recognizes it and when god
recognizes that pervasive suffering god
sides with it
right so even if we're going to get
treated poorly even if we're going to
get harmed even if we're going to die
ultimately god will
vindicate us
right so this idea about the way in
which suffering works
in fact most folks who work or operate
under this idea
they don't see an oppressor having any
suffering
they can't
they can't see an oppressor having a
loss
or some sort of
suffering that happens to them
but that demand on them
means that they are in a position this
is a
this is that part that i was getting at
with frederick douglass
that ultimately they are in a position
to help redeem the nation
right that their suffering and
experience is a way to understand uh how
god will refine the nation how it will
make the nation better
uh as long as you are willing to hear it
as long as you are willing to understand
it or engage it
um and here's the thing this is what
douglas is doing in the narrative it is
how the textual evidence from places
like galatian work as well
are whites going to see it
the answer ultimately would be no they
don't see it they can't see the
suffering as redemptive
uh for
uh the people the nation as a whole this
is what comes later uh and so what
happens in this particular case the way
in which the slaves take on the text
recognize within the text their own
experience and then try to help others
see
how that experience is being carried out
uh has a long history by the way it's
still with us um
in the 20th century you're going to get
a series of preachers uh um
and sociologist w.e.b du bois picks up
on this topic as well when he talks
about the veil uh at the turn of the
20th century that that
there is something being done within the
african-american community that will
make america better but it's got to pay
attention to them it's got to pay
attention to that that experience okay
let's take a step back for a minute so
when
you're reading the book of galatians
one of the things that you're going to
point out is this idea of neither
slave nor free
here's what i want you to do for a
second i want you to think about it
we'll we'll talk um
how does the slave owner hear that
passage
right think about that for a second
neither slave nor free
because we've been working on the slave
owner for a while right for the two
weeks
how does a slave owner hear that
particular passage
more importantly
why would the slave owner not see the
exodus narrative as connected to the
slaves within their midst
what i'm trying to get you to recognize
is so
they can clearly see the text they can
clearly understand
that their slaves might read it in a
different way how come they can't see it
from the view of the slave right
here here's the part where we we i'm
gonna have you talk a little bit or i
hope you're gonna talk a little bit
why is it that the slave owner can't see
the text
in the same way that the slave does
uh would it be because um
when in exodus the slaves are all white
and in now they're they're black so
they can't really see the same relations
okay good we'll hold on to that one for
a minute anybody else
there
it could very well be denial simply
because if that was in case true then a
lot of the things that they had been
doing to the slaves would very well
weigh heavily on their conscience and
which could very well do a lot of things
in terms of
social issues good okay denial
happy
could it be because they don't see
slavery the same way as it was in the
bible like with the hebrews it wasn't
it was different because it was
oppression versus of a like of an
um
of a religion versus oppression of a
race
um and so it's no longer about
oppression but the fact that their
property so their slaves like it's
viewed as a different form of slavery i
guess maybe
which is similar to the the comment
before anybody else just a curiosity
because those are actually all good
here's
yes
part of what i've been trying to get you
to understand for the whole semester is
is why can't they see it relating to
slaves because exodus is about whom
it's no longer about jews
it's about them
right the
one of the texts that that is early on
in american history is the idea that we
are a new israel
right and so if we are a new israel who
is
the st who's where's your place in the
story
[Music]
you're the ones who've been led out of
bondage but your bondage was where by
the way this is a this is a narrative we
tell our we continue to tell ourselves
your bondage was out of what
yeah
good
that would be the biblical story your
bondage is from where
yeah
european rule monarchs right and so what
happens is that what the way in which
they will understand the story is of
course this is not about slaves because
do slaves own slaves
no it has to be about the chosen people
who are the chosen people
we are and part of why i want you to
spend a minute thinking about it is that
you can't that's what we're working on
people will read the text based on their
own particular vantage point their
starting point is how they answer the
question so when i i asked you this uh
on wednesday monday excuse me
you guys were sort of
uh
flummoxed that that slave owners used
exodus as a reason for justifying
slavery right but what why were you why
did that
seem to baffle you
why did it bother you all that they used
exodus as an example of why slavery
should be defended
abby
god is literally supporting the freedom
of slavery so god is the one saying it's
my will that slaves be free so why would
slave owners use exodus as an example
for why people should be enslaved okay
anybody else
yep i mean that
here's here's the thing
they can't see
right
this is about us
right so they can use the text and it
makes perfect sense the problem is
you're looking at it from which
perspective
hindsight looking back
and i started the class by telling you
what story about exodus
yeah you gotta remember way back there
four weeks ago
that slaves read the story and saw
themselves in it right so you were
already predisposed to reading exodus in
one direction
and so you you when you get to it
okay this is really about slavery god
sides with the slaves except you're
looking at the slave owners from
hindsight so when you encounter the text
right in their use of it as a defense
you say
ah
that's not right they can't use that
yes they can
for the ver the very reason that they
see themselves as the chosen people
okay
and so by seeing themselves as a chosen
people the text is not about slaves it
can't be about slaves
it's about
us me right in this particular case it
would be about slave holders
all right um
uh
one last note uh go back to uh fileman
again
now after we've spent the time talking
about it we're gonna go back into the
text talking about the sort of the way
in which slaves experience attacks
remember this is not a text often used
to defend abolition
this will happen often continues to
happen even today people will
use parts of text
and leave other parts out you actually
have to pay attention to what they're
leaving out because when they leave it
out it's saying something like you so if
they point to this verse but not that
verse why did they leave that verse out
or in this case abolitionists don't use
the layman very often to argue for
abolition why did they not use this book
or this letter to argue for
abolition because what does paul do
sends the slave back right see how this
works so there's a reason why it's not
being used often but we're going to
spend a minute talking about it
paul a prisoner of uh christ jesus and
timothy our brother to philemon our dear
friend and co-worker to effia our sister
and to [ __ ] us our fellow soldier and to
the church in your house
grace to you and peace from our from god
our father and the lord jesus christ
remember i told you if letters have
genre there they have form there it is
it's an introduction it's like saying a
salute dear so-and-so
grace to you when i remember you in my
prayers i always thank my god because i
hear of your love for all the saints and
your faith toward the lord jesus
i pray that the sharing of your faith
may become effective when you perceive
all the good that we may do for christ
i have indeed received much joy and
encouragement from you from
from your love excuse me because the
hearts of the saints have been refreshed
through you my brother
for this reason though i am bold enough
in christ to command you to do your duty
yet i would rather appeal to you on the
basis of love and i paul do this as an
old man and now also as a prisoner of
christ jesus i'm appealing to you for my
child onesimus whose father i have
become
during my imprisonment formerly he was
useless to you but now he is indeed
useful both to you and to me
i am sending him that is my own heart
back to you
i wanted to keep him with me so that he
might be of service to me in your place
during my imprisonment for the gospel
but i preferred to do nothing without
your consent
in order that your good deed might be
voluntary and not something forced
perhaps this is the reason he was
separated from you for a while so that
you might have him back forever
no longer as a slave but more than a
slave a beloved brother especially to me
but how much more to you both in the
flesh and in the lord
so if you consider me your partner
welcome him as you would welcome me
if he has wronged you in any way or owes
you anything charge to my account
i paul am writing with this my own hand
i will repay it i say nothing about your
owing me or even your own self
yes brother let me have this benefit
from you in the lord refresh my heart in
christ confident of your obedience i am
writing to you knowing that you will do
even more than i say
one thing more prepare a guest room for
me for i am hoping through your prayers
to be restored to you
apophis my partner imprison my fellow
prisoner in christ jesus sends greetings
to you and so do mark uh aristocrats
damascus and luke my fellow workers
grace the grace of the lord jesus christ
be with your spirit
okay so here's what i want you to do for
our remaining time
i want you to hear the letter
right
if you will remember the documents from
defending slavery how do the slave
owners use this letter
for defending slavery
do you remember
when they point to it
they often refer to it in a way that
says had paul condemned it he would have
done what
he would not have sent the slave back he
would have kept him and he would have
said something about it right so that's
how it gets used
did you hear what's in the letter
for this reason though i am bold enough
in christ to command you to do your duty
yet i would rather appeal to you on the
basis of love and i paul do this as an
old man now also a prisoner of christ
jesus i am appealing to you for my child
onesimus whose father i have become
during my imprisonment formerly he was
useless to you but now he is indeed
useful both to you and to me
i am sending him that is my own heart
back to you i wanted to keep him with me
so that he might be of service to me in
your place during my imprisonment for
the gospel
yes
i consider it a slave could this be like
touching on like
like mulatto slaves or like mix and how
you should treat them
uh since
that is his son that he had while he was
imprisonment
um
most likely maybe with a female slave
uh and he touches on the fact that
he's gonna send him back but to treat
him as an equal rather than a slave good
the last part's perfect the first part
not so much okay he's actually adopting
him this is language of adoption right
so what he's but this is the interesting
part what he said is what i really
wanted to do was what
keep him
so what's paul
originally not going to do in this
letter
not return him
by the way it was going to take a
biblical scholar into almost the end of
the 20th century to start picking up on
this letter
and the power with which it actually
might have served an abolitionist
argument
so when he argues that he is his son
my heart
when i send him back how should you
treat him
yeah
the way you treat him
is the way you would treat me
now do you hear that language of more
than a slave
a beloved brother
right so here's here's the interesting
thing slave owners actually use
deductive logic
right remember that slide i put up for
you about dubose out of the dubose
argument
if it's not condemned outright then
that's just a deductive argument and you
can't do that with scripture
what had slave owners been doing
a deductive argument because the general
principle was the bible didn't condemn
slavery
see how this works
what i really want you to get out of it
because of what we're doing as we move
forward in the class is this idea about
the starting point of the reader the
person doing the interpretive
interpretation they are making moves
mostly internal but they're intellectual
moves trying to make the text make sense
so here is an example
onesimus carries the letter because we
still have it right
that means onesimus did what
went back
what's interesting
is that
it becomes an argument for why slavery
has not been condemned
but the letter itself
actually does make a statement about
slavery
right by the way this is that wonderful
moment when you are all good critical
thinkers
you can actually ask me why am i reading
it that way
because i stand on what side of the
slavery question
on this side where we've already
addressed it
right and so if we've already addressed
it and we now find slavery morally
reprehensible what parts of this letter
am i going to emphasize
right well or the the part that suggests
that
um
slavery might not be what paul's
advocating right so not just a winner
side but a i'm going that's the part of
the letter i'm going to pick up because
the next part of the letter says what
paul says i choose not to do this to you
i'm not commanding you to leave him with
me i'm going to let you voluntarily do
what
let him stay
see how this works
so the text has multiple places that you
can come into it and interact with it
and so the idea by the way this is how
we're doing handling history as well the
fact that you might have an interpretive
move something that happens at one
particular moment in a text and then you
make a judgment based off of that one
particular moment
there are all kinds of factors going
into that interpretive move
historical history works the same way
you encounter an event and make an
interpretive move off of the event
right so here's an example john jaspers
he's a funeral preacher i talk about him
preaching to white audiences
right i'm actually putting him in a
position to suggest that he might be an
accommodationist to slavery
jasper later in life starts to condemn
slavery see how the
the individual piece of information i
give you affects how you understand the
person that's the same way with the
biblical text and so that's what we're
doing when you turn this is to uh help
us move forward for next monday when you
turn to the narrative life of
frederick douglass the opening sections
that you're going to read there's not a
whole lot of conversation about the
bible right so the class has been about
the bible and i've been asking you to
find biblical passages and how they
interact for this one i really just want
you to pay attention the way he
describes slave life his in particular
he uh is a slave on the
eastern shore of maryland
and
early on as a young man
uh he hit the property will be divided
up the slaves in particular he will end
up in baltimore he later gets sent back
onto the eastern shore to work uh in a
pretty heavy labor
environment he ends up back in baltimore
baltimore's not a
bed of roses
at all but it allows him to be in a
position to
escape to get get to freedom
and i want you so i want you to sort of
experience or read a slave's experience
in this environment that's what i want
you to get out of the book
when we get to the last day that we deal
with the narrative life
that's when we're going to pick up the
appendix and the stuff that we talked
about today will come back up where we
talk about how slaves could read a text
former slaves could read a text and
understand it in a profoundly different
way
okay
are there any questions for me
for today's class anything that i've
talked about that was unclear or
something that you might want more
information on
clear as mud huh
good
go in peace
join us each saturday chair and current
university of virginia professor julian
bond
the most populous slave state in the
south prior to the civil war was
virginia the debate to abolish slavery
in 1832 and the 1861 secession debate
became critical showdowns as the old
dominion struggled to decide whether to
stay with the union or join the
confederacy author william freeling
explores both topics in the following
program which will run about 1 hour and
15 minutes
so well
uh i'm wade rawls the president museum
the confederacy thank you hugh
and good evening ladies and gentlemen uh
welcome to the 15th annual elizabeth
roller bottomer lecture all of these
lectures have been held here at the
university of richmond with the
co-sponsorship of our friends at the
university of richmond department of
history
we're all indebted to the roller
bottomer foundation which in this series
in memory of elizabeth roller bottomer
native of harrisonburg virginia and
daughter of confederate veteran and vmi
graduate
i got to get that in
john roller
elizabeth graduated from wellesley
college and married william bottomer
the bottomers were patrons of
educational and historical institutions
during their own lifetimes in the
foundation they established continues to
support many events such as this lecture
series
among the many other programs and events
that the foundation has sponsored was
last week's virginia sesquicentennial
signature conference at norfolk state
university
we are pleased that tonight's lecture
also bears the mark of the virginia
state sesquicentennial commission and
that's the little
150 button that i'm wearing
you know this sesquicentennial thing
seems to be taking off
last week's conference at norfolk state
was filled to capacity and all of you
know that tonight's lecture has proven
very popular we had
so many people on the waiting list
trying to get reservations and and
looking around this audience where
literally every seat is filled i think
we could have filled robin's center
instead
the american public is obviously
interested in learning not only about
the civil war itself
but about the causes of the war and the
causes of secession which are of course
two very different questions
people have asked me what contribution
the museum the confederacy will make to
this important discussion
i believe it is important to look at the
crisis of the union and indeed at
confederate history in a broad
perspective
by examining the words
and the actions of the actors at the
time
before they and others began to do what
our generation has dubbed spin control
this past february we co-sponsored with
the library of virginia an all-day
symposium on four american presidents
using presidential biography to offer a
long-term view of the crisis of the
union
c-span recorded and broadcast that
symposium as it will tonight's baltimore
lecture
one of the panelists for that symposium
was william w freeling
i think it's safe to say that many
people signed up for tonight's event
because they wanted to seize another
opportunity to hear bill freeling
speaking of the annual symposium let me
digress for just a moment to put in a
plug for next year's symposium which
will be on february the 26th that's a
saturday closest to george washington's
birthday
at the library of virginia
who was the person of the year for 1861.
that will be our question and we have
assembled a panel of historians to
nominate and make the case for their
candidates
and we'll put the final decision to our
audience a little bit like dancing with
the stars
the panelists include ed bars
william c jack davis
laurent lee james i bud robertson
that's a shameless teaser watch our
website for more details
uh this december the 20th marks the
150th anniversary of south carolina's
secession and kicks off the virginia
kicks off the civil war sesquicentennial
in earnest our speaker tonight could
deliver an authoritative lecture on the
secession of south carolina
or of any other southern state for that
matter
william freiling is the authority on the
road to disunion i recommend his books
by that title uh highly they are
available for sale outside
it's his magisterial two-volume study
with the first volume published in 1990
and the second volume only a couple of
years ago
his first book prelude to civil war the
nullification controversy in south
carolina
was published in 1966 and won both the
nevins and the bancroft prizes
with craig simpson he has co-edited two
books
that digest and analyze the important
debates that occurred in the secession
convention of two states
georgia and virginia
his most recent book showdown in
virginia the 1861 convention in the fate
of the union
published this year by the university of
virginia press provided the basis for
tonight's lecture
the rain got on my speech
why did we model things by asking bill
to include two showdowns in virginia
two debates separated by 30 years
primarily because looking at the two
debates in one lecture provides an often
neglected broader perspective on the
issues of slavery and emancipation
and secession
but also because bill has written about
this debate himself
and he is married to allison goodyear
freeling
the author of the most authoritative
book on the subject of that earlier
debate
william freiling is a native of chicago
he earned his bachelor's at harvard
where he wrote his honors thesis under
the direction of arthur schlesinger jr
he earned his ph.d at the university of
california at berkeley
working under kenneth stamp he enjoyed a
long and distinguished career teaching
at berkeley and harvard
the university of michigan johns hopkins
suny buffalo and the university of
kentucky
where he had endowed chairs
today he is singletary professor
emeritus at kentucky and senior fellow
at the virginia foundation for the
humanities and public policy in
charlottesville
known best for his works on the coming
of the civil war he took a little
diversion off of his long personal road
to this union to research and write the
south versus the south how southern
anti-confederates shaped the course of
the war
that book was published in 2002
and won the museum of the confederacy's
jefferson davis award
taken together his works reinterpret
both the causes of the war war and the
causes of confederate defeat
not content to rest on his laurels after
more than 40 years of path-breaking and
award-winning scholarship
bill has embarked on several new
projects including a book of essays on
the civil war and a reinterpretation of
abraham lincoln
i'm also proud to say that bill has was
elected last thursday to serve on the
board of trustees of the museum of the
confederacy
so ladies and gentlemen let me introduce
you to one of my bosses william freeland
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen the
question is will your flaws like that
when i'm done
[Music]
it take it takes virginia to come out
like this on a night like this
virginians love their history
and they are so right to love their
history
uh but one of the things that's a little
frustrating for me is that they love
only two parts of their history
they love the founding fathers and of
course they're all of the founding
fathers because such a huge percentage
of the founding fathers are virginians
and virginia had such a huge amount to
do with
making the uh republic making the
declaration of independence making the
constitution
and when you celebrate virginia you
celebrate the core of the founding
fathers so what virginian shouldn't want
to know everything they can about the
founding fathers
and then there's robert e lee
uh who uh was uh i think the greatest
general during the civil war the
greatest general on the confederate side
of virginian to his core who fought his
big battles in virginia who doesn't want
to know about the great lee
and the battles he fought
the trouble from my perspective is there
isn't the same kind of fascination with
the period between
and the period between is ever so
important in american history and ever
so important in virginia history
and particularly i think two crises in
virginia are absolutely crucial
incredibly unusual in our history and
pivotal for understanding um
virginia
and the union's history
for two weeks in 1832 the virginia
legislature actually debated abolishing
slavery
no other southern legislature spent that
kind of time seriously considering
abolishing slavery
and then for two months in 1861
the virginia convention uh
debated whether to secede from the union
uh and whether the union could be
could be remade
no other state had a convention anything
like that the debate fills four volumes
of george reese's magnificent uh
collection of the virginia secession
debates my pal craig simpson and i just
published a distillation of that which
is one-tenth is long for people to
recapture one of the great moments in
virginia history
i am absolutely convinced that any
virginian who understands these two
crises understands a tremendous amount
more about the period before that is to
say the founding fathers and the period
after that is to say the age when lee
predominated if you really want to
understand the things that you guys
already love you got to understand what
i love
which is these two
these two crises these two crises throw
a tremendous light on the causes of a
civil war they throw a tremendous light
on why the confederacy lost the uh
civil war and they throw an enormous
perspective on one of the great
elements of human life in any society at
any time by which i mean procrastination
and procrastination
is my theme for
tonight
and for all the wonderful things that
jefferson did
i think you agree with me that he
procrastinated on the subject of slavery
he did not wish to fully grasp that
subject he did not wish to dare that
subject he did not wish to disrupt all
his other good work by trying that uh
subject
and he constantly said i know slavery
should be abolished i know we're sitting
on a volcano i know we've got to face
this issue but
let the next generation do it or the
next uh generation and that is pretty
much the attitude of all the founding
fathers they tackled so many problems
they solved so many problems that that
problem they didn't dare solve
and that problem came back to uh to
haunt them
and virginia procrastinated and
procrastinated after jefferson for uh
in terms of whether this issue should be
faced and when you procrastinate you
allow other people to decide when you're
going to face an issue and how you're
going to face an issue
and it was a slave
nat turner that finally forced the white
virginians to face the crisis of their
society
i don't have to tell this audience too
much about matt turner
on august 22nd he struck in what can
only be called a domestic insurrection
for you count what nat turner did in
1831 by the number of houses and homes
he destroyed
he destroyed the home of his master uh
mr travis uh and his uh his ostensible
owner putnam a three-year-old baby first
he slid off
his his forces fedor slid off putnam's
head uh and matt turner uh and that
turner's forces uh killed uh um a
man a woman and three children then they
moved on to another house
and they entered the house of william
williams and they come in they destroyed
all the people there the men the women
the children and then they moved on to
jacob williams house
and they destroyed all the members of
that household the men the women the
children and they moved down to the
bowen residence
and that turner destroyed all the matt
turner's forces i keep saying that
turner but it wasn't that turner doing
the killing it was his forces ned
turner's forces uh destroyed everybody
in that house
including five children
in all nat turner's forces killed around
10 men
around 20 women
and around 40
uh children
and it's a precisely that destroying of
domestic households that was so uh so uh
so frightening about uh
turner uh and so intolerable about
mentor for this was supposed to be as
you all know a domestic institution
where uh where
the regime over the slaves was like a
family and that turner had always seemed
like a family friend some family friend
who goes around destroying all these
houses
and and virginians were for the moment
terrified and particularly uh the women
were terrified and they were asking
their husbands to do something about
this situation lest their home uh
uh be
destroyed
and so it's a black slave that forces
the uh white establishment to face this
issue but once again the white
establishment doesn't wish to do it
right away
matt turner strikes on august 22nd
the uh virginia
the governor of virginia finally gets
around to addressing this issue three
months later in december and he
recommends that something be done to
abolish slavery john flood
and the virginia legislature finally
faces the issue on january 13th which is
almost five months after net turner
strikes
and
[Music]
the person who above all else faces the
issue is thomas
jefferson randolph
thomas jefferson randolph is
tj as thomas jefferson's
executor
he's his eldest grandson
he has a particularly frightened wife
jane randolph who writes him and says
jefferson that's who she calls or she
calls her calls her husband jefferson
you've got to do the something about
this situation we cannot live any longer
on this volcano we cannot hope to
survive as a family we cannot hope to
survive
as a state we cannot hope to survive as
a culture unless you do something in the
legislature to
to face this uh problem
thomas jefferson randolph decides to do
just that uh and he precipitates the
debate in the virginia legislature after
nat turner and i repeat no other
southern state has a debate this
extensive and it comes only after matt
turner strikes and really forces white's
hands they can stall for a few months
but they have to face it with women uh
and men worrying so much about whether
nat turner and people like nat turner
are going to strike again and again and
again and destroy houses again and again
and again
what thomas jefferson randolph proposes
is that
in 1840
which is nine years hence
virginia abolishes slavery but they
abolish slavery in the following way
everybody born after january 1st 1840
will be freed the men when they're 21
the women when they're 18. anyone born
before say december 31st
19 18
nine will not be freed
uh and nobody will be freed in virginia
for eighteen years and probably
uh slavery will not be destroyed in
virginia for about eighty years
when you add up all this kinds of
arithmetic
so virginia faces the problem thomas
jefferson randolph
faces
the problem but
but
only uh 80 years hence another good
example of virginians procrastinating
about this problem
there's a debate
and the debate is fascinating and the
debate throws ever so much light on what
it meant to be a virginian what it meant
to be a southerner and what it meant to
be a slaveholder in uh 1832.
and the first thing that is fascinating
about this debate over slavery is that
it's not a debate over slavery
it is a debate instead about how to
whiten virginia
nobody argues in that legislature about
whether slavery is right or wrong the
whole argument is how are we going to
get rid of the blacks
the whole assumption is you cannot
abolish slavery unless you read virginia
of blacks
thomas
jefferson
randolph
argues that the best way to rid virginia
of blacks is my way because it won't
cost us anything
all the virginia masters will sell their
slaves out of state to alabama or
mississippi or whatever before that
emancipating birthday
so here is emancipation on the cheap we
won't have to spend a cent
we can free all the slaves we can wipe
uh slavery out of virginia and we can
wipe blacks out of virginia
with this magical uh plan that i have uh
devised
nobody in that debate
just defends saving slavery nobody calls
slavery a positive good nobody says that
slavery is a good institution the whole
debate is what is the best way to whiten
virginia
those who don't agree with
randolph
say that this is an immoral
way he wants to abolish slavery it's a
matter of taking our family friends and
forcing them to be sold down south to
mississippi
and georgia what kind of morality is
is is that it's a very dangerous plan
that is being proposed because anybody
not freed is going to be uh furious that
somebody born a day later is going to be
uh freedom uh
this is not the moral way to do it the
more moral way to do it
most virginians argue is to send the
blacks back to africa
to
to free them
and to give them a chance at a second
life as democrats and as christians
in uh africa and their various plans uh
to do it
their various plans to uh to abolish
slavery in virginia and use the money to
use some money to uh
to send the blacks that are freed uh
back to uh to africa and there's all
kinds of debate about that but there's a
problem
the problem is not so much money you
would think that that was a problem but
it really is not too expensive uh for
virginia to afford to send
slaves back to africa the problem is
will they go
will
blacks wish to go back to
virginia
the some of the debaters in the virginia
um
debate say uh
we don't care whether they want to go
we'll make them go uh and particularly
william henry broadnax makes that point
and broadnax does not want any
foolishness he is the uh he was the
general who was sent down to capture net
turner uh and he was the general who saw
the havoc that nat turner had roast and
as far as he was concerned you do not
wish to blacks to decide our fate any
further
we decide we will make them uh go and
people answer broad necks and say now
that's immoral
you are forcing blacks against their
will to
go
and so the virginia legislature debates
and debates and the base this meanwhile
the uh slave holders in eastern virginia
are extremely upset by this they think
this is just an invitation for more
blacks to rise in insurrection if they
find out that the legislature
is is debating this and the legislature
is all torn up about which plan uh to
adopt uh and
basically is a question of how best to
get rid of blacks in virginia not so
much to get rid of slavery but to get
rid of blacks the whitening debate i
call it not the virginia slavery debate
that's the first thing that's really
striking about this debate and the
second thing that's really striking
about this debate
is the big opposition that slavery comes
from western virginia
and i have to stop for a second to say
that virginia is a world uh torn at this
point before and after into three
different sections there is eastern
virginia where we are now the piedmont
and the tidewater where uh the
population is around fifty percent black
fifty percent uh enslaved
there is the middle area virginia the
beautiful valley uh right uh near where
i live uh one of the most glorious
places to live in all the united states
where there's about a 20 percent slavery
population and then there's western
virginia what we now call the state of
west virginia but which was in the
western part of virginia which has uh
anywhere from zero to ten percent slaves
an utterly different uh society and that
utterly different society is furious at
the eastern virginians not for having
slavery but for having a legislature
that's skewed so that western virginians
don't have an equal voting power it has
long been virginia's
constitution to have
to have the eastern virginia to have the
legislature mal portion so the eastern
virginia has much more power and that's
quite deliberate because they don't want
west virginia to vote to abolish slavery
and so
the issue western virginians say is not
whether blacks should be enslaved it's
whether we should be enslaved
whether whites should be enslaved
whether eastern virginia slaveholders
have the right to tell us what to do in
the legislature instead of giving us our
fair amount of slavery and a slave a
fair amount of democracy they give us
more than a fair amount of slavery
anything and by the way they use those
words it's not uh that it's unfair that
we don't have the legislative power we
should have according to our vote uh
according to our numbers it's that we're
being enslaved by the eastern virginians
who are ruling us without a democratic
vote
in the virginia legislature
we don't care if they have slavery but
we want to have white democracy
and if they're not going to give us
white democracy as they had not in the
constitutional convention of 1829
then we've got to get rid of slavery so
the argument is not
ultimately just an argument about
slavery it's an argument about white
democracy and whether white democracy uh
is is compatible with
with uh
[Music]
with slavery and then there's a third
surprise debate uh in the legislature
there's a sensible debate
about slavery
is not ultimately about about slavery
but about whitening it's ultimately
about white democracy and whether east
virginia is treating west virginia
fairly
and it's ultimately about blacks it's
not about whites it's about blacks it's
about how you can control blacks and
blacks have are having an enormous
impact on the mentality of this slave of
this slaveholding class as a result of
nat turner and as a result of the havoc
that can be wrought we like to say that
blacks had no power in the politics of
antebellum virginia and they don't have
any votes but they have enormous power
over their master's mentality uh and you
see it uh in in this uh debate uh and
the debate becomes a question of how we
can control the blacks which is another
way is to say saying that the whites see
that blacks are an independent asian
and can act in ways that are uh that are
uh quite uh contrary
so this debate over black's role and
over white democracy and over whitening
virginia goes on for two weeks and then
the legislature tries to resolve it a
motion to dismiss the whole subject is
lost a motion to uh to allow some kind
of anti-slavery proposal in virginia is
lost
not gonna table the subject not gonna
accept anything to do about the subject
more procrastination i think you will
agree with
me
so what is finally decided is we got to
see if blacks will go
so let's ah pass
let's pass legislation that uh that
gives free blacks in virginia the right
to go back to africa we'll offer them
free tickets and if that works then we
can move on to abolish slavery and
that's the resolution and what does that
do ladies and gentlemen that puts the
ultimate decision in the hands of the
blacks
they can decide whether they wish to go
back to
africa
and as i don't need to tell this
audience they decided not to go
and so there is no decision after all
this fuss after all this commotion after
all this horrendous
sense of crisis virginia cannot decide
what to do about the institution of
slavery it's blacks that inspire the
debate it's black's mentality that is
all that is often debated and ultimately
it's blacks that decide the issue in
this white virginia
then
i think you will agree that that is just
a wonderful background for understanding
the secession debate uh in 1860.
once again that secession debate is
forced on virginia
lincoln is elected president on november
6 1860. what does virginia do about it
nothing
what is the virginia legislature
when is the legislature going to decide
to
worry about what should be done nothing
meanwhile uh the uh the south carolina
hot heads uh break up the union on
december 20th and uh and more lower
states uh follow and at that point and
only at that point when it is obvious
that you cannot avoid this issue
the
virginia legislature decides to call a
virginia convention to consider
secession in the legislature if i
remember right meets on january 12. by
the way you cannot trust my memory
on any of these dates i don't believe in
reading lectures i don't even believe in
looking at my notes so as a result
sometimes i get little facts like that
wrong so don't quote me
and don't tell me my whole lecture is
wrong because it was january 13th not
january 12th
the
the
the legislature votes on january 12th to
call a convention now there's a big
decision to be made which is can that
secession convention by itself break up
the union
and there are two choices
you can say that a vote of the virginia
secession convention to to break up the
union automatically withdraws from
virginia's
consent to be governed by the federal
union or you can say that all the
legislature can do all the convention
can do is recommend a course to the
people and then the people have to
decide whether they wish to withdraw
their consent to be governed in a
popular referendum
as a result of forcing by
back up a second
what does the virginia legislature
decide about that
of course they decide not to decide
and they submit it
to the people who are going to elect the
secession convention in a popular
election on february 4th and on february
4th the voters are charged not just with
electing delegates to a virginia
convention decide to decide about uh
secession but also they're asked to
decide whether there must be a
referendum on secession after the
secession convention after the 1860 i
keep going at the the secession
convention
no way
it's the it's the 1861 convention they
had so everybody scratch out to session
convention that's a session convention
it's the 1861
convention
and the voters decide as a result of
enormous pressure by the western
virginians that there must be a popular
vote on secession uh after the
convention decides which i think you
will see is more procrastination
it's not enough to have the convention
decide there must also be a popular
verdict but as far as the western
virginians concerned and concerned that
is essential
they concede that a state has the right
to secede
that a people has a right to withdraw
its consent to be governed and switch
its consent to be governed to another
government but as we got to be sure it's
the people that do that
and therefore you've got to have a a
popular referendum and the west
virginians say in effect if the
convention votes to secede and a popular
referendum votes to secede as stupid as
we think that policy is we have to go
along with it but there must must be
both votes if you if you uh forget
everything i've said until now you've
got to remember that one uh that the uh
the the can the the um the people must
ratify a convention's decision
so finally on february 12th uh 1861
the uh virginia convention meets to try
to decide what to do about a convention
what to do about secession
and the first thing that happens the
first important thing that happens is
that the lower south commissioners
appear before that convention
and uh tell the convention what they
should do lower south commissioners are
like
how do you put it um ambassadors from
the lower south to the upper south
trying to tell the uppers and the
the lower the upper south what to do
i should pause for a second to say that
at this point that is to say when the
virginia convention first meets
one-third of the south is out of the
union two-thirds of the south is still
in the union two-thirds of the south has
not voted to secede two-thirds of the
whites in the south have not voted to
secede
the owners of two-thirds of the slaves
have not voted to secede and though the
confederacy is being formed it doesn't
have much chance of winning the civil
war uh unless more southern states
secede which is one reason why all eyes
are on this virginia convention which is
the only convention debating them that
aside the commissioners appear before
the virginia convention
they make
they make a very explicit argument
the uh
we have seceded
we have seceded because we think slavery
is in danger
we think if slavery is in danger
then black control is in danger
and the blacks will
riot throughout
the south unless we secede from
lincoln's immediate menace to slavery
i know that there are some uh in the
south who would like to deny that
slavery has anything to do with
secession they ought to read the uh
secession these speeches by the south
carolina and the georgia uh and
don't worry it's president obamacare
and if they read those speeches they're
not going to doubt for a minute that the
lower south seceded because they thought
that virginia was a menace to slavery i
defy any uh
person who who loves the confederates
cause to read those to read those
speeches to read the speeches in the
secession convention to read the
language in the secession ordinances of
the lower south and to say that slavery
had nothing to do with the causes of the
civil war it's just impossible
what is equally impossible is to say
that that's all there is to it
and you see why in the virginia
convention
for the virginia delegates listen to
that argument from the lower south they
listen to these lower communication
south commissioners with a great respect
and they decide on their name and their
first decision uh has to be whether the
lower south is right uh and whether
secession is mandatory as a result of
the slavery issue and what do they
decide most of them decide no way
that slavery is not in that great danger
that the union must be preserved
if we can
and what the
virginia convention becomes
is not a virginia secession convention
any more than the virginia slavery
debate becomes a debate on slavery
in 1832 that so-called slavery debate is
a whitening debate in
1861 the so-called secession convention
needs to be called a union convention
and here i got to stop for a second and
thank uh brent tarter uh the historian
of the library of virginia who first
pointed this out to me in an absolutely
brilliant outburst uh
while i was last in
in richmond and i'm stealing his idea
and you'll all be glad to know that
brent's idea will be fully expanded in
his book on slavery in virginia and
there's no book that i'm more eager to
read so here's brent's idea when you
look uh at what the convention debates
what is it debate it doesn't debate
secession it debates how to save the
union
and there are all kinds of options
before the convention about how to save
the union virginia can call a southern
convention virginia can propose uh
compromises virginia can do nothing uh
virginia canadian the convention can
adjourn for six months and everybody
will wait until they come back
there's all kinds of things we can do to
try to save the union and this secession
convention falsely called secession
convention ends up debating uh how to
save the union for weeks and weeks and
weeks the main debate is on how to save
the union at the very time when the
union has been shattered uh
and uh and other issues are intruding
and you have another surprise which is
again so parallel to what happened in
1832. you remember in 1832
what was supposed to be a debate on
slave on slavery becomes a debate on
white democracy
and in 1861 what was supposed to be a
debate on secession becomes a debate on
virginia taxation
and the west virginians keep saying look
we don't even want to talk about
secession we don't want to talk about
unionism we want to only talk about
secession we want to talk about the fact
that you're taxing us unfairly
and we want to change the tax code
of virginia
that is a that is of what you would
almost expect from a region that is not
really virginian in the same way it is
virginian but it's not virginian in the
same way that eastern virginia is
and the third surprise of this uh really
marvelous debate is not
just that they end up debating the union
not just that they end up debating
taxation
but
the third surprise is they end up
debating how to control blacks and there
is the most intriguing change in that
respect from 1832
in 1832 the menace was supposed to be
that blacks were going to rise in
insurrection
in 1860 nobody's saying that anymore
what they are saying is the blacks are
going to run away
and if they run away and we leave the
union we leave the fugitive slave law
and
the
chance of ever getting our blacks back
is
lost
in this debate over white whether what
white people should do ends up being a
debate about how to control blacks all
over again but a very different form of
black resistance
anybody who thinks that blacks had no
influence on the white population in
this period ought to read that aspect of
the virginia secession convention debate
well about one-sixth of the convention
is secessionist and the more they listen
to this stuff
and the more they hear all these
irrelevances as they see it coming up
and the more they see this stalling and
the more they see this procrastination
the angrier and angrier and angrier and
more exasperated they get virginia has
simply got to finally decide virginia
finally has got to make a decision these
these these guys who want to debate just
union or not have got to realize that
we're living in a different period
that secession has
started
and if we don't uh do something and do
something fast we're going to just be
swamped by history whoever heard of
delaying and delaying and delaying when
you're in the middle of a a crisis like
this and out of their sheer exasperation
the secessionist the few secessionists
in the virginia convention force of
debate on april 4th
1860 the convention's been sitting for
almost uh for almost
two months at this point
and they demand a vote and the vote on
secession takes place on april 4. this
mind you only nine days before the civil
war starts uh at fort sumter and
virginia votes two to one not to secede
two to one not to secede
nine days before the civil war starts
but history uh plays into the hands of
the secessionists at this point
in 1832 it was matt turner that forced
the decision
and when you procrastinate like the
virginians had about slavery somebody is
going to force a decision
in
1861 it's another somewhat another
outsider outside the ranks of virginia
white's that forces virginia whites to
decide and that person is of course
abraham lincoln
who decides that he must reinforce fort
sumter
and
sends a telegram i said excuse me sends
a
messenger down to the south carolina
governor saying i am about to reinforce
fort sumter if you don't fire on my men
we won't fire on you we'll just
peacefully reinforce the fort and thus
be able to keep it
but if you fire on us well then we may
fire back on you uh and that of course
is what happens uh civil war breaks out
at fort sumter on april 11th and the
12th and fort sumter is reduced
now you would think would you that that
wouldn't you that that would force the
virginia convention to decide no way
they still are debating how to save the
union and the secessionists are getting
angrier and angrier and angrier and then
it appears that the secessionists are
going to win because on april 15th
lincoln issues his proclamation calling
on 75 000 troops to subdue the south
carolinians and calling on 3500
virginians to march down to south
carolina
and and
and
and stop this secession as lincoln sees
it
nonsense
so what does the virginia convention do
it continues to debate how to save the
union at which point henry law wise
loses his call
we haven't talked about henry wise
yet but henry wise is an absolutely key
figure in this
he had been governor of virginia during
john brown's raid he had just finished
his term of governor he was probably the
most popular politician in virginia
after the uh great
virginia founding fathers
he was not a hothead really but he was a
man of tremendous temper
and he was just totally exasperated with
these virginians and he decided as an
ex-governor that he was going to take
this thing in his own hands
and then he did two uh
very very brave uh and outlandish things
first of all he organizes a corp of of
soldiers to go down to harpers ferry or
go up to harpers ferry uh
arsenal uh and uh the federal naval uh
gospel yards and seize those
installations
how can you seize installations before
the virginia convention much less the
virginia people have voted to secede
henry wise says i have had enough
i have had enough
and i am going to order the troops to do
that so so he sends
illegally
virginia troops down to start a civil
war in virginia
and then he marches into the convention
he pulls out a
stopwatch
and he says to the convention
at this
hour i have ordered the civil war to
start in virginia
carefully puts down his watch
moves back to ascension
and says if anybody denies my right to
do that i will fire my horse pistol
anthem i defy you to procrastinate i
defy you to stop me i defy you to do
anything but allow this to take place
that by the way is an exact replica of
henry wise's horse
[Music]
two days later the virginia convention
finally decides to secede and submit the
issue to the people
this infuriates the western virginians
who say we have not had a fair chance to
win that referendum that is required in
order to
secede we
do not wish to have a referendum on
henry wise's horse pistol we're trying
to have a referendum on whether
secession is wise and that horse pistol
is going to change everything in in a
voter's
mind
and it's just
patently illegal what henry o wise has
done and henry wise's answer is i've
done what you got to do you can't just
worry about democratic liberties at a
terrible time like this and there is a
marvelous debate
in the virginia secession convention
between hot head henry wise and cool
head john baldwin about whether what has
been done is a legitimate
movement mr baldwin please come forward
i'm henry wise people
you all know me
and i'm mr baldwin and this is that jerk
john baldwin was going to debate with me
on this issue and john will you please
mr baldwin i should say no i wouldn't
give you the name of john would you
please come up the microphone so
everybody can hear you
i desire to draw attention to great and
high considerations affecting whether we
are limited by the constitution of the
state
or whether these being revolutionary
times we are invested with all manner of
power
this convention is authorized to change
the whole constitutional state
not without the sanction of the people
the people themselves in calling their
convention together stated our
limitations
suppose they have required us to
submit questions back to them
is there a man here with a car of war
rushing over the people themselves
mr wise got to put on his glasses excuse
me
oh yeah
the car of wars rushing over the people
themselves crushing them uh under its
wheels when the whole frontier west east
north and south when the edge of every
bay and estuary in the bay is endangered
by a vision invasion will you tell me
sir that
whether the welfare of the people does
not require us to take the
responsibility of doing whatever we can
for their defense between now and the
referendum in may sir the safety of the
people justifies the overriding for a
time at least of the acts statues and
even the constitution itself
but not under our system under our
system civil war attacks the safety of
all the very vitals of the state the
happiness of the people and the
constitution itself now to tell me that
this convention is bound before it can
do anything
to defend the people before it can
prevent the naval yard from being taken
with all its immense stores before it
can capture the forts held by the
federal government among a people
destitute of arms to tell me that before
all this is done we must await the
sanction of the people is to present an
argument too conservative in a series
such as now upon us
the gentleman informs us that the
welfare of the people is a sort of
higher law known in free government i
deny it i deny that we have any higher
law under our system of government than
the constitution
i deny that there can be any welfare of
the people in violation of fundamental
constitutional principles
the gentleman seems to think that in
revolutionary times the great principles
of free government are all to be
forgotten
it seems to me if ever there was a time
to appeal to the great cardinal
principles of constitutional power it is
in a time like this
this convention like the people
themselves are under obligations to
observe the constitution of the state
until it is lawfully changed it cannot
be lawfully changed until it is
submitted to the people and ratified by
them
the argument of the gentleman and his
principles be correct we the
conservators of the people can do
nothing between now and may in the
referendum
let the people say instead
our convention has advised us to secede
in order to defend ourselves we elect in
case we elect us to see we will take the
law we will take the arms necessary to
defend ourselves we will take the forts
we will take the naval yards we will
take the ship ship tame ship ship the
ship timber
if we do this and take the naval yard
now we will have plenty of arms and
ammunition
but if we do not take it when we vote to
secede we will have no ships no musket
no ordinances no powder
the amount of the genuine's argument is
that we are to do nothing
that we are let the power go
the naval yard go the forts go all the
arms at harper's ferry go all this
because of a mere sticking point between
twiddley d and tweedly dumb
by what authority is war upon us who has
declared war the president of the united
states it is true is threatened to war
against the confederate states but is
not yet our war until we adopt it sir
what right have we when the people have
said that our actions shall go back
before them to bring about a state of
things that would prevent them from
having the right to pass upon it
they say revolutions never go backwards
and if we start without regard to the
proper limitations of power
we are in danger of emerging from this
revolution anything but a free people
it may be that we will make this war at
a disadvantage that constitutional law
may be unfavorable to success
but i would rather go into a war with
all the disadvantages resulting from
constitutional power than to throw off
the reserves necessary for the safety of
the people
i can never consent to leave the
principle of constitutional law
of limited government and of
representative responsibility and
restraint
to launch out upon any principle so
vague so ominous of evil is the
principle of the welfare of the people
in the name of my constituency in the
name of constitutional law
in the name of constitutional liberty
in the name of representative
responsibility
i protest against this tag
and that ladies and gentlemen is really
the way it went uh
and i have found i've been taking this
this whole subject to high schools
around virginia and i have found that
the high school kids really love this
debate
and seeing it all kinds of things that
are contemporary in their own lives
and they see the relevance of history in
a way that no matter how much i talk
they i couldn't
possibly
see it
the upshot of what happened between
baldwin and wise is that two different
people
two different groups in virginia think
that the issue has changed forever
eastern virginians think that lincoln is
trying to enslave them
that lincoln is trying to push them into
killing south carolinians that lincoln
is trying to rule them without their
consent
uh and when you read these uh wonderful
secession
excuse me these wonderful uh convention
debates you quickly see that anybody who
says that the civil war is only about
slavery only about black slavery are
crazy uh
what uh what these debates revealed is
that however much that might have been
the issue in south carolina
and in georgia and in alabama and in
mississippi the issue in virginia is
whether white people are being enslaved
by the tyrant lincoln and the issue is
whether
whether
white people should fight for the safety
of their homes against the invaders the
whole issue has been changed and changed
under the gun
as the eastern virginians see it
and the western virginians think that
the whole issue has indeed been changed
so that they are enslaved
they are not going to have a legitimate
chance to win the secession election
they are not going to be
able to uh to have the people of
virginia peacefully uh decide and the
eastern virginians after all the time uh
arguing about uh representation and
arguing about taxation have now decided
to force
western virginians out of the union and
they want no part of it
as a result of virginia is unique again
in what happens they finally are moved
finally moved to act this time not by
nat turner but by the lower south and
then by lincoln and then by henry wise
they are finally
they are finally
forced uh to uh act uh and in the acting
they caused not one secession but two
secessions the secession of virginia
from the union and the secession of west
virginia from virginia and that is
exactly what you would expect going way
back to the virginia slavery debate of
1832
the what happens in this convention
throws an enormous light i think on two
things
on why the confederacy fought so long
and so hard and so valiantly against
superior northern power the whites of
virginia are not just fighting to
preserve slavery they're fighting to
preserve their honor their power their
legitimacy against whom a man who they
think is a tyrant who has uh tried to
with will take away their consent to be
governed and boy will they fight and
fight and fight and fight until subdued
by the yankees
but there's another perspective on all
this and that is the perspective of the
virginians who are to who not feel
that they must follow virginia into
secession and they're two important
groups
and each of them is crucial
and one is the blacks exactly what the
uh secession what the 1861 convention
decides uh they might do
whenever the union army
gets
close
and the western virginians do not fight
on the side of the
of the confederacy and that parallels
exactly what happens everywhere else
which is another reason why virginia is
so very important during the civil war
four border states having one-third of
the southern population
having one-third of the southern slaves
having two-thirds of the southern
industry do not secede and fight on the
union side just as west virginians do
and uh and something like 180
000
excuse me something like 500 000 uh
southern slaves run away during the war
of those 100 000 about 100 of those of
those 500 000 about 150 000 join the
union army
and with
the 250 white southerners like the west
virginians that join the uh union army
that's 400 south 400 000 southerners
fighting on the northern side
during the civil war that's more can men
than lee lost excuse me more men than
grad lost
throughout the civil war for every
soldier that
union soldier that drops a southerner
replaces him you want to know why the
south lost the civil war there is a
crucial reason you want to understand
the sources of that reason look at the
virginia convention debate
that is what i mean when i say that this
debate throws an enormous light forum
forward onto robert e lee's era
and it also throws these two debates
through an enormous light backward on uh
jefferson's era and what jefferson did
not accomplish
but there's one more thing
as far as i'm concerned the reason you
study history is not just the enormous
color of the occasion not just getting
to know incredible people like henry
wise not just listening to wonderful
debates like the debate between wise and
baldwin it's also to find out things
about universal human nature it's also
to find out things about how human
beings behave about what kind of world
one lives in as a human being and what
kind of predicaments one will face
and i submit to you that a universal
human characteristic
is procrastination
[Music]
we all procrastinate
and when we procrastinate we all risk
having
powerful people who know what they want
control the situation that's why
minorities so often control democracies
that's why our children sometimes
control us
that's why
that's why
we get uh sometimes into wars that the
majority doesn't don't want
procrastination is dangerous stuff doubt
it
look at what happened in these two
wonderful virginia showdowns in the 19th
century thanks so much ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
new virginians make me want to cry i
swear
well i think i've managed to leave us a
few minutes at least for questions
we have a microphone that we'd like to
make sure that you wait until the
microphone gets to you before posing
your question otherwise you will not
appear on tv
excellent presentation
dr freiling
if you look into the causes of wars deep
enough you'll often find
the causes are struggles over
resources
wars of
imperialism are for controlling other
people's resources
wars of independence are often
for control of one's own resources
what were
lincoln's
economic reasons for
preventing the cotton states from
withdrawing peacefully from a
voluntary union and
how did he justify his reasons
against
the ordinance of secession that we know
is the
declaration of independence
as for what lincoln thought of the
declaration of independence your
declaration of independence uh
lincoln's lincoln thought and i think
that there are two ways to look at this
uh it is quite true that democratic the
government depends on the consent of the
government it's also quite true that in
a democracy a cardinal principle of the
democracy is you go to the polls there's
a winner and a loser and the winner
rules and the loser has to obey
and as far as lincoln was concerned
those
that cardinal principle of democracy is
violated by uh by what happens i've
often wondered what would have happened
if the south had not stepped in the
ballot by the south the south that did
succeed and not stepped in the ballot
box
and it seceded before the election that
would have taken away from lincoln a
powerful
argument that he had so are you right
that uh no people can be ruled without
the consent of the governed or is
lincoln right that no democracy can work
uh if the losers don't obey the winners
as far as i'm come we historians were
trained to see two two sides to things
and i think there are two sides to this
argument as for the first part of your
question uh resources there is a there's
an element of resources i think lincoln
is more concerned about this democratic
thing than his about resources
but lincoln grew up in
in indiana and illinois
he had his first great successes on the
ohio river which as you all know flows
into the mississippi river as far as he
was concerned that's a national river
that river that goes uh through the
midwest and down to new orleans and the
south is trying to take away that river
that american river that northern river
that southern river and reserve it for
themselves
and he says as a good son he thinks i
think is a good son of the midwest i
cannot allow that i cannot allow the
south to have control of the mississippi
river and that i believe is the great
resource that he thinks a war is worth
but i feel there's much more he's much
more committed to trying to prove that
democracy works
which i know according to your argument
he's only proving that doesn't work
which to me only shows again that
there's two sides of this issue thanks
for your excellent question
thank you again for your presence here
tonight my name is larry folk from saint
margaret's school tappahannock virginia
and my question is
roger wilkins writes of thomas
jefferson's initial draft of the
declaration of independence in his book
jefferson's pillow
does jefferson's inclusion in that draft
of a clause to abolish slavery tell us
anything about how far along the people
of virginia were
in supporting such a proposition at that
time
thank you
good question and i think the answer
is probably
clear from what happened in 1832 uh
which is the the virginians and
jefferson are very willing to consider
abolishing slavery they don't
particularly like slavery they realize
that it violates the declaration of
independence but what are we going to do
with the blacks
that is the issue that stops jefferson
that's the issue that stops virginia in
1832 and unless they are willing to face
that issue and solve it in some way or
forget about it and let blacks be free
in virginia no they are not ready to
face this issue
personal feeling thank you very much for
a great uh lecture i'm jonathan white
from the university of alabama i got a
question about the the referendum in may
of
in the introductory essay to your most
recent book showdown you talk about the
western virginians wanted
voters not militiamen to decide the
issue and i went and compared the voter
turnout for the presidential election in
november of 60 in may of 61 and there
were about 3 000 more voters in may of
61 than there had been in november 60
and that's also including some counties
whose returns have just been lost like
sussex for example and many western
virginia counties do you have any
evidence of
voter intimidation or
thing problems with the referendum vote
in may of 61.
there are by the way as you probably
know
such evidences of in alabama and in
mississippi uh in various votes on
secession
i haven't seen it in virginia
i think the intimidation is this
the intimidation is that war starting
because virginians are not peacefully
deciding whether it is better to secede
they are trying to decide whether
good virginia boys that seized harper's
ferry with henry wise's arms are
legitimate patriots
and that's a very different issue than
do you want to succeed the guy who
controls the issue is going to win in
democratic politics every time and what
henry wise has done in the vacuum that
the virginia convention has created by
debating nothing but union union union
when the union uh is so difficult to
save at this point a vacuum has been
created
and wise steps into that vacuum just
like a vacuum had been created in 1832
and nat turner stepped into that vacuum
and i repeat that's the danger of
procrastination somebody's going to step
in
good day sarah thank you for your very
fine lecture my name is bobby lamb
um as an historical curiosity my great
great grandfather william ballard
preston
was the key figure
in both 18th many
1832 debate and also the 1861.
and uh the debate in 1832 was especially
interesting because
uh william bell preston was a lawyer and
he made a very loyal argument he did
call slavery a curse but he also tried
to get rid of slavery by saying virginia
had the power to decide what constituted
property
and he said we could change the
definition of what constituted property
to say that human
channels were not property
and so of course he lost on that account
but he did come out very strongly
against slavery
and then
he had been a congressman everybody hear
that and that's so important william
ballard preston is against slavery you
know almost everybody's against slavery
in 1832 but despite that preston can't
do anything that's right
and then he was a a wig in the congress
at the same time that abraham lincoln
was so they became friends i'm sorry to
say
but uh
then
but then uh he was in no sir you're not
being fair to my statement abraham
lincoln
but then in 1861 he was a delegate
in the convention from montgomery county
and he was the leader of the swing group
that uh was not only give this lecture
no no no
i'm just saying but there was another
procrastination in which he was involved
with and that's when virginia the
convention sent three commissioners up
to meet with lincoln
george with random who was a grandson of
thomas jefferson who was a secessionist
alexander hugh holmes stewart who is a
unionist and we embelled preston who is
a member of the swing group
and they they thought that
lincoln gave an equivocal response and
it was right after
uh something's been fired
well he said he was going to enforce the
law et cetera but he didn't say he was
going to call it troops
and uh
and they thought that he had
prevaricated you might say uh and
william ballard preston was the one who
introduced the resolution for secession
right
so
and well that's because he's a friend
that is very informative and uh it
indicates
what
to me doesn't need indicate in the
virginians love their history need to
know their history or cherish their
history uh and you don't find very many
audiences that can and ask a question
like that thank you so much
[Applause]
could you give the microphone to this
gentleman over here oh
sorry bill charles here thank you for
being so entertaining
the thing which has me just bouncing
around this room mentally speaking is
where is the parallel between
then
and the tea party today
somebody want to come up here and answer
you know i've got a winning streak going
here though
[Applause]
well look whether you like the tea party
or not i think you see something of the
same thing to it that there's a vacuum
right now
that uh right now although i happen to
think more of him barack obama has not
seized the public debate
he has not acted in ways that
that
that force other people to respond to
him he has been a bit of a
procrastinator
and when you procrastinate you risk
things like the tea party and to me it's
another example of the same darn thing
what do you think
i think i'm glad you're up there and i'm
over here
it's not so it's not so unsafe up here i
got my pistol
why don't we do one more bill there was
somebody in the in the back with the
question uh if we get the mic
yes could you speak a little bit more
towards the issue of the discontent of
the counties in western virginia over
property what constituted property and
how property was taxed
especially in the 1840s and 50s please
very good question i'm sorry i had to
gloss over that
needed to get to get onto my pistol
the constant the virginia constitution
of 1850 declares that slaves for the
purposes of taxation
slaves cannot be valued for more than
300 hours
and and slave children cannot be taxed
at all
a slave child at this point is worth
about
dollars an adult slave is worth about
fifteen hundred dollars
so the eastern virginians are getting a
huge tax break uh as a result of this
constitution and the eastern virginians
make clear in the convention that that
is deliberate and then it's not so much
that they're trying to line their
pockets
they say uh it's that they're trying to
stop west virginians from killing
slavery by taxing it
and
they will they will they will stick to
their guns if they can uh and uh
and save that that principle as far as
the western virginians are concerned
these guys are really being foolish
they want us to fight their bottle in a
civil war and have our property taxed
more than their property
can't stand those people
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
every weekend on c-span 3 experience
american history tv 48 hours of people
and events
[Music]
the confessions of nat turner is william
styron's pulitzer prize-winning novel
based on the true story of an abortive
slave rebellion in 1831
the book was reissued last year by
random house with its original cover
now from the boston public library mr
styron is joined by history professor
sheldon hackney and economics professor
glenn c lowery for discussion on the
book and the controversy surrounding its
1967 publication
this program runs an hour and a half
hi
good afternoon
my name is shoshana paxiarz and you'll
be tested on this afterwards
and i am the executive director of the
new center for arts and culture
it is my great pleasure to welcome you
to this very special event of the words
on fire festival
in which robert brewstein
founder of the american repertory
theater and inductee to the theater hall
of fame
talks with pulitzer pulitzer
prize-winning author william styron
with university of pennsylvania
professor and former chairman of the
national endowment for the humanities
sheldon hackney and with boston
university professor and social critic
glenn lowry about the issues surrounding
the controversy around the publication
of mr styron's novel the confession of
nat turner as a starting point of the
conversation
the words on fire festival launches the
new center for arts and culture
a groundbreaking new institution in
boston
two years in the making that has now
become a wonderful reality
the mission of the new center for arts
and culture is to build community by
exploring jewish culture and the
interconnectedness of all cultures
words on fire is an eight-week festival
that explores themes evoked by the 1933
book burnings in berlin
on the occasion of the 70th anniversary
we are presenting a rich array of
programs including art exhibits films
readings these lectures and conversation
series and a number of special events so
for a full schedule please take a words
on fire brochure at the information
table
in the foyer just outside the doors and
visit our website www dot words on fire
wordsonfireboston.com
there are many individual individuals
and organizations that helped make the
new center for arts and culture and the
words on fire festival this wonderful
reality
we are genuinely indebted to them
in the interest of time i will not name
them all
and you will be very happy about that
but please look them up in the words on
fire brochure so you know who they are
i will only thank by name the boston
public library this amazing institution
that is providing a home to so many
words on fire events
and of course we are deeply grateful to
our distinguished panelists
and now it is my privilege to introduce
to you your host for the afternoon who
in turn will introduce the panel
mr robert brewstein is the founding
director of the yale repertory and the
american repertory theaters
where he has supervised well over 200
productions
acting in eight i didn't know that part
and directing 12 including his own
adaptations of the father ghosts the
chancelling and the trilogy of
pirandelo's works six characters in
search of an author
right you are if you think you are and
tonight we improvise
he has written 11 adaptations
for the american repertory theater and
is the author of 13 books on theater and
society including re-imagining american
theater the theater of revolt making
scenes
a memoir of his yells years when he was
dean of the drama school who needs
theater a collection of reviews and
essays for which he received his second
george jean nathan award for dramatic
criticism democracy in america and
cultural calisthenics his latest book
the siege of the arts was released in
2001.
bruce stein also served for 20 years as
director of the lobe drama center and is
professor of english at harvard and
drama critic for the new republic he's a
recipient of numerous awards
like the george pork award in journalism
the elliot norton award for professional
excellence in boston theater the new
england theater conferences 1985 annual
award for outstanding created
achievement in the american theater the
1995 american academy of arts and
letters award for contribution to world
theater
from the egyptian government
and on and on i know that i'm going too
long you have lived a too rich a life to
introduce you
a rich life
his six characters in search of an
author won the boston theater award for
best production in 1996.
brewstein is a member of the american
academy of arts and letters
and of at the american academy of arts
and science and as i said before an
inductee to the american theater hall of
fame
mr brewstein has honored us by serving
in the planning
task force of the new center for arts
and culture and we thank you very much
for shaping this institution
please join me in welcoming mr robert
bluestein
[Applause]
we are very privileged this afternoon to
have three very distinguished uh
panelists with us
uh who need less introduction than i do
since they're much better known
uh but i will try to introduce them the
format of the afternoon will be as
follows um each of the panelists will
speak for 10 to 15 minutes
then they'll be interchanged among the
panelists for perhaps another 20 or 30
minutes and then we'll open up
for questions and challenges from the
floor asking you only that you move to
one of these microphones which are
situated down at the bottom of the uh of
the auditorium
uh the whole afternoon should take no
longer i would think then an hour and a
half perhaps an hour and 45 minutes
but allow me uh for the moment to
introduce briefly first william styron
and they will speak in the order in
which they're introduced
uh who was born in newport news in 1945
and who is a world famous author of any
number of books
starting with his first novel lie down
in darkness which
uh took him two and a half years
uh to write
with and and the climax of the novel is
is justly famous
uh it won a uh national uh book it won a
pulitzer prize i believe it didn't work
free to rome
uh and he is now wearing i want to
correct you you took 20 years off
[Music]
i wish it were true
did i say you took two and a half years
to yeah or that you were born in 1925
right near your friend i'm trying to
shorten your life
you're just trying to especially
uh
bill also helped to launch the paris
review
uh he published the long march a novella
which was a short novella though a long
march and a large-scale novel called set
this house on fire in 1960 and it was in
1967
that is highly controversial the
confessions of nat turner was written a
novel that entered the mind of a
mysterious black man who uh has led the
only significant rebellion in the
history of black slavery it was
published to rave reviews and met almost
immediate controversy
it won the house medal from the american
academy for arts and letters in 1970 and
in 1979
mr steyron published his fourth novel
sophie's choice
an extraordinary account of the
holocaust which was recently made into
an opera produced at
covent garden and i believe it will be
coming to this country within a couple
of years you must see it it won an
american book award
uh in the summer of
1985 uh bill was struck by clinical
depression
and his recovery
uh thank heaven resulted in uh one of
his most brilliant achievements which
was darkness visible a memoir of madness
published in 1990 it first appeared in
the shorter version in vanity fair to
enormous acclaim and won a national
magazine award a tidewater mourning
three tales from youth told the voice of
a young boy
was published in 1993.
next on bill's right is his and my good
friend sheldon hackney who as professor
of u.s history at the university of
pennsylvania
specializes in the history of the
american south since the civil war
out of an interest in american utopias
and other social movements comes his
emphasis on the civil rights movement in
particular and the 1960s in general
which he frequently pursues in seminars
he is at work on a book now about the
american identity from pre-colonial days
to the present which is the subject of
electric cause among the articles and
books on history that he has published
are populism to progressivism in alabama
which won the albert j beveridge award
he is the former president of both
tulane university and the university of
pennsylvania and of course became the
chairman now the former chairman of the
national endowment for the humanities he
has recently published a book
uh whose title should be self-evident
and which may very well be the subject
of one of his of the discussion tonight
called the politics of presidential
appointments very happy to welcome
uh professor hackney and on sheldon's
right is glenn lowery
who is currently university professor
of economics
and director of the institute on race
and social division at boston university
previously he has taught economics at
harvard northwestern and the university
of michigan
as a prominent social critic and public
intellectual
he has published essays on racial
inequality and social policy and dozens
of influential journals of public
television uh of public affairs both in
the u.s and abroad professor lowry is a
frequent commentator on national radio
and television a much sought-after
public speaker and adviser on social
issues to business and political leaders
throughout the country he's a
contributing editor to the new republic
the editor which by the way is my
stepson peter beinart
he's a member of the publication
committee of the public interest a
member of the council on foreign
relations
his most recent book is the anatomy of
racial inequality which appeared in
february 2002 from harvard university
we're very happy to welcome lindsay
lowery
uh
i would just like to say that this panel
takes place in the context of the
multi-site festival sponsored by the new
center for arts and culture which is
called words on fire and it's a festival
as you know that has been evoked by the
70th anniversary of the burning of the
books in germany in 1933
and since that unspeakable assault on
language thought
imagination and free expression there
have been
a large number of similar book burnings
in the world both real and metaphorical
the worst by far was the treatment of
dissenting literary figures and
heretical works in the soviet union
starting in the twenties and lasting
until the time of glasnost in the
eighties vladimir bokoff and yvonne
boonen had the good sense to get the
hell out of russia right after the
revolution
but under stalin's regime alone isaac
babel died in a concentration camp
maya hold was executed vladimir
myakovsky committed suicide anna
was denounced and expelled from the
union of writers
synovsky and danielle languished in the
gulag
joseph brodsky and alexander
solzhenitsyn was sent into exile
boris passed an off passing act was
muffled and prevented even from picking
up his nobel prize for dr zhivago
this pattern of artistic repression
spread well beyond soviet borders to the
entire soviet bloc where it was
responsible among others for the exile
of the czech writer milan kundera and
the suicide of the pole tadious borowski
it goes without saying that the mind of
totalitarianism
is unable to tolerate any deviation from
prevailing articles of faith or dominant
ideologies whether political or
religious
the ayatollah khamenei famously put a
price on the head of salman rushdie for
what he presumed to be irreverent
remarks about the prophet muhammad in
the satanic verses and the chinese
communist government
imprisoned dissident thinkers and even
ran tanks over the bodies of students
protesting the regime in tiananmen
square
there is a sense in which this
suppression of dissidents by
totalitarian regimes
is a living testimony to the importance
of the creative and the critical
instinct
and intellect
in democratic countries such as our own
which are relatively open societies
it is often said that freedom of speech
is a sign of its insignificance
philip roth once wrote
i'm trying to quote him correctly that
in totalitarian countries nothing is
permitted and everything matters
whereas in the united states everything
is permitted and nothing matters
he said that about 25 years ago
and since that time apparently a lot of
things have begun to matter to judge by
the amount of censorship if not
precisely a book burning that we have
begun to experience here
of course religious fundamentalism in
this country has always been a potential
source of censorship
darwin for an obvious example has been a
red flag to creationists since the
origin of the species was published in
the celebrated scopes trial clarence
darrow and william jennings brian locked
horns and broke spears over a high
school teacher's right to teach
evolution in the classroom and today we
finally have a president in the white
house who actually believe that the
earth was created in six days
possibly because he has the power now to
end it in less than five
as a result countless works of art and
thought have become victims of the moral
certitudes of the religious right any
number of books have been prescribed in
any number of classrooms this may be
trespassing on the material of next
week's panel
which involves three gay playwrights
here in the same room but it wasn't long
ago when terence mcnally's play about a
homosexual jesus corpus christi so
offended certain members of the catholic
church that they threatened to blow up
the manhattan theater club and kill the
theater's directors lynn meadows and
barry grove
now clearly the luxury of free speech
has not been a universal privilege
extended to every group in america
most notably excluded were black slaves
in the 19th century whose verbal and
literary expression was forced into
furtive corridors by the conditions of
captivity
and liberals communists and fellow
travelers in the 20th century were
hauled up for interrogation by the house
and american activities committee
largely for the sin of writing bad
screenplays and with progressive
overtones
the very name of this committee is
incompatible with the rights afforded
under the first amendment unamerican
recently however some members of the
very same groups discriminated against
in the past have begun to practice their
own form of discrimination
the jewish anti-defamation league for
example
was originally formed quite correctly as
a watchdog agency designed to monitor
any signs of prejudice against the
jewish people
but for all its positive value
the jdl began to put limits not just on
hateful actions but on what was
construed as hateful speech thus
becoming the model for many racial
sexual and ethnic groups eager to expose
prejudice and defend wounded
sensibilities
inevitably some of these were going to
see prejudice and defamation where it
didn't exactly exist
most famously mark twain's huckleberry
finn perhaps the greatest work of
american literature became an object of
controversy excluded from many
classrooms primarily because it used a
racial epithet no longer utterable
except by black people themselves
today many works of
by white american and european males
have been removed from reading lists and
colleges and high schools for similar
reasons
william styron's confessions of nat
turner while not suppressed or censored
was vigorously assailed by radical black
and communist critics with styron
himself exposed to abuse whenever he
appeared in public
some were offended by a homosexual
incident in the book some objected that
a black hero had become the fictional
property of a white man but the freedom
to differ and criticize had turned into
the impulse to suppress
and censor
the desire to burn or bury books and is
not the exclusive province either of the
political left or the political right
it may be a province of politics itself
the action of a tyrannical majority
against the dissenting individual which
often finds expression by muffling what
is troubling or provocative and that is
what we hope to discuss tonight through
the contributions of these three
splendid thinkers and artists each of
them as a result of political
correctness or moral correctness has
collided with groups of individuals who
would suppress thought i'm very happy
now to
turn over this meeting to mr william
styron thank you
i want to
thank you for that very elegant
pre-sea of
the problem we're addressing
this afternoon it was beautifully done
i might add that i have a sense of
being here of deja vu
if i may use a french expression
in recollecting
how and back in my college days in the
40s
um
i was amazed to discover that a favorite
book of mine that i've been reading
the edmond wilson's
the memoirs of hecate county
had been banned in boston
the venue of our
discussion today and i think it's a
lovely irony that this
this conference should be taking place
in the city which at one time was
unbelievably high bound
and sensorious as
the puritans themselves
i
would have a lot to say impromptu but i
can say it better
by
reading a very brief excerpt
from an essay i wrote some time ago
about the
controversy over
the confessions of nat turner
this will be just an abridged uh
version of the
essay i wrote
which was
incorporated into the
introduction of the modern library
edition of the confessions of nat turner
in the early 1970s several years after
my novel appeared
two historians named seymour l gross
and eileen bender published a long essay
entitled history
politics and literature
the myth of nat turner
the essay was a carefully argued defense
against the attacks
on the confessions of nat turner which
were chiefly embodied in a polemical
book called
william styrens nat turner 10 black
writers respond
professor's growth and bender made the
interesting point
that as a result of the extraordinary
denunciation i had received
my book had been cast as far as black
people were concerned
into the abyss
they they said
like the white school children in south
carolina
at the turn of this century
who had to take an oath never to read
uncle tom's cabin because there was no
truth
in mrs stowe
present-day blacks are being similarly
assured that they can safely despise
mr steyron's book without having to read
it
there is a curious element of prophecy
embedded in this statement
because much of the status the limbo
kind of status of my book
has extended at least insofar as black
readers have been
affected
has extended until the present day as
recently as
10 or 12 years ago
paulie marshall
a black writer and a reputable one
was quoted in the new york times book
review
where she was playing one of those games
by which writers were asked in this case
books i never finished reading you know
moby dick and
proust so on
as saying that she never even started
reading
the confessions of nat turner since she
had been assured that the work was
racist
this from a woman who was also professor
the distinguished virginia university
and presumably
receptive to the idea of free inquiry
the racist tag was fixed to the novel
soon after the publication of the ten
black writers book
which appeared this summer after i
that summer
the book was published by boston's own
beacon press
under the auspices of the unitarian
universalist association
a high-minded group ostensibly dedicated
to preserving
the truth
[Applause]
the this collection
which contain critical pieces by largely
well-known black intellectuals from
various disciplines that is english
sociology psychiatry history
along with several critics and fiction
writers was an extraordinary book by any
standard a collective creed occur
another french phrase
of throbbing pain and rage
its overall lament was that i had
written a malicious work
deliberately falsifying history that was
an affront to black people everywhere
the volume received great attention
front page of the new york times book
review
two consecutive reviews in the daily
times and so forth
there's nothing restrained about the
assault i was labeled
i quote psychologically sick
morally senile
and was accused of possessing a vile
racist
imagination
major complaint was apparent from the
book's first sentence how dare a white
man write so intimately of the black
experience
even presuming to become become that
turner by speaking in the first person
following close upon this indictment
were other charges
that i had concocted a demeaning sexual
connection between that turner and a
white girl
that i had missed the beauty of the
afro-american idiom that i had created
an indecisive and emasculate wimp
rather than the stalwart figure of
history
that the text reflected in a proving
view of the paternalism of slavery
that my description of a fleeting
homoerotic episode in adolescence meant
that i regarded regarded nat as a quote
raving homosexual
that i had failed to give him a wife
that the secret agenda of the entire
work
was to demonstrate how the black
struggle for freedom was forever doomed
to failure
the bill of particulars was interminable
virtually nothing in my work
according to these inquisitors had merit
the most innocuous and tangential
aspects of the novel this received
scathing
treatment there was never a mention
anywhere in the book that i might have
at least
several points in the narrative
describe the agony and the humiliation
and the degradation of the institution
of slavery
a couple of the essays a bit less irate
than the others
were at least well considered they had
in common the conviction that i had
somehow missed
the religious and emotional center of
the black experience
they may have been right
i knew from the beginning the hazards of
setting
foot in exotic territory
and was aware that even though i was
dealing with long ago virginia instead
of say harlem
or watts about which i would never have
been able to write with authority
my stranger's perspective might not
always ring true to black people
one of these more rational critics who
called matt turner a tragedy
in the non-complementary sense
and my figure of nat of nat a quote
caricature
expressed the general hurt and
frustration he shared with his fellows
by saying this
styron has created another chapter in
our long
and common agony
he has done it because we have allowed
it
and we who are black must be men enough
to admit the bitter fact
there can be no common history until we
have first fleshed out the lineaments of
our own
for no one else can speak out of the
bittersweet bowels
of our blackness unquote
right or wrong this was a civilized
sentiment
which i could at least take seriously
but the prevailing tone was strident and
harsh
sounding very much like the agit prop
flatulence of the 1930s
over the entire enterprise hover the
spirit of historian herbert abdecker
the official united states communist
party theoretician
who engineered the work
and enlisted
the
cooperation of
a fellow black communist named john
henrik clark in putting the book
together
he'd done pioneering work on that turner
and american slave revolts in the 1930s
and 40s
a militant quotation from appthecker set
the tone of the book
his work had been groundbreaking and
useful at a time when negro history was
almost totally neglected
but it was badly skewed by communist
party dogma
his thesis that the institution of
slavery was threatened by constant
rebellion simply did not
and does not
hold up under scrutiny he underestimated
totally
slavery's
suffocating might
my own view shared by many students of
the history of slavery
was that the institution in the united
states was almost uniquely despotic
a closed system so powerful
and totalitarian
that organized insurrection was almost
entirely precluded
although of course rebelliousness
on an individual level
was always present
this overview
necessarily
dominated my version of matt turner
it was unfortunate that in the 10 black
writers respond so many recklessly
unprovable allegations were made
i'm afraid they were also written in
shabby and slipshod rhetoric
which left the impression upon many
people including
those sympathetic to the black cause
of a kind of intellectual squalor
for me the most frustrating aspect
of the 10 black writers respond and that
closes in on why we are here today
is that
it caused my work to be lodged in a kind
of black
index
expergatorius
from that point on
along with such overtly racist novels as
the klansmen and mandingo
less such a notion appear overstated i
would point out ample evidence
of not turner being not only unread by
blacks but in perpetual quarantine
this came from reports filtering back to
me from black studies programs in the
years up to the present
several times i learned the dismal news
that in specific courses
10 black writers respond would be
required reading
while the confessions of not turner was
not listed and in some cases either
actively
discouraged
or banned
i suppose i should have taken some
pride in having written a book
whose point of view
or insights
or even truths or whatever
caused such widespread fear
but this
nonetheless was censorship
and it marked the lowest ebb
in the history of the confessions of nat
turner
when the confessions of nat turner
appeared
in 1967 i was teaching
history at princeton university
and i prevailed upon
bill to come down and talk to my class
this must have been
fall of 1968 it was after the 10 black
writers respond book had come out the
confessions were in the midst of
controversy
and i thought it was a terrific thing
that my students were going to get a
chance to talk directly to the author
and engage in that conversation
um so bill came
and we uh appeared at my lecture fairly
large lecture i noticed that there were
a few more people than usual
there but that's not unusual since you
know strangers flock into my lecture
hall all the time
i introduced bill and as i finished
a group of black students got up from
the back and strode to the front pushed
me out of the way i heard i felt bill
uh kind of going tense
and he said well he uttered an expletive
and
they then gave a little harangue
about the confessions of nat turner the
gist of which was that it was racist
that any right-thinking person would get
up and stalk out of the lecture hall so
they led a walkout of the hall and all
the black students and a fair number of
white students left a fair number remain
and bill
in a testimony to his gumption
did talk and answer questions in that
lecture hall
that afternoon i i taught
a graduate seminar and bill went with me
to my graduate seminar which had a
couple of black students in it who were
in the morning class and who walked out
so we got to the seminar and there were
my two black graduate students and i
said i hope in a light tone hey you
walked out this morning what's up you
know what are you doing and they said
well um
we had to do that we had to show our
solidarity but we really liked the book
and we wanted to meet mr styron
so we had a a great session now what i
think
uh they did then we would nowadays call
uh an act of political correctness that
is they were they were showing
solidarity they were sort of obeying
the the lead of their political group
and i want to tell a little story about
myself
um
having to do with political correctness
because you may not know it but i am the
pope of political correctness
i was designated the pope for political
correctness by ralph reed of the
christian coalition christened i should
say rather than designated
when in this was the spring of 1993 when
i was leaving the university of
pennsylvania the presidency to go to
washington or at least i hope to leave
uh penn and be become the chairman of
the national endowment for the
humanities
but things had gotten a little rough and
as i walked down the hall to my
confirmation hearing glad that i had
gotten at least that far
ralph reed was holding a counter
press conference
i was headed toward my senate hearing he
was holding a press conference floyd
brown the author uh creator of the willy
horton advertisement in the 1968 uh
presidential campaign was uh there with
him
in that counter press conference so by
the time that i
got to my confirmation hearing
by then i had been mocked on national
radio by rush limbaugh denounced in
hundreds of newspapers in newsweek by
syndicated columnist george will
excoriated in the washington post by
charles krauthammer flayed alive for
television by pat buchanan on firing
line and otherwise held up for scorn and
derision
the wall street journal editorial page
the house organ of movement
conservatives had written seven count on
seven unflattering editorials about me
and the university of pennsylvania over
the span of a few weeks in april may and
june
while i stood blindfolded and lashed to
the stake
they were criticizing me john leo of the
u.s news and world report created a
sheldon award which he annually bestowed
still bestows it on the college
president who most closely approximates
my profile in cowardice
whoever formulated the precept that
there is no such thing as bad publicity
didn't have this in mind i feel sure
so as i walked down the corridor in the
senate office building toward my
appointment with the senate committee i
thought of the tony auth cartoon that
had appeared in the philadelphia
inquirer just two weeks before it showed
a pride of lions feasting on a carcass
labeled laniguiner
parachuting into the midst of that
feeding frenzy was a figure labeled
hackney he had a quizzical look on his
face as he gazed down at his carnivorous
landing zone and i knew exactly how he
felt
well um
how could a mild-mannered
unassuming ivy league president get into
such a mess
that's what the story is really about
that's what this little memoir is about
and i will not tell you the whole story
i will
give you a few uh
read a couple of passages in some
snippets of that story
the my i began to get in the mess
because of two disciplinary incidents on
the penn campus
that spring
now it's important for you to know that
the pen president then and still really
has nothing to do with the disciplinary
procedure no constitutional role in it
the first incident
became known as the infamous water
buffalo
occasion where a group of black sorority
women were celebrating their initiation
by singing singing very loudly uh in a
little patio beneath a high-rise
dormitory
making a good bit of noise but noise is
an ordinary thing on a college campus
nevertheless a large group of black stu
white students began leaning out of the
windows and shouting at them that became
a very angry exchange and a lot of
very strong racial slurs were used
including the unforgivable n-word
and a lot of curse words that we can't
have on c-span
and the and the women
understandably got mad they went to get
the campus police the police came back
all the white students
brave souls that they were melted away
except for one
young man who said yes he had
participated in it and he described that
what he had said was hey you water
buffalo if you want to have a party
there's a zoo over there as indeed there
is at penn there's a zoo about a
mile away
the black women file charges under a
very narrowly drawn racial harassment
policy that was in effect then at penn
i'll say more about that a little bit
later and that that disciplinary case
of the uh against that young man
brought by the black women never got to
a hearing on the campus through a whole
series of
faulty steps it just never got heard so
they were all up in the air the whole
spring
nothing in the papers about this until
the day before the end of classes a
large group of black students being very
angry at the student newspaper
stole the whole run 14 000 copies of the
daily pennsylvanian in a swooping
exercise
that did make the newspapers became a
very
hot item i think in part because i was
by then uh publicly known to be
the uh president's choice to be the
chairman of the national endowment for
the humanities lining guinea who then
taught at the university of pennsylvania
law school
had
just been
had her
nomination withdrawn by the president
and the same people who had accomplished
that
feat then turned their attention to me
and i think they saw their chance to
make me
a character in a story that they had
been telling
more important than that however i
believe that my tormentors recognized
quickly that the events at penn could be
shaped to fit the critique of the
university and of liberalism that
already existed in the public mind
having been developed by conservative
intellectuals over the previous
generation i was to be emblematic of the
cultural elite that was running the
country and was out of touch with the
people the elite that since 1960s had
been leading the nation away from
traditional values that made america
great that had sold out to left-wing
authoritarianism that unleashed on
college campuses the nkvd of political
correctness that was the sponsor of the
rise of minority groups to a privileged
status within society that was
anti-western in orientation that was
enthralled to statism that was
subversive of capitalism and that needed
to be crushed and replaced by the new
republicans
this of course was a role that i would
have declined had i been asked but i was
imprisoned in a story that someone else
was telling
that basically was my predicament and i
i
did want to go to washington
so i was working very hard
on that task
and um the wall street journal editorial
page was very working very hard in the
other direction
now
they certainly have a right to criticize
me but they they went beyond the bounds
and this is a bit of this is an exercise
in the politics of character defamation
uh before its campaign was over the wall
street journal editorial board had not
only colored the reports of the events
at penn in ways that were not flattering
to me they also published a number of
outright untruths that i had failed to
say that the theft of the newspapers was
wrong that i had defended the newspaper
thieves on the ground that they were
exercising their right to free speech
that i had punished a horton professor
for insulting black students in class
that i had proposed banning rotc from
the campus because of the anti-gay
policies of the military that i defended
political correctness on the grounds
that it promoted a free exchange of
ideas that i defended blasphemous
slogans written in chalk on locust walk
in support of a visit by the
controversial artist andres serrano that
i followed a double standard in
protecting controversial left-wing
speakers but not people on the right
all of those charges were demonstrably
false
nevertheless the wall street journal
editorial page really did set the tone
of the story they they created uh the
storyline if you will and it's
remarkable and this is one of the ways
in which uh intellectual
life gets distorted they they set uh a
land that other mainstream journalists
actually followed uh the story to them
was political correctness gone amok
once you decide that that's the story
and i am the
central character in that story then all
the facts fall into place whether
they're true or not and that sort of uh
was what i was going through i was
i was a story i was captured in their
story
and as long as the story was in the
mass media i had no chance to reply
there was no way that i could catch up
with the with the story at all
though when it got to washington things
are were a little different because the
senate is a face-to-face mechanism i
remember
going down to meet a tim worth who had
just left the united states senate
uh to get some advice i didn't know him
but
uh an appointment had been arranged by
some mutual friends and i went in to see
him and he said sit there and i'm going
to tell you all about the etiquette of
getting confirmed and what you have to
do and the mechanics and the etiquette
but there's one thing that i want to say
that is the most important thing that
i'm going to tell you and if you forget
everything else this you should remember
it is not about you
and i must have looked a little funny
and he said it's not about you now it
turns out that there are sort of three
senses in which
that's true first the people who are
after me were not really after me they
were after the president
secondly
he said
well
he said that there are
535 dramas going on in washington that
is one around each of the members of the
house and the senate he said you're not
the hero of any of those dramas so it's
those are not about you either
and most importantly
of course that whatever goes on in the
public realm can't touch the real inside
interior you the the person who has
integrity if you if you uh
remain true to who you are
things will work out well i i took that
to heart and i began calling on the
senators and i would uh soon found
myself trapped in a catch-22 i went to
call on nancy casabaum had a very nice
conversation on leaving i said can i
depend upon your support senator and she
said how can i give you my support when
the nomination isn't even before us
meaning that the papers had not come up
from the white house i was not actually
nominated they had only announced their
intent to nominate so i went to see
orrin hatch also had a very good
conversation and said gee senator can i
count on your support and he said how
can i give you my support how can i
commit to you when the white house
hasn't uh committed to your nomination
it's not up here so finally i got my
sherpa
my guide to all these things the white
house guy to admit that no the foot the
paperwork wasn't just lost in the
general counsel's office they wanted to
make sure that i could actually get
uh confirmed before they sent the papers
up so there was the catch-22 i couldn't
get senators to commit to me until i
could get the white house to send the
nomination up the white house wasn't
going to send the nomination up until i
got some republican senators to commit
to me
uh bad problem in the midst of this i
went to see i was told by harris wofford
that i should go see senator danforth
john danforth from missouri
who had been clarence thomas's champion
you may recall and who had sat
beside clarence thomas in that very
painful hearing and who felt bruised by
that so i went to see dan fourth and had
a wonderful conversation and at the end
of which he said that he could support
me in fact what he said was i have been
looking for an occasion to make a speech
about the confirmation process and the
lack of civility in it and how we're
chasing away good people and you are
going to be my occasion so i am your
republican vote
now of course you don't miss the irony
here is that
just because i got into trouble through
no fault on my own in my view
i also was going to get out of trouble
through no fault of my own because
danforth needed to make a speech and
that was the occasion
indeed i did make he did make that
speech and he wrote an op-ed piece in
the washington post uh i did get through
the the committee hearing unanimously
approved and finally through the
floor action of the senate and was
approved and uh and served four years
and had uh a very fulfilling time and a
very distinguished administration i want
to say too
thank you thank you
um on leaving
in 97 in the last round of
appropriations hearings
as i was going i was sitting there
giving out the
neh testimony and the members of those
committees house and senate republicans
and democrats said very kind things
about me my my resignation art was
already known said elaborately nice
things about me in the washington manor
and i was feeling really pretty good
about this and i was
sitting up tall in my chair
my pr guy who was sitting behind me so
he could keep me from saying anything
terribly stupid leaned over and
whispered in my ear if i had known it
was going to be this good i would have
had you resigned two years ago
so i was still feeling very good and uh
as these
hymns of praise were pouring down on me
and then i heard tim worth's voice in
the back of my head saying it's not
about you
thank you it's a very poignant and
powerful presentation
and now professor glenn lowry
well it's good to be here
um
let me start by saying that there is no
such thing as free speech
i'm just going to declare that there's
no such thing as free speech any of us
who writes or talks publicly about
something controversial
bears the cost of having others hear us
write or talk in that way
and draw whatever conclusions about us
they might be
inclined to do
um
so we will be bearing a social price now
of course
stalinist russia hitler's germany piles
of books burning in the square people
being put in the gulag these are serious
repressive acts
i'm not endorsing them but they're also
not a threat to us here in the united
states i want to argue that the more
practical threat is not the iron fist of
repression
it's the velvet glove of seduction
it's self-censorship it's the books that
are not written the arguments that are
not made the punch is pulled the
evidence not presented
the questions not asked
because we anticipate that they will
offend that we will how did bill clinton
put it uh not any longer be viable
within the system words to that effect
about one of his early life peccadillos
one wants to remain viable within the
system
one wants to be able to get that offer
at stanford
one wants to hear have the nomination go
through
and if one says or does or argues in
certain ways one one runs the risk that
that won't happen i mean here we sit
with a nation at war
and i think everyone recognizes that not
everything that might be said or written
about this situation is being said or is
being written
i think we know that there are arguments
that are arguable they may be right they
may be wrong but they're not being made
right tom daschle says
perhaps there was a foreign policy
screw-up that brought us to this
unfortunate pass that's
arguable maybe right
but he paid a price for saying it and i
haven't noticed a lot of other
democratic senators coming forth to say
the same thing or bill maher the
comedian says how can a man be a coward
who's willing to kill himself for his
cause
okay i don't know if that's right or
it's wrong believe me i'm not saying it
so you know don't get mad at me i'm
simply making you aware of the fact that
the person who said it paid a price for
having said so
so so i say that before i tell my horror
stories about my own particular travails
on the left and on the right because i
want to put on the table this fact it
seems to me very clear that we're
dealing here with something that is
really quite universal that doesn't know
any particular color this is not just
something that black people are doing to
protect themselves against you know
criticism or to keep their pride or
whatever sometimes that's happening but
it's not only that that's happening or
that uh christian fundamentalists are
doing so that their worldview won't be
offended by
public actions this is something it
seems to me
that is that is really quite widespread
um
race and intelligence
the bell curve
are blacks actually genetically inferior
to people of european ancestry in terms
of their average
intellectual capacities
as a question
presumably it can be posed in a
scientifically respectable way
one can investigate it one can write
about it
and yet the taking up of that question
and the writing about it
the trumpeting of the facts just in from
the lab our newest indications are that
well it does appear
that there may be some good evidence
that they're not quite up to it
um
that is not only a sort of disembodied
act of individual autonomy or discretion
in expression it's also a political act
it's an act that occurs within a context
are those books be burned no i would
never say so i would never say so those
books should be read
and they should be criticized
on the other hand
might a community of investigators even
the national science foundation
in electing among
all the questions that they might want
to fund to be asked
exercise i'm going to call it censorship
because that's what it is
by not providing money to fund this
question
and instead using scarce resources to
fund some other because their judgment
is
that the propriety of the asking
against the context
warrants that uh they they not so ask
yes they might do so and i might even be
prepared to defend their doing so would
i be engaging in the promotion of
censorship
perhaps but it seems to me that that
kind of judgment
is inescapable and that the grounds for
making it are different from the grounds
that we would go to to defend
the sort of theoretical right of free
speech that is to say they'd be much
more political they'd be much more
historically sensitive
another example
people complain some people some people
in print patrick buchanan i read
recently about jews jewish americans in
high places influencing american foreign
policy to the benefit of israel but to
the detriment of the american
interest
those arguments are made those are ugly
arguments it strikes me or at least they
can be the one that i saw patrick
buchanan write down made me squirm in my
chair
why was i squirming because what he said
was untrue probably although i'm not
exactly in a position to know in every
respect i was squirming because i was
keenly aware of his willful
crossing of a line his kind of willful
lack of deference his willingness to
open up a discourse that could easily
turn ugly it could easily get vicious he
ought to have been
more restrained i thought to myself as i
was reading him did that mean that i
wanted him not to write freely no
no i don't want to live in a world where
it would have been against the law
for him to write or where people would
have stormed the newspapers and smashed
the presses for that peace having run
that would be an awful world a
totalitarian world
but i wish that i lived in a world where
he
would have felt sufficient restraint
to not go that route or to put it in a
different way
or we talk about slavery about nat
turner
well what about historical research on
slavery
um or what about um
museum curatorship around the question
of slavery
what objects do we display and how do we
put them in context or
robert fogel and stanley ingerman to
historians economists
some years ago
wrote a series of books about
quantitative analysis of slavery and
they they came to conclusions like well
slavery was not as bad in every respect
as many people have said although they
didn't use those words
look at the diet of the typical slave in
the 1850s based on our data that person
was getting more calories per day than a
working class resident of uh birmingham
england
okay
slave labor in the factory they didn't
eat as well as slaves on the plantation
the historical argument goes because the
plantation owner had in his own interest
to ensure that his stock
were adequately nourished and the
factory owner had no such direct
connection to his workers well as a just
disembodied
objective examination of the evidence
that will might be true on the other
hand
we might all see
the problem
with
putting that kind of information forward
without the appropriate
qualification or context predication i
don't quite know how beautification i
don't quite know how to say it
um i'm not being exactly precise in
identifying the the limits because i
don't know exactly where there are all
i'm trying to accomplish now is to point
out that there are
limits that we all recognize them that a
decent respect for the opinion of our
fellows in society often leads us
to censor ourselves that that's probably
not a bad thing
at least not an unqualifiedly bad thing
but i don't want to leave it there
so that's the lay of the land that it
seems to me is the nature of the case
as i say and i don't want to tell horror
stories but i've experienced this on
left and right years ago i was known as
a black conservative because i was
published publicly criticizing
affirmative action policies or
suggesting that african americans needed
to pull our socks up get our
institutions in order keep our families
together things of this kind
against the backdrop of reagan era
policies and a lot of people
upset my views on certain matters
changed i find myself in the 1990s
writing a review criticizing a book by
two scholars as being
well not effectively argued in some
respects uh those scholars happen to be
conservatives the fact that i was
criticizing their book publicly led to
them reacting against me in a quite
strong way and some of their friends so
too so now i'm ostracized and i'm not
invited to the same dinner parties now i
have unpleasant encounters with people
well that's too bad it ought to have
happened grow up
true you could say that on the other
hand that's life
right
so
if i want to play that game
of public criticism on sensitive matters
maybe i'd better grow up and recognize
what comes with the territory that is to
say if you're going to be a firefighter
and being a writer on questions of race
in contemporary america is not unlike
fighting fires
then be ready for smoke inhalation you
just might get singed a little bit
it's tough out there right so it would
be too bad it seems to me if we didn't
also emphasize the need for courage
on behalf of writers the courage of our
convictions in the face of this
implacable inevitable universal effort
to try to censor and delimit what's said
it's out there and our um
discomfort may simply be part of the
price that we have to pay for the glory
that we get heaped upon us for having
been visionaries iconoclasts or all the
rest
thank you thank you man it's excellent
that's the best presentation i've heard
of of of an argument for limitations on
speech
how the rest of you feel about this
[Laughter]
very sound to me um
i would have
picked up on the uh
the need for courage but also the need
for for courtesy so
what what we the what we need is
the ability to talk to each other across
lands of disagreement
and
that ought not to be limited in any way
but if if we really want to benefit from
the clash of ideas in the exploration of
ideas then we do have to engage a bit
which means maybe holding back a little
bit in your delivery but also
if you're stung it also uh probably
requires you to
to forgive a little bit as well
bill
i have very little to add to that i
thought it was a very sound argument
um
civility
um
the
getting back to the nub of the
the issue with me which was the attack
on me
was the astounding absence of anything
remotely like civility
i mean there was uh
to um
to use
even in those
understandably
inflammatory times of the late 60s
when attacking someone
that you disagree with in this case
myself
to use a phrase in the attack such as
the one i quoted that i had a vile
racist imagination
it's pretty strong stuff
uh
you could
and and that set the tone of those ten
black writers
uh there were one or two that were
um that attempted uh
in their essays to
demonstrate a little courtesy but it was
basically
an extremely
uh
inflammatory
uh
scarless attack
and uh
and in in retrospect it initiates
of whatever little
credibility any of the essays had to
just to re-read those
read the these essays in in context and
to see the
astounding
and nastiness of tone
still it still
bothers me
that nastiness of tone has now become
the norm if you look at fox and cnn
that's the way the news is now being
engineered i must say i take a more
libertarian view of free speech
than you do glenn because i it seems to
me that there are restraints on speech
uh
one is legal strengths i mean slander or
defamation you know is grounds pursuit
and the other is the supreme court's
argument that um you know um
you cannot shout fire in a crowded room
that's a restraint on speech as well
but i do believe that the best answer to
bad speech is better speech and
if we begin to suppress what we consider
to be
hateful speech as long as that hateful
speech does not lead to violence i mean
that is that seems to be the border that
i would put on it uh
if we put a restraint on that then it
seems to me that anything can be
interpreted as hateful speech and we're
in we're in trouble yeah and i'm not
suggesting that we put any restraint on
anything i am complete agreement with
you about that
what i'm saying what i'm reporting say
it's not a normative argument i'm not
saying it ought to be this or that i'm
simply saying this is it
what i'm reporting is that speech about
things that people care deeply about
that sensitive that's controversial
that's powerful that could have
political consequence is going to meet
with reactions that are going to feel
repressive
that's that's my report i'm saying
that's a character of the world and then
i'm observing that it's not obvious that
one would have it otherwise that doesn't
say civility let me just second the
civility point i mean obviously that's
that's that's right
um
but it's it's not obvious that
we would want to live in a world in
which
people did not constrain themselves in
certain ways around things that they say
in deference to sensibility
and it seems like we're not going to be
able to get that constraint unless when
people
violate the norm again i want to use the
example of the war
i i think we ought to be able to say
whatever we want to say about the war
but i recognize
we can't say whatever we might want to
say about the war
at least i can't or it won't
aristophanes did
in the middle of the peloponnesian war
he was criticizing uh his own country
for the conduct of the war and if you
remember during the vietnamese war
um there was a lot of criticism of that
war both on stage and in literature what
have you and that was one of the
healthiest times in this country's
history
sure that's a good example manny bruce
is a very good example
any other points sure let me take up the
uh the delicate question of of hate
speech which you alluded to
delicately
um
the
you know this is comes out of my pen
experience in the water buffalo incident
penn had not a speech code as the
opponents always call it because a code
sort of implies an elaborate set of
rules that run for pages and pages penn
had a
a
single policy which said
in a face-to-face
conversation or encounter
you you may not use a racial slur
with the sole intent of insulting or
injuring
that would that was the policy now you
may that's hard to enforce one of the
lessons of of
the pen my pen experience with the water
buffalo is that you can't in that's not
enforceable basically and it's not a
good idea to have disciplinary rules
like that
especially having to do with speech
though
i also think that that on a college
campus this does not apply to the
world at large or to the
soapbox in the park or newspapers or
other means of exchange but on a college
campus
to think that the university has no
responsibility to try to create
an environment in which all of its
members can learn and can succeed
is not really thinking about the problem
very much which is to say
it's not enough just to say let the let
the kids have it out you know that
if the answer to
your
phraseology is the is the familiar one
uh the answer to bad speech is is more
is good speech well uh how would you
feel
if for instance a group of students
um burned across in front of the
afro-american studies program
uh well that that's that's clearly
intimidating it's also meant to insult
and if the university just says well uh
as long as they didn't violate the fire
ordinance it's okay you know
i i i
i think that's a short-sighted if if
someone is going around painting
swastikas on uh hillel
on the door
i i think that's more than
destroying property i think that is
creating an atmosphere in which which is
threatening and in which those students
who are targeted by that
cannot function very well so
disciplinary rules don't don't work i
will grant you that but the university
has some obligation to do something to
intervene to bring those students
together to talk about what their uh
what what has been happening and to try
to get them to understand uh how they
can communicate with each other in a
more civil way but but simply ignoring
it is not the answer
if there are no more points among
the panelists i thought we might be time
to open the floor to
those that are straining to have
something to say from the audience if
you wouldn't mind coming down to one of
these
microphones we'd love to hear what you
have to say
identify yourself and
direct your question to one of the
panelists please
my name is sandy seltzer and i want to
first thank the panel for their very
articulate presentation
um
my question is essentially based on what
all of you have said but
it was triggered by uh professor
hackney's
last statement
and i would like if you would
to all contemporize the issue of
the role of free speech especially on
the campus since three out of four of
you
are academicians by implication in a
sense so is uh mr styron
uh i would direct your attention to the
incident
at harvard university
i refer to the appearance of the uh
irish poet
tom paulin
and the incident at wellesley college
namely the appearance and the
controversy over the presentation
of
mr
baraka
alias leroy jones uh and what would be
your response uh to those presentations
of the role of the university uh
and uh
your statement uh professor brewstein
that free speech ends uh where the
threat of fire or as one supreme court
just as i recall once allegedly said
your free speech ends if you say i'm
going to punch you in the nose your free
speech ends where my nose begins did i
go to what
part of me
what was the end of your free speech
ends where my nose begins
yes
um good point
well my own position on the on the
invitation of poland and barack is that
they should not have been invited but
once they were invited they should have
been allowed to speak
um
and i should have been allowed uh to
protest their speech and to counter it
with my own remarks if i were there and
i think that's actually what what did
would have happened if uh poland had not
uh removed himself from the situation it
would have been an unpleasant situation
for him
but
so let me ask you both why are they not
to have been invited
well because i think uh the
pollen speech paul i don't know poland's
poetry but i know the poem that was uh
that was
under controversy and it is a
uh
it seems to me a deeply anti-semitic uh
and uh insulting poem
uh and uh barack is uh is even more
insulting uh baraka has not been clearly
in his right mind uh for the last 20
years as far as i can say um even though
he now is the poet laureate of newark
but um
new jersey how big important
but they should be allowed to speak of
course
another example at harvard was about 20
years ago
hey speaking as
glenn lowry
brought up the issue of the bell curve
there was a um
a cohort of
of one of the principals who was
espousing the bell curve named hernstein
richard richard hernstein
and he i remember
finding myself allied with this man
whose principles
are really totally against my own
because he had come to ha he he wasn't
at harvard but i believe he was invited
to speak
and
he was
literally booed off the stage this was
at harvard university because he
represented
this to to many people including myself
a rather poisonous ideology
and i remember
allying myself
with a friend of hernstein namely a
person ordinarily i would not be allied
with namely norman pedoritz
the editor of comment who was editor of
commentary then and i wrote norman who
was a friend of harrenstein
that i who had been through a similar
ordeal with matt turner
sent a my
bond of
of fellowship to to dr hernstein for his
ordeal
because i think it's an outrage when
people are
denied the ability to speak their mind
i think all of us
in this room all of us in this country
all of us on this panel
have been subjected to some kind of
abuse at one time in our lives as a
result of our
persons or our color of our skins or our
religions or our intellectual
persuasions or what have you
um
but i keep thinking of what nietzsche
said uh
he said once that life is hard to bear
but do not affect to be so sensitive
and by that he meant
harden your skins toughen your skins and
be ready to give back what you get
don't collapse before it and don't feel
you have to marshal your forces and
don't feel you have to start suppressing
speech
in order to defend yourself
do it on your own
and i think if we all got tougher
stronger we'll have more iron in our
blood i was less sensitive
less open to wounded sensibilities i
think we'd be a much stronger
and more powerful country
another question
question
sir
my name is richie tiemann a couple of
points professor lowry you resigned from
the american enterprise institute a few
years ago when in the wake of the denis
de souza book i take it and perhaps the
charles murray belker book has something
to do with it uh i i my understanding
was that you resigned just because you
didn't want to be around people who felt
this way how does that
square with your being a a professor a
man from academia who likes to engage
and argue and debate these issues of the
day it seems to me you would want to
stay there
and take these
two guys up and see if your ideas are
better than their ideas or was it some
other reason having to do with your
evolution into something more liberal
than where you were then and my final
point mr hackney
i i just in reading this entire affair
uh
your experiences at upenn
and comparing that with what people like
harvey silverglate has written in his
book which he didn't mention which is
perhaps the hardest shot against you as
opposed to people like ralph reed and
rush limbaugh
did you
have have you
had a a a all-encompassing theory of
free speech
uh which uh
i i i think uh in particular of your
remark in your defense of a student who
wrote in a newspaper in 81 i think it
was
lamenting that ronald reagan did not die
from the assassination attempt you
defended those words very strongly why
didn't you come out and defend eden
jakovic's words as strongly as you did
the previous student
you want to go first i'll go first
look i'm proud of having resigned from
the american enterprise institute i
don't make any apology about that and
there's no inconsistency between my
being a professor i you know i i wrote
a number of critical essays reviews and
whatnot in
relation to both books so i had plenty
of opportunity to engage people with
ideas it was charles murray who wouldn't
show up at academic forums to discuss
the merits of the argument in the bell
curve hernstein died before the book was
published
uh not i who was running and hiding from
an argument so
it doesn't it doesn't have anything to
do with whether or not i was willing to
engage people
um i resigned for a reason as relevant
to the subject of this uh panel
words don't just speak for themselves
they come embodied they come in context
all right in particular books from the
american enterprise institute are
different books and virtue of the fact
that the american institute enterprise
institute has on its board of academic
advisors
prominent african-american intellectuals
i was giving cover
and legitimacy in my person
to an enterprise the nature of which i
came
on my own intellectual merit to regard
as noxious
and so i wanted no longer to have my
person
associated with it that's why i chose to
step down but in so doing i didn't take
away anybody's right to speak i just
took away their right to speak in my
name
[Applause]
the other question it gets us into uh
minutia about the
disciplinary procedures at penn but
i did
defend the young man the student
columnist in 19 whenever it was 81 or 82
who uh
said indiscreet things about ronald
reagan the chickens are coming home to
roost
he was fired by
the
board basically the student newspaper
board which is a separate corporation
and i said that he had a right to say
what he wanted to say
as does everyone i defended the right of
the of the uh penn professor who burned
the flag in a communications course i've
defended the rights of 10 faculty and
students to speak on the campus
left right and in the middle
the problem with the eden jacobits is
that it was a disciplinary case and i
was not part of that disciplinary
procedure and to have intervened would
have been to
create many more problems than
it solved because
it would have been an unconstitutional
act so i did not
intervene
are there any other questions from the
floor yes sir
this question is is primarily for
professor lowry
if i follow you right and i want to get
this right you can correct me if i'm
wrong your argument was basically that
um
when speaking and when presenting a
viewpoint one should be aware of the
context
uh in which the point is made and censor
oneself accordingly but at the same time
one should speak despite the possibility
or despite the uh well despite the the
popularity of your position so for
example tom dashiell who right who says
something that's very unpopular now and
he gets excoriated um and if i follow
you right your the basic criterion for
self-censorship would then be
reasonableness that is
can my argument is my argument
reasonably made that is um is the bell
curve a reasonably uh documented
scientific work uh is the the theory of
the the jewish conspiracy the
pro-zionist jewish conspiracy set out by
who was it buchanan buchanan is that is
that a is that reasonably stated um
and mike this is sort of a statement
like in i guess in the great tradition
of academic discourse this is sounds
like a statement but it's secretly a
question
[Laughter]
what i want to know is um
i guess in an age where
there seems to be a greater recognition
of the power of of rhetoric
um
the for example i mean i'll give away my
i'll show my feathers here but the the
bush administration has done an
excellent job on i'm not criticizing
them actually i'm saying this is an
amazing job of
bringing us to war based on
not exactly a series of evidential
findings but a series of rhetorical
moves
in an age where rhetoric is so very
important in an age of rhetoric is so
very powerful it doesn't seem sort of
like the criterion of reasonableness
doesn't that seem like a nice dream
i'm not sure i understand meaning we
where it's hopeless people are not going
to be
that is in public discourse sort of the
criterion of reasonableness i i agree
would be
perfect would be great but
it doesn't seem to be the case and it
doesn't seem to
work we don't seem to be moving in a
direction where reasonable is really i
mean when you're in a sort of let's say
sound bite culture to say to say it like
that
is it possible to have a reasonable
discussion or
is it all rhetoric at this point and
then how do you
how do you move things toward a
reasonable i'll turn it into a question
how do you move things toward a
reasonable discourse
when you have
two seconds of news or the crawl and
beneath the
commentators on the news
i'm not quite sure what to say in
response
i want to say though that my position is
not
that one should
censor oneself based on the anticipation
that what one says might be regarded as
unreasonable by somebody who hears it if
i if i understood you i'm not saying
that
i'm saying
people who hear what you say and who
have powerful feelings about it will
sometimes react to you negatively that's
part of the environment in which we're
all functioning it's probably it's
natural it's probably not all bad
uh sometimes we'll find ourselves
pulling our punches in anticipation of
that and that's just the way things are
that's so so that's what i'm saying then
i'm saying have a thick skin
if you want to play in this game and you
got something to say be prepared to know
that when you say it there may be
consequences but that comes with the
territory stop whining and complaining
about the fact that people are attacking
you for what you've said you can
anticipate that they're going to do so
yes they should be civil
um and
i want to say one other thing
just to um amplify um my earlier remark
i think here in the united states when
we're talking about domestic issues and
they bear on race
the person
of the individual who's engaging in a
discussion matters mr styren pointed out
that some of the animus that was
directed against him was the fact that a
white man had deign to
dot
that's terrible
okay he ought to be able to
dot dot dot
on the other hand let's not be naive our
persons do matter
and sometimes we strategically display
our persons or
our persona is strategically displayed
by others in order to generate a certain
effect okay two-wit
clarence thomas nomination hearings i
was appalled at what happened
to clarence thomas in the nomination
hearings and the whole kind of firestorm
around him because of his politics not
being able to go to the court
on the other hand i saw
some of what the other side
the anti-thomas side was saying in this
respect
thurgood marshall an african-american he
serves on the court he steps down
president george bush the first
is going to appoint a successor he
appoints an african-american but someone
who stands against everything that
defined thurgood marshall's career and
everything that embodied the hopes and
aspirations of the african-american
people or that's a slight exaggeration
but only a slight exaggeration now that
was a cynical move some said
because it plays on the persona aspect
namely he's an african-american you see
the legitimacy of the court as a
representative institution is maintained
we appoint an african-american and yet
ideologically he stands against
everything that the man's career and
that african-american struggle had
seemed to represent so
we in effect honor the need to have
representation while undermining the
representation so when people reacted
against that in an ad hominem fashion
while they ought not to have done so
and while the ad hominem attacks violate
some decorum about how we ought to have
discourse with ourselves there was ad
hominem
nests built into the very situation from
the start
[Applause]
are there any more questions on the
floor yes sir
my name is dick leonard by the way from
quincy mess
and i speak as one who's had his speech
suppressed
at one time i was an advocate for the
utilities and nuclear power and high
voltage transmission lines were not well
received by many audiences
specifically in schools when principles
barred me from speaking to classes about
energy and energy conservation
but i speak today as
a member of an audience and i think it's
important to recognize that as authors
and artists you have something to say
and there's an audience that will
receive that positively or negatively
and i think it's important for us to
realize
that when a swastika is put on a door
or a um
a politician
makes a claim in poughkeepsie new york
about uh the abuse of a black woman a
black girl
and
to a great extent
these
statements
are to me
important
because they tell me
where the sharp points of our society
are
i'm i'm more worried about blandness in
our communication i'm more worried about
reasonableness as being the problem
we need
the sharpness
because that
if you will that girds our loins again
and each time we need our
loins girded if i can continue with that
analogy
and
so it's important that we listen
as an audience to
what's said and it's important
that what is said
must be heard
hopefully much of it is ignored by the
audience but it needs to be heard and
discussed
and just on a lighter side i see
i guess it's a metaphor of what we're
talking about happening in this very
community
in terms of banning smoking
in restaurants
where people voluntarily go but are
going to be polluted by
one person's emission
and they are going to be polluted based
upon how closely they sit to that person
and i find
the
that that needs to be discussed more and
more
as a physical expression of what we're
talking about here which is the
intellectual expression of things maybe
we don't want to hear
things that may smell bad but we still
need to receive it process it
analyze it and make judgments about it
so i think it's important that we have
that
offensiveness
and we don't avoid that offensiveness
and i appreciate the pointed arguments
that i've heard from you gentlemen today
thank you
thank you
we have time for just one more question
before we conclude who would like yes
my name is marty goldman
and my first book
as you can see
was not turner written 10 years ago
i think mr stein knows the book
in the late 1960s i taught
african-american history it was called
the negro in american history at clark
university i introduced the course i
introduced it at holy cross i taught at
rutgers
and i taught for about five years at
boston university
i can tell you i sold a lot of mr
styron's books
over those years
there's a defense of mr styron in this
book
if i may i would like to just read it
ironically however
it wasn't a historian who played the
major role in the resurrection of nat
turner in the 1960s
it was one of the great american writers
of the post-world war ii generation
william styron
styron is a white southerner who had
grown up in the tidewater area of
virginia
not far from southampton county where
the net turner rebellion took place
styron's 1967 novel the confessions of
nat turner set off an angry debate
his critics often black argued that
styron offered
readers a negative picture of a man they
considered a universally admired
african-american hero
much of this criticism against styron
was harsh and often unfair
he was called a racist
because he was a southern white man who
dared to write about a black hero
but styron's novel was a work of fiction
as a novelist he was free
he was free to do whatever he wanted
with his characters and to inject his
own imagination into his work
and here's the most important line i
think
moreover william styron's portrayal of
everyday slave life in the old south
is one of the most remarkable
achievements in either history or
literature
few writers or scholars have given us a
snapshot in time of southern slavery
that compares to the brilliant work of
william stein thank you very much
aren't you glad you came
i now want to say something about this
book was written 10 years ago
it was named one of the 10 best books by
the national council of social studies
and the publisher came back to me a year
later and said we want you to sign a
contract to do a book on the slave trade
sure i said
i signed the contract i began the book
and about six months into the work the
editor called me sheepishly
this is in the mid-90s now and said
marty
i don't know how to tell you this but
they want to pull the contract
i said why
i'm well into the book i'm well into the
research
they want a black writer
they don't want a white writer i said
after not turner
they didn't give a damn
but
the editor said sheepishly you can write
anything you want besides black
[Laughter]
read my book on crazy thank you
[Laughter]
i want to thank liam styron i want to
thank sheldon hackley and glenn lowry
and all of you for a very
responsive
the confessions of nat turner was
originally published in 1967
it was reissued by random house in 2002
with the original cover
visit randomhouse.com for more
information
non-fiction books and the publishing
industry saturday morning at eight
through monday morning at eight eastern
48 hours of non-fiction books all
weekend every weekend on book tv
this year random house marks its 75th
anniversary recently book tv interviewed
random house author william styron and
editor robert loomis who shared memories
about their careers with the publisher
this interview in mr loomis's office in
new york city is 50 minutes
bob loomis and bill styron do you
remember when you first met
i don't remember the exact instant but i
remember the
the time frame
i remember it being uh
in the late
or mid 40s
in uh at duke university
where i was a class ahead of bob
but i don't recall the exact instant of
our
communion our first connection what do
you remember we had some stories in the
archive which was the
literary magazine and they were so
superior to anything any college kid
ever wrote they just pulled me over but
i didn't know who he was but i remember
going into student union and i would
pretend somebody was styron
and they would change in my
mind into something amazing you know and
then one night we met at the title house
outside
the campus which was a hamburger joint
and bill took me over to a house of the
man who ran duke university present and
we sort of then became
a lot closer and we met there quite
often as a matter of fact yeah that
it evolved into a kind of a
a little club a tiny little club about
three or four
students
bob myself one or two others and this
central figure his name was asheville
bryce who was a
a kind of uh
oratund south carolinian who uh
who was as bob said head of the duke
press
and uh we that's where i had my first
dry martini we eat martinis and
spaghetti
and we got pretty um
carried away yeah
you came from virginia and you came from
ohio yeah
did you do you remember what you wanted
to do in your life at that point
i wanted to be a writer
there was
no other alternative
for me
why well
i'd been through the war i've been
through i've been in the marine corps
and uh
i had come back
from the marines
feeling that i had to
express myself about this
shattering experience not that i had any
truly shattering experience i was not in
combat but i
i did have i was drenched in the in the
marine corps
spirit
and i also just wanted to write because
it was to me
a need i'd read a lot of books
by this time not nearly as many as i
later did of course
but
the idea of
being a writer
of being able to write with the ferocity
let's say of
of in this case thomas wolfe
who at that time was the kind of hero of
mine the idea of being able to emulate
this talent was to me the cena
there's nothing like it
mr lomas how about you at that age well
i want to be a writer too
but i wasn't good enough i knew that in
fact i went to do
probably going to engineering school
because i had to make a living but about
halfway through
i switched to english and
and people like bill were very
influential to me about that i think you
were writing some of lie down in
darkness at duke at that point
i may have i remember i had
graduated in 1946 from duke
came north
to become a writer and to
by the way to become an editor at mcgraw
hill from which i was fired
for um
this behavior
of one sort or another
and was
put on my own devices so to speak
and was trying to write
i rented a apartment on upper lexington
avenue
and also enrolled in a class in the new
school at the new school in writing
and uh i was given a
100 option on a novel by the then
teacher his name was hiram hayden
who was also a publisher he he was
published at crown publishers
and um
so with this 100
option
uh i headed back south to durham
to
to attempt to deal with this first novel
which i was yeah and that and that is
indeed i believe
when i when i got
together with bob
who else was that duke with you all
there are other big names
mack hyman was there the no time for
sergeants
person
bill canine and clay felker clay felker
was one of my roommates yeah
and when did you begin to have a
professional relationship not until i
came to new york
we crossed again because once we got up
here hiram hayden who had signed bill up
taught at the new school one night a
week he lived in westchester
and he stayed in my apartment
he slept that one night
every week
and
he then had gone to random house and he
hired me a random house where bill was
already and when hiram left
bill didn't
yeah my first
novel lie down in darkness was published
in 1951 by hiram who who had then moved
from crown
to bob's merrill
and it was
for me a very very exciting thing to
have that happen
uh to be
not only a first novelist of
considerable success because the reviews
in general were quite good but to also
find myself on the bestseller list
along with the
two other
i would
hazard premiere first novels of that
period namely the catcher in the rye and
from here to eternity i wasn't as high
on the list but i was i made six or
seven and that was a big thrill and how
old were you i was 26
and that first novel was about
that first novel was about a doomed
southern
tidewater virginia family
centrally the
central figure being a
a
highly
disturbed
young woman named peyton loftus who
killed herself
that was the basic story
mr lewis do you remember the first book
you edited at all period at random house
i don't
you do not i don't do you remember the
first book you edited of mr styrus yes
what was that it was set this house on
fire
that's the book he did after uh lie down
in darkness and when he stayed around
the mouth and i was here that's
what we got together and you've been
together from from then on from that day
forward are you personal friends yes oh
yeah we're very close friends and have
been
an
uninterrupted uh
friendship i might add with very little
uh flaws or dips
bill was my best man twice
twice right
and in the history
to people who have never thought about
random house they've just read books
what's so special about this place
75 years later bennett and donald
bennett and donald clawford the founders
made a very
great place out of this company it was a
family
and people who worked here
uh liked it a lot and they never left
hiram was the only one that ever left as
far as i know
and bennett couldn't understand why that
surf he just couldn't get over it why
would he do that
and and
many writers bill
in my estimation the best but then i
mean we had o'hara and robert penn
warren
and
michener and
any number of people like that who
stayed all their careers with a random
house
that's that's fairly unusual why why'd
you stay all these years uh i stayed
because well to begin with uh
bob touched on on donald and bennett
donald cloth and bennett surf bennett
was a
profoundly uh nurturing
uh
publisher
he made you feel at home i mean it was
this was when random house was on
madison avenue in the
present uh helmsley hotel
it was par then part of the
i believe the archdiocese of new york it
had had sold
part of this building to prevent a
beautiful old
uh
uh elegant house
and uh one just simply felt very much at
home of this place
i'd walk up the marvel staircases very
very sumptuous sort of place and there
at the top of the stairs and understand
this is old-fashioned publishing this
would have been back in the 60s
there would be bennett with his pipe
and i would hear this voice saying bill
steyron the boy author
come in and so
i would walk in and he'd set me down in
his office
give me a drink
and just ask me how things were going
this is publishing of the old-fashioned
sort it was quite wonderful
do you miss those uh those years and
more special for you then yeah they were
great and donald the partner was sort of
the rock they were completely different
personalities but they actually they
loved one another they were so close in
this book we're going to publish their
letters during the war you'll see
a genuine affection in these men that's
very rare and it never never stopped and
they got along just
great they they complimented each other
and made a place that was uh
i i remember once bennett came in and
the receptionist
was crying and she had received a letter
from rca that she was being retired
because we that company owned us
bennett said you sit there i'll pay your
salary every month from now on for as
long as you want
that's unusual
they gave me money for an apartment i
didn't even ask for it i didn't even
know about a check i never signed a
thing there was no interest no nothing
i'd only been there six months
you have to you have to think people
like that yeah i think that was another
just the pure crass
uh money aspect was never a problem
uh i remember once having a minor
emergency
financially
and uh it didn't pan out that i had to
to uh
get the money from bennett but i
mentioned it to him and he said oh
just whatever it was five thousand ten
thousand sure don't worry about it it
was it wasn't even contractual it was
just natural it was quite a wonderful
thing let me ask you about numbers how
many books have you written in your life
seven or eight
but you've written a lot of other things
i mean yes i've written a great deal of
essays
short stories yes yeah
of all that
you remember all these years what was
the most personally satisfied
well it might
sound odd but i wrote a
when i was in paris in 1952
i wrote a short novel called the long
march which
i poured my soul into it was about the
marines
about a brutal march in
in the
north carolina camp lejeune one that i
participated in
um and uh
i wrote it at white heat
and i remember uh reading it aloud to an
audience uh that included peter mathis
and my friends peter madison and george
plimpton
um at
matheson's apartment i read it all
afternoon it was quite a long long
novella
and there's something about everything
coming together there
that made me feel that uh to be a writer
was just the best thing on earth i just
felt satisfaction in every respect
i was counting a list of what you edited
over the years and i know the list is
not complete because shelby foot's not
on it but i counted
150 books how many books have you ever
totaled up the number of books no
is there any way for you to gauge when
you've really
been satisfied with a project
uh sure it's it's quite obvious i mean
it's first what it is
and that it and that you're excited to
be able to
shepherd a book like whatever it is
through
and if it's and if the editing goes well
and you think you've helped
and then if it really sells it people
buy it and the reviews are good well
that's really what it's all about it
doesn't all those things don't always
happen together but when they do
well
that's a great great satisfaction i've
always had it with bill
i mean everything he did
always i mean he doesn't take much
editing i mean he knows what he's doing
but you two have a routine though when
you're when you're doing a book how do
you do it well it's varied slightly over
the years but uh
it includes my having read aloud
a lot of
of what i've written to bob
that is great gobs of text
usually at my house
whether it's on martha's vineyard or
connecticut but somewhere
and that has been an interesting
uh
phenomenon to be able to
read aloud
and to get a response
uh immediate response from someone who's
so acute in terms of critical
acumen
how do you respond i like it
do you ever not like it no
not really it's not that and you're
reading only parts of things you can't
put it together
but we'll talk about things but it's a
great privilege to have that happen it's
actually i think writers
if bill went out desert island would he
write a book knowing nobody would ever
read it
he might but the fact is that having
somebody read it is
is is is partly what it's all about so
if you can be in on that at the
beginning it's certainly great for me
but he also has a forum
just like just as he said when he read
the long march to that small group in
paris
he
says now he got more
satisfaction out of that than almost
anything
that he ever did
and that's because he shared it and they
loved it
so that's part of it
what's your guess
about
authors
how many of them
want to influence the world by what they
write versus those that just like to
write
and can you tell when you work with
yes but mostly it's it's not it might be
a non-fiction book
um if posner's writing about the kennedy
assassination i think he wanted to
influence how people felt about it
and he did and he did he stopped almost
the whole conspiracy thing
but other people don't really feel that
way they want
to
tell the world
bill i i think i think with sophie and
nat he certainly wanted to tell us about
two kinds of slavery
and the subjugation of people and he
wanted us to understand as we never had
before
that's changing the world a bit but i
don't think that was his motive
because he's more interested in
character i think i think it's
it was said by
i'm not really sure but let's say it was
i think it was d.h lawrence
he said that
a book
is very unlikely to change
humanity in any particular way
i think he might be specifically have
been talking about novels i'm not really
sure because certainly there are
majestic works of
philosophy that have changed the world
but let us say it was a novel but he
said that
a novel cannot change
humanity but it can change the
consciousness
of single individuals
and i think that that is
definitely true
i have evidence to that effect
just in response to my work
and that that's very satisfying can you
give us some examples of the evidence
yes
the book i wrote about depression
darkness visible
i get letters virtually every day
telling me that
that has changed
people's perception about this illness
that was
non-fiction about yourself yes in this
case yes but
i guess what i'm saying is endorsing
lawrence's view that it extends to
non-fiction in this case
all of these individuals have indeed
been i have not changed
anything about the treatment of
depression
professionally
but i've i've altered many i think many
people's awareness of what the illness
is what years were you
the most depressed
um
well the the
the event of depression which
i wrote about in darkness visible
took place
between the
spring of 1985 and the spring of 1986
and included
a
serious hospitalization for seven weeks
it was
embraced there roughly a year
um
and it was that experience which gave
rise to the book and i remember
vividly
how bob figured in this
issue
i remember
when i was
getting a bit better at the hospital
bob came to to visit me and i was
allowed to pass to go to the cafeteria
i remember sitting there um
with bob one night
saying uh
and this was several years before the
book appeared of course but i said
if there's one book that i will
definitely write
if i write no other book it will be a
book about this
incredible
voyage of
horror and
and uh discovery that i
went through in in suffering this
illness
and bob
of course later on encouraged me to do
it again
so
um his input into the
issue was very important
do you remember when did you sense that
he had was getting depressed
did you ever talk about it before that
this was new to all of us and it came on
i believe somewhat gradually
we had a 60th birthday
for bill up in the country
vineyard and we a lot of us flew up
there now bill was starting to be in the
throes of this
then
but you watch him in the photographs and
he was holding my little baby and so
forth but he was getting bad but it
didn't
we didn't know that's what it was i i
don't think maybe you did but i i didn't
know i knew something was happening that
was pretty you know that maybe you'd get
out of it but there was something going
on i thought it was
the fact that i'd stopped drinking
i didn't sort of enforce myself to stop
drinking because i found it was making
me ill
and i had a queasy feeling when i drank
and that this was a form of withdrawal
from alcohol which in to some extent it
was
but in really what it was under
underlying all of this
was the beginning incipient beginning
beginning of a severe i mean
catastrophic depression
what year were you completely
healed from all that well i think as i
said it lasted from
spring of 85 to spring of 86 by the time
spring arrived in 86 i was virtually
free of the illness did you know it was
over
sure
and when did you say this i didn't say i
mean this was beyond my saying but you
can tell when someone no no and ask when
did you say or what did you think to
yourself there's a book here oh well he
he it was his idea i i simply thought it
was a marvelous idea and i knew that no
one
had been able to tell others what it
felt like because they weren't writers
they had clinical
things they had people being interviewed
and in fact as i remember you wrote this
for johns hopkins
i wrote it really
uh it was an interesting i i did indeed
i i
um
i got so infuriated at something i'd
read in the new york times about
um
the way people had regarded the suicide
of primo levy
uh as if
according to this article primo levy
suicide at the age of 67 was some sort
of moral lapse
these were scholars at the nyu
discussing this man
and i was enraged by this and i wrote an
op-ed piece
in the new york times which was entitled
something like why primo levy
need not have died
and i said that these people who were
condemning
levy really had no understanding of the
real reason he did what he did was
because he was profoundly clinically
depressed
uh and and that that's what happens when
you're depressed and i tried to intimate
that there was a great deal of pain
involved and this had to be understood
at any rate
that provoked a huge amount of response
a male
and it included an invitation as you
just implied from johns hopkins the
department of psychiatry
for me to come down there and give a
lecture on the on the illness
and
fascinatingly enough on the way down
to baltimore
i stopped in new york
and gave part of this address
at a
meeting
of a newly formed
society to prevent suicide american
suicide foundation
and
this was a rather fragmentary
sort of version of the lecture
but in the audience was
none other than tina brown who was then
editor of vanity fair and she came to me
and said
afterwards at my table and said would
you consider writing this as a longer
piece
and that's of course what happened i
she gave me an enormous amount of
space i think 13 or 14 000 words and it
was in vanity fair and that was the the
central part of the book now back to the
editing part of this situation when do
you
when you
edit
fiction versus non-fiction any different
no
no does the reader expect anything
different from your experience
well yes
yes but the same dynamic
works its structure and character and
being clear as a matter of fact i was
just thinking i forgot about this one of
the things i knew was something was
happening to bill he'd given me
something to read it was something he
had tried to start several times
i don't know what i said or wrote back
it surely wasn't very
really critical
but he blasted me like he never blasted
me before i kept the letters two-page
diatribe it was i don't remember that of
course not but you you you see you once
told me that part of depression what it
did it completely ruins your self-esteem
you have none you have no defense about
anything
uh about yourself
and i think somehow whatever i had said
had aggravated that
and that was out from that because it
was completely unlike him but i was
devastated by it yeah that's something
i've completely forgotten maybe that was
part of the illness
of the residual part of it and what
point did he write this to you
well it was incipient it was coming on i
think
i'm not sure
maybe it was after maybe it was before
but i think he still was
shaken
by what had happened or what was going
on how did you deal with him then i just
ignored it you ignored it completely
yeah that's funny i don't recall that
but i'm sure it's obviously oh there's
no it wasn't an answer no that was the
thing i just said okay and
you see he's forgotten that's what i
hoped
would happen well i had for a long time
after i recovered
from the illness
attempted to write this as fiction
and i remember sitting down
writing thousands of words i must have
written
20 30 000 words of
ultimately aborted
version of what i finally wrote as
nonfiction where i had characters
doctors
patients and all that and simply i
realized as i was writing
that it was not coming alive that it was
there was something
false about it it just didn't have the
authenticity i
really needed
and so
the events i just described were the way
that i finally
uh got it down as a book do you still
write longhand yes always always yeah
well i have a very childish scroll
i don't think so it's quite beautiful
well thank you very much
and pencil and yellow yeah it's it's
number two i'm trying to say that it's
very legible the number two pencils
number two venus velvet pencils if they
still sell venus velvet
um and uh i try to write very very
carefully because i i know that someone
will have to transcribe this
into type or on a word process when you
read him do you read
no this copy he waits until he if he
reads it out loud but if he he types it
incidentally that that vanity fair thing
was really unusual because you have to
go back and remember what vanity fair
was like this was the most unlikely
piece to run in vanity fair one could
imagine
but it was so powerful and it's so
effective that
i remember edwin morris called me he had
read it in vanity fair he was in
washington sat down on a park bench and
he just sat there for hours
he was so uh
taken by it
so it from that this grew and it was an
incredibly effective piece and nobody
else had done it
have
have you all done everything you wanted
to do have you said everything you want
to say no no no
no i i've said a great deal of what i
want to say but
the last word is always there waiting to
be said what's missing
well
there are always things that make you
cranky and upset and
make you feel that you should write it
down as a polemic or something like that
so those such things are in the works
for me
but i i would
i don't think one is ever
totally satisfied with what one has done
you say you don't think of what you've
done you think of what you haven't done
that's probably a
not a very
sensible way to look at your work
there's always the potential you say for
having done more
um
but i think uh i'm certainly happy with
what what i have done well i mean go
back you know where you two guys were
together in 1947
yeah 47 your duke university and you
both want to do
what you do yeah except you were going
to be a writer
well you didn't know that
um how about you
what have you have you
have you gotten out of this life what
you wanted so far
yes very much i feel very lucky you know
i don't think most people find out what
they really should do
they get a job
arbitrarily or by accident somewhere and
they get into it they get interested in
it
but it's not really what they're
interested in maybe a lot of people
don't have a real interest but i luckily
fell into this
i i can do it pretty well
and i meet these people
i mean you're meeting the best minds
of our time and and it's ongoing
and uh i don't there's nothing better
than that and it's constantly look it's
routine you do the same thing over and
over again every year but right around
the corner there's always something new
and you know it's there
and it happens so i mean i've been here
a long time but i just never want to
stop
now
if we were sitting around with a bunch
of
random house veterans in this room some
that have maybe departed
and you said let's all start telling
stories of the old days
it would take a long time what would you
give but give us a couple of stories
from the old days where people don't see
anymore they don't hear about this stuff
um tell them about lolita oh yeah that's
uh
the
i wrote a brief piece in the new yorker
about this but it's worth recounting
um
when hiram had hiram hayden who as i say
was my
mentor
originally who urged me to write and was
and and got me to write lie down in
darkness a man of great perception
in many ways
who came to random house
with autonomy it was the first time a a
an editor had come
this was in the late 50s to random house
given by bennett's surf total autonomy
to do what he wanted
and um which was very very surprising
but
hiram had these limitations
uh in the meantime i
had become infatuated by
lolita which i had read in the
uh olympia press version
the the dark deep
allegedly pornographic version which of
course is
balderdash because there was no
pornography in the book at all it was a
heavenly book i thought
uh wonderfully
just everything it was it was
filled with laughter and
and everything else and i just loved it
as did a lot of people who had read it
in this olympia press version
so i
i went to hiram
his office at random house at the old
the old madison avenue random house
and said hiram you must read this
uh it's this is a wonderful book
he said i'll do it he he and i were had
a very good relationship
and two days later i think i came back
to the random house i said hire him
what do you think he said i will publish
that over my dead body
he said that is the most
uh devastatingly
uh
harmful book i think i've ever i have a
young daughter of 13
and
i will not publish this as i say over my
dead body i couldn't believe it this
because plainly he had palpably in his
hand a masterpiece he shoved it back in
my hand
and
i remember
going right next door
to bennett's to bennett's surf's office
and bennett had in the meantime read the
book too
and i said
bennett what's going on here
and bennett said i know he was in tears
virtually in tears he says
it's a masterpiece but i can't do
anything about this hiram hayden hates
it what's wrong with that man and so as
a matter of fact what happened was that
it was published very soon after that by
putnam
who made a absolute fortune on the book
besides
giving the world a masterpiece
that was an indication of the some of
the complexities of publishing at that
time
do you remember the time when you had
the most names around in and out of the
old headquarters over on madison avenue
and personnel first person
you know uh celebrity type names the big
the big names like mr stop sure when was
that what was the period when you had
the most i remember mostly with bennett
because those people came in and it was
convivial you saw everybody
even we even saw miss america when she
came by which she would do
because bennett was
uh uh
would you know he just invited all these
point people and so all the authors that
came in we kind of all met
but it was natural it just seemed like
that's what it should be we had to we
had the best list of american writers
in the world
we didn't go by we didn't go to england
to buy anything i mean everybody came to
us
and nobody everybody else had one or two
but we had a lot of them
and uh and it was all because of bennett
and donald pretty much
well maybe you can tell me a story when
i was a kid in college
i worked as a rehearsal assistant for a
guy named william saroyan oh boy oh yeah
and
he for about six months he came to
purdue university and i was there and i
just i carried his bag around
i didn't even know who he was
and of course i know now but uh what
about him he's a talented guy but he was
a horror a horror yeah he was delightful
oh sure but he just drove everybody
crazy why because he was such an
egomaniac prima donna yeah just awful
he he uh there was a biography went
around nobody published it but it's
unbelievable what he did to bobby's he
went to double day once signed a
contract for three books
and delivered all of them the next day
and walked away what did he he didn't
write that much for random house so what
was it for no we did stories the daring
young man in the flying trapeze we did
and i remember in the earlier letters
bennett uh writing to somebody saying
gosh we've printed like 2 300 copies and
it's in the new york times bestseller
list
that's what it was like back then they
were really happy about him
uh but he was young then i mean saroyan
but as he got older he became almost
impossible to deal with it was very
cranky i met him several times very
straight do a rather cumulative
fellow
in his later years you know bennett also
had i think the best sense of humor and
about himself
he laughed at himself
he he wanted to do a lifetime library of
a great great greek drama
all these were his ideas modern library
everything
he didn't know anything about it so
he read up about it in the encyclopedia
britannica and he called moses hottest
from colombia who was the professor
got him in told him what he wanted to do
and how to said he would do it ben in
the meantime spouting off about greek
drama from the encyclopedia
then it took him out to the hall it was
a one-man elevator hottest was about
this high
the two doors porthole hottest went up
on his toes and he said i'm glad you
liked my article on the encyclopedia
britannica and his face disappeared and
then bennett would laugh so hard he
would fall almost fall on the floor
you also have to remember that bennett
he was a lot of people disliked bennett
because they thought he was a kind of a
celebrity monger which in many ways he
was
uh who loved uh publicity and being on
television shows like what what's my
line where he was a superstar i mean he
was as
visible as
mariah carey or someone like that in
those days
and um
but you know he one of his
accomplishments just one of his many
truly literary accomplishments he almost
single-handedly
uh was responsible for getting
joyce's ulysses published in the united
states
he
stage managed that whole thing
was made made sure that it would be
smuggled in and then uh slapped with a
subpoena and that sort of thing what was
wrong with it why couldn't he publish it
it was considered obscene it was
considered obscene because of its
language of course the famous judge
woolsey in i think 1933 or two
pronounced it a fine book and and that
is largely what he did that what bennett
did then it's been a campaign he tried
to get learned at hand the judge to
bring it in
because he thought nobody would stop him
if they did he would have a terrific
case
but han decided finally
but bennett got along with with people
like truma capote
very close or faulkner
he was quite remarkable in in the people
he dealt with and how much they liked
him did you two know william faulkner
well i i was going to mention that
i never knew him i had a wonderful lunch
with him
um i went out with uh
robert linskett one of the editors at
random house and
and uh faulkner had a
lunch in a hotel but the unfortunate
memory i have but which has a resonance
though because of bennett is when i was
asked by life magazine to write an
article on on faulkner's funeral
and they called me on martha's vineyard
and i got on a plane and like bennett
got in touch with me said we're we'll
all go together we'll go down to
mississippi together on this hot
july day so we landed uh with donald and
bennett donald clougher and bennett at
the memphis airport
and i remember walking down the
ramp
and this little
tennessee lady was coming the opposite
direction and i saw her go into kind of
a spasm
of when she saw this saw bennett
and she kept saying
i don't believe it
i don't believe it and we just bennett
sucked on his pipe and one kept walking
and she went past and then
in a frenzy of sort of celebrity
watching she
scamfored back and stood right in front
of bennett
and said aren't you bennett cerf
and he said well yes yes i am says what
are you doing down here bennett she says
um
i'm going to uh
going to bill faulkner's funeral and she
said bill who
and that drove bennett right up the wall
because he had this terrific mixture of
being loved for his celebrity but also
he had this serious side and the idea
that someone wouldn't know who faulkner
was really caused him a great deal of
distress
why have you bob loomis over the years
kept such a low profile
it's easy
is it done have you done it on purpose
yeah
why well because uh
what we do here is
is really private i mean it's
you know it's not public
it's just not
nothing we do i do here it should has
any business
anybody else knowing it's just it
confuses the issue sometimes they think
editors make books sometimes you can
ruin a book it just isn't just doesn't
make any sense and
i i've never felt uh even talking about
it was very rewarding anyway
right it's not that's something else
what do the two of you think the impact
of the book is today versus what it was
when you started
i my own view is that the
lamentations about the book's demise is
uh
overwrought
i believe the books still have an
enormous effect
but forget that question for a moment if
you don't mind and just talk about that
you know when you used to write years
ago when you write now
are you does it resonate as much do you
hear about it as much oh yes i i
i
i think it could be you know you could
say honestly that there is a great deal
of siphoning off of interest because
there's so much competition from every
direction media pop culture and all that
but
i i'm always
reminded of someone's pointing out that
in russia during the heyday of the
of the russian novel
only three percent
of the russian people could read
that that underscores something very
important the idea that
writing novels writing fiction has
always been marginal
in virtually every culture
possibly with the exception of the night
of the victorian period
uh in the 19th century when uh both in
france and in
england you had this
people like dickens and zachary and zola
and so on
still
um
i i really do believe that
that
given the fact of its
marginalization the novel still has an
enormous effect on people once again you
can tell from the feedback you get
by the way you
mostly novels and then the one book on
depression yeah uh which one did you get
the biggest feedback
i mean
well i i think in terms of here i i'm
unable to say because i think in sheer
volume of uh
of
of reaction probably the book on
depression darkness visible as i say i
scarcely a day goes by that i don't get
a letter
bob lewis what about the book uh and by
the way do you know are there more books
published today by far than there was
yes
and and they're selling in greater
quantities
not just in hardcover but paperback
and there's more money to be made
but
bill's right
the noise out there is great the
celebrity culture is great there are
television everything else impinges on
so much time and the idea of a celebrity
i mean
magazines like vanity fair and even
people when people first came out
a lot of people in our business
were ashamed if it was on their desk
because it seemed to be uh rewarding and
and celebrating people who were just
famous
they didn't have to do anything they
they weren't worth it in a way that's
taken over
and talk was a the epitome of that
it seems to talk magazine talk magazine
that has not been good for our business
and except
when once in a while an author is a it
happens to be one of those people
but basically things we do and i like to
do don't fall into that category so we
sense that a lot of attention and is
being paid to other things
except for the fact that more books are
being read and bought than ever before
but but the but the relationship
grew
in in every way so that so that
sometimes people are frustrated because
they don't uh they don't get enough
attention
is there competition uh among authors i
mean you you're a fairly social person
you go you know you're seeing
i mean you're out among the people well
i'm not all that social i do
spend a great deal of time mainly in my
house up in connecticut and martha's
vineyard
more social life in the summer than i
would like i mean i i'm not a recluse if
that's what you well i guess what i was
leaning to do do you see a lot of other
authors
a certain number i uh
i don't hang out
in any
quote literary way with with writers but
i i happen to have a very healthy
friendship
with
not
all the writers of our period but
certainly
most of the writers of my generation
i've i've had very healthy relationships
with
how about you i don't think there's
uh that kind of rivalry very much
people know better than but they are
rival they are they have rivalries about
money
the money paid in advances
uh is some is is
and
that can cause problems and jealousies
among writers it seems to me but of
course that really is so separate from
what
they're really worth or what they're
writing that it remains i think uh in a
separate category but i don't see very
many people
jealous of i think when you're young
there's a certain certain kind of
[ __ ] of the walk rivalry that you have
with your you know the sort of
testosterone stuff that
uh i remember mailer and i had a kind of
a
uh
a a kind of
jealous connection at one time
which led to our break but we're now
reconciled and a friend of mine
i think
that kind of uh
envy and and rivalry is for young people
young writers when you get old you
you're you embrace
every everyone embraces everyone else i
think i would like to think so anyway
to kind of wrap it up i want to ask the
two of you to talk about
this
current controversy i will not put names
on it on purpose so you don't have to
talk about names but the whole business
of plagiarism
and
you have two different perspectives here
you're an editor do you worry about the
plagiarism thing from your standpoint do
you is it your responsibility and you're
the writer if you ever come close to
plagiarizing anything
i
plagiarized heavily in my book
confessions of nat turner i lifted
verbatim
uh
several pages of
of methodist sermons
documents
of course this is acceptable i think in
in in fiction
it's understood that appropriation of
that sort
is perfectly okay
look at i mean virtually all of ulysses
who are mentioning ulysses is a often a
pastiche of other things
i do think it's
it can verge on the reprehensible
uh if it is not acknowledged that is if
taking someone else's material is not
acknowledged in in works of biography
and history and so on is this current
controversy over
several authors
do you consider it valid
yes it's valid
but i don't worry about it first
as far as i can tell none of the
publishers involved knew this
no nor could they except by accident
it's not something that you can go and
read all the other books and see if
there is something like that i think
this is a result of the pressure
of of again
production certainly stephen ambrose who
might admire a great deal
is writing so much and they have people
helping them as doris kearns goodwin did
in giving them material and doing
research and you know handing them stuff
that they could have
inadvertently picked this stuff up and
uh and
if it weren't properly uh identified
they could agree with you they could use
it but on the other hand i can't imagine
a writer reading the manuscript or
galleys of a book and coming across one
of those passages and not realizing they
didn't write it
because you really know what you've
written you know yeah no i i i agree it
depends on the extent and the and the
obvious uh
uh intent of of
of duplication of coughing i have a
feeling that
in dars kearns goodwin's case especially
at least from what i can tell that
most most all of that was inadvertent
was probably uh honestly
unconscious
act really
to wrap it up i want to ask the two of
you how
what have you done for what are we
talking now 50
wow
five years as in friendship
twice the best man in your
weddings
uh how have you stayed friends what have
you done to stay friends and to avoid
the the bad problems well i think we
grew up in a similar at a similar time
the war in in a way
we had in common we had the depression
in common we had a love of literature in
common and then we have his his
professional work in common which is the
biggest bond it's a dangerous one
because that can break and it can be
awful but it didn't
and so those
i always look to him
for what he's going to do next and i
can't wait i'm so proud of somebody
saying you're siren's editor i just
there's nothing better for me that's
what that's what my life is and and
and so from my point of view
i would do everything i could to
keep that relationship and from my point
of view i value bob so much totally
aside from our friendship because he's
my conscience
and i mean that because um
uh i have and this to me is the test of
a great editor
i have like most every writer tried to
get by with things when i was writing
that is saying
well a moment of laziness a moment of
of
of laxity
i'll see if i can get that down
a great editor like bob
in his case has always nailed me
he's always when we've been going over a
manuscript
very gently but firmly he said
what did you mean here and i cringe
inwardly because i realize that he's
caught me out
at something i should not have been
doing and his his unerring instinct
for nailing me at my weakest
is
my contrast maybe two or three times
on that note gentlemen i'll say thank
you thank you
daryn thank you for joining us
thank you
you've been watching an interview with
random house author william styron and
editor robert loomis on the publisher's
75th anniversary visit them online at
randomhouse.com
[Music]
48 hours of non-fiction books on tv
you're watching book tv
on c-span 2.
[Music]
coming up on book tv an interview with
random house editor ann godoff marking
the publisher's 75th anniversary
then a panel of editors from various
publishers on books coming out this fall
[Music]
tonight on book tv hellenic studies
professor andre yural yumatos chronicles
the history of the balkans from the 14th
century up to the nato bombing of serbia
after that historian kenneth heinemann
on 1960s campus activism put your bodies
under the wheels
and later time science correspondent
madeline nash discusses el nino on the
pacific born weather system and its
impact on the world's ecological systems
[Music]
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals
next week in eastern europe it's the
warsaw international book fair the
program runs may 15 to 19th from the
palace of culture and science
then we close out may back in america
for the catholic press association's
annual convention in minneapolis
minnesota
if you missed book tv's live coverage of
book expo america in new york city last
weekend head north for toronto in june
and get a look behind the scenes in the
book business at book expo canada
in july spoken word artists non-fiction
writers and children's books authors
will be heading uptown in new york city
for the harlem book fair
late summer aspiring writers will gather
in craigville beach for the 40th annual
cape cod writers conference there
published authors will lead workshops in
children's books fiction nonfiction and
poetry
and in september the baltimore book
festival features non-fiction writers
like william burroughs author of by any
means necessary cookbook authors such as
sharon borsten and up-and-coming writers
including naomi rand author of the one
that got away
please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list email us at booktv
cspan.org
you're watching book tv
only on c-span 2
created by the cable television industry
next you'll hear from ann godoff the
editor-in-chief of random house trade
box she talks about her career at the
publishing house this year marking its
75th anniversary this interview in new
york city is just over half an hour
and got off here the publisher the
president
the editor-in-chief
of random house what does that mean
i'm a lucky girl
i think it means that
random house the
random house publishing trade publishing
division
basically is run by an editor
on someone who
thinks about authors and books
first i come from an editorial
orientation i
take my job as editor-in-chief very
seriously
and it informs everything that i do
every publishing decision and
and i think it really speaks to the um
to the makeup and constitution of our
list
let's break the three down as a
publisher what's your job
it's to oversee the entire list in terms
of marketing
and sales
and decisions about what
books to print and when and how many
um and it's much more of a kind of
oversight job for the entire list for
the random house group and velard that
division and the modern library as well
so how many books would that be a year
oh gosh um well i would say there are
about 125 hardcover books at random
house
where we've now started a trade
paperback line and that's an additional
75 random house trade paperback
the modern library
probably about 125 as well both in
hardcover and paperback and velard about
between 40 and 50 titles so whatever
that adds up to um
it's a lot of books
i don't know if you you can tell us this
or not but in the modern library of 125
is it 125 titles
what's the biggest seller
oh my um this year uh it was uh karen
armstrong's islam um in part because of
the events of this year but we do a
chronicle series and hardcover um
significant pieces of history uh in a
short form and um and karen armstrong's
uh
short history of islam i think is
probably the copy winner this year
what's the book though that's uh you
know i'm backless
bestseller best you know that
every year sells
is atlas drug in your no
no um
no it isn't uh we published atlas
shrugged in hardcover but no it's uh
paperback life resides elsewhere uh i
think it probably would be the best
seller if uh if we had it but we don't
i don't know brian to be honest i don't
know what the best seller is i'd have to
ask david ebershoff the publisher well
let's go then to your next
responsibility editor-in-chief what do
you do in that role
in that role
i oversee
the acquisition of new books and new
titles and then ultimately um the
decision about when to publish
a title that we've acquired
and every
kind of bolt tightening that has to
happen
about
any given title
i think the
editor-in-chief role is the one i'm in a
way the most comfortable with because it
also deals with the
fostering of editorial talent you know
being an editor is really uh a job i
love and also a job that i understand to
be an apprenticeship
and and one that really
you learn by observing and you learn by
having experience and i take that role
as the editor-in-chief very seriously to
pass down my experience into and to
hearken to the experience of my
colleagues here it's a pretty
experienced group as you'll see how many
people work for you
well in the whole division it's probably
about 90. um
but among the editors the senior
editorial staff's about
10 or 12. do you still edit i do yeah i
have a list of my own who are you
working with now
oh gosh um i'll leave some people out so
therefore i'll be in real i'll be in
real trouble um
in no particular order uh salman rushdie
uh zadie smith
um christopher reeve
uh in the in the relative near term
those are some of the people i've also
i'm ron chernow's editor michael pollan
um ron cheering out let's take him just
for him okay he did the book on
rockefeller he did
are you doing a new one he is on
alexander hamilton when is that coming
i think he's about two years away from
delivering so we're probably about three
years away from publishing so as you
work with him on that how often do you
see his work i mean how does that
process work everybody works differently
um
very often with nonfiction you see
things incrementally you see them in
small bits and then you edit that bit
and if everything is going well then you
encourage people and you keep it to the
side if things are going as i say south
then we uh we call everything up short
and we take a look at it and and
reconnoiter um and that can be in that
that could be in chapter intervals it
could be in um
you know hundred page intervals um with
ron he's a first draft guy he likes to
write a first draft through um and then
i edit from the first draft and we have
a very significant set of conversations
around that first draft editing and then
from there we
look at it and and and see what happens
he writes he writes cleanly he does take
he takes editing which is good he likes
it loves it actually and we have a
wonderful set of dialogues around that
first draft by the way what do you do
when somebody doesn't like editing
it depends who it is
it really depends who it is i think
everyone benefits from from editing
frankly i think there's hardly anyone
who doesn't um
[Music]
if they really don't like it um
then we we even talk about that and we
sometimes talk about that at length
and i've generally found that people say
they don't like editing but then they
come around to it kind of sleep on it
and
maybe for a couple of weeks they sleep
on it but when they do
they they come to see that maybe there's
something that's being raised even if
they don't agree with it
completely there's something that's
being raised that a reader would raise
because that's what an editor is is the
first reader first close reader and uh
if you do that job properly you're not
you're you know you will then be
addressing the reader's concerns and
every writer wants to address the
reader's concerns so that's the that's
the dialogue that happens and i i've
found that most people in the end kind
of come
back
to thinking that they should be edited
your third responsibility president
what's that
i don't know it's just a letterhead
thing i think i'm not altogether sure
it's a it's a it's a corporate
responsibility i guess in a way it's um
it's something that
i never thought i'd be that's for sure
um the president of anything uh
it just really speaks to a kind of
divisional role and capacity and and it
um allows me to speak for this division
um when i'm talking to my fellows at
other divisions who are presidents
that's about it i don't do anything
presidential that i'm aware
this this is the 75th anniversary of
this this this title this name this
imprint
random house
now owned by germans yes
what's that done
to this
whole i mean how does it fit
um i think that
that bernoullisman in fact has created
an atmosphere for us to um to really
be a very independent entity that's very
much the um that's very much their
managerial posture um we are the
divisions publishing divisions are very
different each to each and that has been
encouraged um and in fact uh it
certainly acknowledged and i think very
much encouraged so
so quite literally i don't think
anything has
has changed in the practical day to day
we're of course responsible to this
larger
company um but the idiosyncrasies uh
that are random house uh and we um we
revel in in those idiosyncrasies and i
think that comes to define us and comes
to define our list and make people feel
comfortable here and also
allows for
allows for us to present ourselves in
the marketplace as a very distinct and
important publishing entity
those idiosyncrasies are are
more than indulged there as i say are
encouraged by that that parent
corporation now what are some of those
idiosyncrasies
well i think that you know
we're very proud of our
um heritage at random house um and it's
they're a collection we're a collection
of individuals
um with a with a history that uh that we
understand and that we um we pride
ourselves in i mean the whole place of
course now is called
random house so the random house trade
publishing division is a division of the
larger
random house
um i've said to my boss peter olsen
that there doesn't seem to be any
confusion in my mind because in fact
we're of course
the real random house
[Music]
i don't know how well that washes with
my colleagues but it certainly is the
way we seem to feel here that this
history of 75 years of publishing this
history of publishing you know very
strong
titles in a very broad number of
categories which is why in fact it was
called random house to begin with
requires that the people who
shepherd those titles are people who
have very varied interests and um and so
as a result have um kind of interesting
uh personality quirks and interesting in
a variety of ways of
of articulating their passions
because that's what you that's what you
want and that collection of of
interesting people and the fostering of
that
that group is exactly um what random
house should be so we should be random
in our um in our title acquisition and
we should be random in our personnel as
well i think you're here in midtown
manhattan at the moment on park avenue
but that's not going to be forever where
will you move to we're moving to um a
building that's being built on
on
broadway and
56th street i think and when everything
is in there right is that all
bertelsmann is that what's going to be
or it's all the publishing it's all
random house it's all the publishing
divisions of the greater random house
how many different including the real
randomizers how many different besides
your imprint random house how many
different other
uh imprints
it's uh um bantam and bantam dell uh
broadway and uh doubleday canav and
vintage
um valentine
uh crown
the audio divisions of random house it's
a it's a
substantial group anybody ever
totaled up the number of books now
hardback non-fiction fiction books
coming out of all those companies in one
year they have i just i don't have that
over a thousand years i
so who has sat in your chair in the past
uh
um
a number of people i have sat in my
chair um before me harry evans who
um
i took over for and before that joni
evans
um
and then howard kaminsky
and um
now going back um i guess it was in the
original days
yeah
who would have been who had this job
uh bennett surf
um
i guess would have had this job that's
an easy one for me because i grew up
watching him on television yes well he
was much more adept at than i so
and i wanted to ask you about that i
read a profile on you in the new york
magazine
the gentleman said you wouldn't talk to
him no i only talked to you brian you
only you don't like this
um no i i no i don't like this i have a
a kind of um
a mass eye approach to this i think i
think my soul is being destroyed um so
we'll just uh you know we'll just we'll
just say well in this instance and for
this thing that i love which is which is
random house in the discussion of the
75th anniversary of random house um
you know that that maybe my soul's
intact but but uh
but generally i think publicity is is a
negative
why because you obviously are around
people that love publicity yeah
i don't know why entirely i mean i think
that there's um
i think that there's a lot to be
um
a lot to be made of
of working hard
and having it not necessarily
paraded before
large groups of people i think what i do
is
um
very
quiet work generally the best work i do
is is um
you know sitting behind the desk or at a
chair
or talking to people about the work they
do
but it's very you know it's very varied
i do many many things all day long
when i do editorial work i work with
people who are passionate about what
they're writing about
that passion i think
trumps uh trump's media
if you're passionate about what that is
you can then you want to have that
displayed in front of a lot of people
and you can
i feel
perfectly secure in saying i don't like
the media personally because i have many
many
pots to keep simmering
but that my author should go on do a lot
of media because they've spent so much
time being passionate about one thing
and um
but for me i don't i don't think i'm any
good at it for one thing and i also
don't don't think that it it ultimately
kind of um
serves many interests that the many
interests that i have as opposed to the
one that my authors have well with that
having been said i want to ask you about
something very important that i read
about you and i want to know more about
and that is the once sold oldsmobiles
yeah
at what point in your career did you
sell
when i didn't have a career i sold those
bills um
i sold osmobiles right out of
pretty much right out of out of college
i was very very good osmobile salesman
but i use the selling of osmobiles as i
use a lot of things that i did in my
prior life
every day
i think if you if you could sell an
osmobile
you can negotiate with an agent
um and in the end i uh you know
i remember when i was selling osmobills
that i um
they used to have this thing where you
would go back to the manager in the old
days you know to confirm some price that
you had already settled on and you
already well knew in your mind was
you know was fine
um so this going back to the manager
thing is something that i often use and
say okay take a breath
don't say yes right away
that it's a good negotiating tactic
and
so yeah i was a good good automobile
salesman for another reason
i realized that the way my colleagues
selling cars i was
24 i think
that my colleagues
didn't always tell their customers the
truth
about one thing or another
white walls as opposed to where you know
gonna sell your car with
out white walls um
crossfire speakers used to be my
favorite one um which really meant
stereo
uh
anyway there was
an opportunity it seemed to me um when
you were selling cars to tell somebody
the truth
and um really kind of
open your hand to them and say
this is what the car cost me i've got to
make a living too so if i put that
little bit more on it we can have a deal
well i saw cars like there was no
tomorrow everybody just fell like a like
a stone
it was great so i've used that too
every day you sold them here in town
yeah sold on 57th street and 11th avenue
this great great
salesman
for 11 months but
it was it was a very good it was a very
good experience and as i say it really
taught me that
there was a great advantage to telling
the truth in negotiation how many years
did you live in california grew up in
california
and i lived there until i was almost
through high school
beverly hills
yeah
what what impact did living in beverly
hills have on your interests i mean when
did all this start
i always loved to read um and i always
felt that um
you know i had no intention of coming
into publishing i didn't come to
publishing if i was 30 years old um in
fact i was in architecture school
when i took a temporary job at simon
schuster
to kind of pay my way through the end of
architecture school but it turned out
that i liked my temp job more than i
liked
my school
and so um so that was very that was very
clear to me then that i had really found
the right thing albeit
serendipitously
um but i think i think what beverly
hills did was give me a hatred of
publicity it may have done that um and
to a certain extent of um it certainly
cured me from any um as i'm sitting here
talking to your camera of any any uh any
need for a celebrity that's for sure
just us and one other person that's
that's the only way you can deal with
this stuff i guess that's right your
parents did what
my father was in the record business and
um
my mom was a mom and is what about the
reading when did that start
from the very very
very beginning very early i read
very early um there there's a photograph
of me as a very small child holding a
book of that's a much bigger than than i
am um i had
i was
i had
kind of a self-image of somebody who was
a reader and i've always i've always
loved it
remain remain a reader but you went all
the way from the west coast to new york
university
oh with some yes i did in film school
and and what was the draw to come back
here
come back to new york or come to new
york from
my my family's from new york and my
father died uh when i was in in high
school and we moved back just to be with
my family
so you just this was a natural place it
was the right i just was i've been very
i've been very lucky in my life just
having
fallen into the right places and with
the right people and
had the right kinds of experiences
random house 75 years
you've done some things to celebrate
that uh including sitting down here and
talking to us but i mean over here on
the shelf for instance is james joyce's
ulysses yeah you're re-publishing it
yes we're publishing it in the uh with
the original um
the original design the original package
um
to uh to to kind of celebrate the fact
that uh over those 75 years we did some
my my predecessors did some very
um exciting publishing certainly ulysses
was was was up there um and this is to
hearken back to the to the story of of
random house and the publishing story of
random house and uh yeah we've
repackaged um
18 titles uh over the year which we will
publish over the year um and
uh use their use those jackets and use
what we call the back ad the back of the
book and the flaps remain the same and
so that the books will really be kind of
facsimile editions of the editions that
were published in the year they were
published well when that was published
uh very controversial yes
uh language among other things in there
but
today if you tried to publish this
obviously you're going to play but
how does that compare to what's happened
all the what year was it 1920
was it 24 something got me in but
whatever um
what's happened to books
in 75 years
that's not a softball um
what
what do you think's happened
boy i
i think there's great writing that's
going on now
lord knows ulysses is a
was an extraordinary publishing event
there's a story around the publication
of ulysses that's probably not one that
you could replicate in this
day and age
but um
when i look at um when i look at the
people who are writing now and the kinds
of things
that we are publishing
um will there be books that we will talk
about whatever it is 50 years hence
yeah i think that there are um where are
there books that change uh hearts and
minds yes i think there are so there are
probably are more of things that are
similar about um
the effort that goes into writing and to
a certain extent the effort that goes
into publishing um
that are that are very similar to the
ways you know it's a very different
climate it's now a business which it you
know there are many um
many people who who say oh they lament
the loss of the the gentleman's
profession and so on i don't know
whether i lament the loss of the
gentleman's profession precisely um but
i certainly um i certainly think that it
was it was they were different days uh
and easier
and easier days in terms of what um
you know what what was needed for
commercial success
uh
but you know if you go
drill down as we say and you look at the
book and you look at the author and you
look at the the component that the um
the the editorial author relationship
has and the ultimate eventual
publication and ultimately the success
of that book any given book
that's very very much the same and it's
something that i like to
i'd like to talk about and inculcate in
the people who are are here and in the
young editors that are
that are among us and to um and to keep
that fresh that hasn't changed yeah
marketing's changed yes it's books are
more expensive to buy and they're more
expensive to acquire for a publishing
house and they're much more expensive to
market and they're many more vehicles to
market them
with and the relationship with the
stores is is different and more complex
and all of those things are elements and
things we think about every day but in
the end
author to publisher author to editor
that work is the hard work that work is
the same and that's the good work
what do you think the impact
is on book publishing that having
many more women in positions like urine
in the leadership positions decision
positions i have no doubt it's an
absolutely wonderful thing um can you
see the difference though and what books
are being published you know
no um i think that that uh publishing
has been very good place for women for a
very long time um
in in literally in the leadership roles
uh that's not that that's
fairly new relatively new
but
um
as editors as people who were decision
makers
that ceiling has been
has been pierced and was a long time ago
and we have very very talented women
you know for a long time
but i think in terms of acquisition i
don't think that you can you can acquire
at a publisher you know
for or or by gender um that you really
need to to say yeah those these the
primarily the books this particular book
will be read by women or this one made
me by men or maybe this this is this
crosses um
but
i i think that um
as an editor i think you know maybe i
buy more books that
um men would read i think it's very
possible um i certainly do a lot of a
lot of non-fiction that has an
investigative piece and
has a hard edge or um
is
about financial things or whatever um
so
i think that you know interest is
we we kind of
um
put that in a box more than more than in
fact it is i think women read books that
may be earmarked for men more often than
one would suspect and maybe vice versa
would did you edit uh john barents i did
midnight in the garden of good and evil
i did
why did that make it why did that work
that's been asked
many times um and i think it was a
i think we did absolutely everything
right and john barrett did everything
right
um did you did you get him at the
beginning oh yeah
i'll tell you the story of john bear
pretty quickly
i received the book right before lunch
about 10 years ago now almost well nine
years ago and
my lunch date canceled that day so i
bought a sandwich and i sat down with
john barron's book this is absolutely
true
and i didn't get up until i finished
because
i thought oh boy this is something
and um
it's something very different and very
unique and i have to acquire this i have
to find a way to acquire this book
um you didn't have it at that point i
hadn't bought it yet nope i just read it
for acquisition i also thought it's odd
in a way it's odd in the way that's
going to appeal certainly not we had no
idea it was going to appeal in the way
it did but it's very
um it's very different i mean
for example john made a very
deliberate and very intelligent decision
that this book was a true crime except
the crime the literal crime didn't
happen until about 350 pages into the
book
that runs counter
to uh
to everything it was that runs counter
to oh let's have a murder on the first
page uh john built up the city of
savannah as a as a character
and then when that character was well
and truly built up he knew he could
he could kill somebody and get people to
really rush to the end of the book
that's very daring very smart and
doesn't run true to form i loved that i
loved that as an editor and i loved it
because it couldn't be compared to
anything i think one of the problems we
have in
book publishing is we always like to
compare something to something else
if something is comparable to something
else it's therefore somehow to me less
now many many books have been compared
to midnight in the garden
but john was the the first one out of
the out of the box so that thing when i
was finished with it that day after way
way after lunch
i just sat there and kind of simmered
for a while and i thought i've got to
buy this book and i hadn't met john yet
and
i didn't know what a wonderful promoter
he would ultimately be
and he didn't want to sign a deal or do
a deal until he had met the editor so he
met this editor who was
mad for him and mad for this idea and
mad for the uniqueness of this book and
i said to him i promise you i will do
something
worthy of the uniqueness of this book so
we did a number of things right at the
get-go we changed the way the book
looked changed what they call the trim
size the literal physical size of the
book we found something that was iconic
to put on the to put on the jacket
didn't know quite how iconic it was
ultimately going to be but the statue
that statute
and then
we looked at it
well what i called the southern campaign
we were going to build from savannah
and
move the troops north
and we did we started in savannah and we
brought everybody down to savannah all
the
various newspapers and magazines and
had a huge party not unlike the party
that was in the middle of the in the
middle of that book
gave them a lot of punch and set them
out on the streets of savannah to write
their various stories and then john
wove his magic and didn't stop for years
literally years went on the road to talk
about the stories the many stories that
came in the last figure i saw was at
least two and a half million hardback i
guess so
yes i think that's right and paperback i
i i i don't know hundreds of thousands
oh i would say
many many hundreds of thousands if not
more before i forget it is he writing
another book he is writing another book
right now what's it about
i don't know if i can tell you
all i know is that in the discussion i
had him on book notes he said it was it
could be it could possibly be about
venice
he said that to you he did say that
and then he wrote a little piece in the
new york times a couple weeks ago about
venice
but otherwise i have not heard
seen or read yeah we're going to publish
a book by john berent about venice but
john barron's view of venice is
so john berrant that um
when
i would say
two years from now
what i've seen is very wonderful he is
very wonderful he's a wonderful man is
he still does he hold a record on being
on the new york times bestseller list
i don't know
it's like i can't remember how many
remember at the time like 200 at least
200 weeks or something like that
i don't know i'm not sure whether he
holds the record
can you duplicate what he's done by with
anybody else and and
did you know from the beginning i know
you only had 25 000 copies at first
printing yeah
no i mean i i think can we duplicate it
i hope so every every morning i wake up
and i hope so um
but
i think i think you don't entirely know
it was a great confluence of
a terrific book with a with an
indefatigable author and a good package
and a lot of other things
can we do that again i hope
i hope john can do it again
but i think it's just one of those one
of those lightning strikes i've got to
turn your time back to you because we're
about out of time and i want to ask you
the last question why do you do this
what is it
about this that you like that is a
softball
i like that it's different every day
um
that i get to deal with the most
intelligent group of colleagues
i can even imagine
um that every day people come in and
talk to me about
affairs of the heart really things that
they are consumed with
intellectually and um and often very
emotionally
about things that they're going to
write about
and i can
help them make that
affair of the heart a reality um
you know you were asking me about
selling cars when i sold cars the part i
liked about selling cars best was
when i delivered a car when somebody
came in and picked it up
often what i like best now is to either
write the note with the finished book as
it comes off press or to literally give
a finished book to an author that's
a variant of delivering a car
a variant kind of raised by some
enormous exponent because when you see
an author who has worked as hard as any
author has
on a manuscript that ultimately becomes
a bound book
that
often can become
[Music]
something that people talk about in this
forum and in many uh across the country
and we can get it into people's hands
and that then
when a reader sits down and has this
very unique uh
experience with the
written word it's a very private and
intimate thing in this culture we don't
have very many private and intimate
moments
but reading is one of them
it's something you do
alone and it's something you do
for yourself and it's something you do
basically to to
want more for yourself it's a positive
um and i think that's um that's a
wonderful charge to have
that's a very important and sacred trust
and this sounds mushy but i honestly
honestly believe it i love
what i do because what i do
results in in
a bound book and in the printed word and
and making that and bringing that thing
to a lot of people um and i do that from
what i consider to be the the bully
pulpit which is random
got off house
how easy that was thank you very much
just a snap thank you publisher
editor-in-chief and
president president of random house
thank you very much thank you
you've been watching an interview with
ann godoff the editor-in-chief of random
house trade books on the publisher's
75th anniversary visit them online at
randomhouse.com
because basically i like the um
the author jeff shara he's a terrific
author and i got into this because i'm
going backwards from the civil war back
to the mexican war
now from book expo america in chicago
the country's largest book industry
trade show a preview of some of the new
books coming out this fall
robert schwab director of marketing for
classic americana publishing
incorporated what is your company our
company is a
a publishing firm that's really trying
to bring back
a lot of classic literature that has
fallen out of print
where we have a strong emphasis on
african-american titles although we
really look at the broader picture and
have books that were popular in their
day around the turn of the century
and uh some of them had big print runs a
message to garcia one that we're
bringing back just now
uh had 41 million copies in print in its
day literally circled the globe
uh and uh yet fell out of print a lot of
people
remember it would like to have it but
can't find it and that's what we're
about we're trying to bring these back
in a way that they'll stay in print
and make them accessible to people
let's talk a little bit more about
message to garcia the little book down
there on the table how did that book
come to be published by you and what is
the story again well messenger garcia
started out as an article in a magazine
by a fellow by the name of hubbard he's
had a company called the roy crofters
and it was a
company that specialized in printing
fine quality books and magazines
it was picked up by the western new york
railwray
as kind of a
piece that they handed out to their
employees
it talked about loyalty employable
employee loyalty
that started something that became
a worldwide phenomena
a russian prince came over to the united
states traveled on the western new york
railway saw a copy of it said i want my
employees on the russian railway to have
it then when russia went to war with
china
they had all their soldiers carry it the
chinese soldiers founded on dead russian
soldiers said well if they're carrying
it our people should have it
then the japanese when they got involved
with the conflict with china the same
kind of transmission until 41 million
copies literally circled the globe
um it was this period uh this was right
around the turn of the century around
1900
uh it talks really about a time period
of the spanish-american war
and it was a story about a lieutenant
rowan who was commissioned by president
mckinley to bring a message to the cuban
insurgents that were trying to break
away from spain
it's a preachment it really talks about
loyalty but there's a story behind the
story and that's what we try to do in
our books is add a little bit more of
the historical perspective we found
rowan's actual story his first hand
story
that he published in 1922
and it's it's a marvelous adventure
story about how he
sailed from jamaica into cuba went over
land
found a general garcia
uh conveyed the message then came back
with some emissaries maps that helped
then the united states make its landing
into the cuban
island and then take eventually that
as a
kind of a statehood for a number of
years two other books two other books i
see here uh one by w.e.b du bois
uh the souls of black folks
of the bla of black folk and the
jefferson bible could you tell me about
those sure
wub du bois is probably one of the best
known black american authors
he's probably also one of the most
controversial he's considered the father
of the civil rights movement his book is
about 13 essays that cover the time
period of the carpetbaggers and the
reconstruction of the south to the early
period in the united states when civil
rights became a topic
he he broaches some very significant
topics like the color line
provide some answers he himself became
disenfranchised with the united states
later on in life he helped found the
naacp he formed a magazine called the
crisis
and then towards the very end of his
life he moved to ghana as a communist
rejecting the united states because he
couldn't see a hope
to the solution of race in the country
the jefferson bible is very interesting
because it came out of jefferson's
library which became the beginnings of
the library of congress celebrating its
200th birthday
it was forgotten he had clipped passages
of the bible and pasted them in a little
book that he used as a devotional kept
it very private because he didn't like
people to know that he had any religious
inklings
uh when he died that got passed on to
the library congress it was lost until
somebody found it they published a
special edition just for congressman and
then it went out of print and we brought
it back so that every american enjoy
the the treasure that he left
and to that we added some of his
writings which deal with how he lived
the faith that he talked about in
his bible are most of these books i also
see the confessions of nat turner are
they available in other forms
yes they are
not through us many of these books are
available as e-documents
you might find them
in
classic collections but they're not
generally available to people
nat turner for example is up on the web
but unless you have the ticket price
a computer and access that way you can't
read about that passage of history so
for 499
we can bring it to almost everyone in
the united states in a way that will
last another book you mentioned was
retro racism that's a newer book that's
a brand new book and it's dealing with
the subtle issues of race in corporate
america and in
education and in government
it doesn't look at the overt things but
rather looks at the quiet racism that's
occurring in the united states very much
rampant today
it doesn't have answers but ask
questions and provides a platform for
people to discover where they stand in
their own lives and racism
where would books like this be available
for people and how many copies of say
the jefferson bible how would that how
would you expect that to sell we expect
the jefferson bible to sell well because
it probably will be a crossover book it
will sell probably very well in the
christian marketplace it will sell well
in trade channels they'll also sell well
in non-traditional sites like
museum gift stores and things like that
other books will have entrees into the
very few black book sellers in america
there's quite a following of these
titles because
they're very interested in
their past and a lot of these books have
not been available recently so there's a
following there
colleges and universities want these for
their history studies
libraries are buying them but we do see
a general trade market as well for these
and where would somebody saw this
interview be able to
find one of these books i'm sure they're
going to be able to find them in barnes
noble
they should be able to find them in
borders
the bigger chains they'll also be able
to find them on amazon
we also have a website where they're
available at classicalamericanabooks.com
so
there'll be a lot of places they can
find these
robert schwab of classic americana
publishing incorporated thank you thank
you good to be with you
you're watching book tv
each weekend c-span 2 offers you 48
hours of programs about non-fiction
books authors and the publishing
industry
write to us with your comments you can
reach us on the world wide web at
www.cspan.org
now james west talks about and reads
from his book william styron a life
the book traces styron's life and
discusses his many books including
sophie's choice the confessions of nat
turner and darkness visible
james west is an english professor at
penn state university he spoke in state
college pennsylvania at shepherd's book
center an independent bookstore set to
close at the end of this month
thank you all for coming here today it's
it's a great pleasure to be here and to
talk to you about
my book on william styron
um
i think all of you know in general who
william styron is and uh something of
his background
he is a southern author but he's a child
of the new south he's by no means a
product of the old
magnolias and moonlight south of popular
fiction and
movies uh he comes from newport news
virginia
which is
a virginia
town that really has
not much in the way of conventional
history it's not the sort of
history say that williamsburg just
across just up the river
has
it's instead a raw
vital
commercial
transient kind of uh city
and i think maybe for that reason uh
william styron was not as closely bound
to
the south as many other writers have
been it's not as if he were from oxford
mississippi for instance or from
asheville north carolina as faulkner and
wolf respectively were
but he certainly has remained a southern
writer and the south figures large in
his thinking and his writing
as you probably have been able to tell i
myself am from the south and from the
tidewater region of virginia is a
distinctive accent
there are many southern accents and mine
has a
particular quality to it and as a matter
of fact living as i do in central
pennsylvania i'm often asked about it
and
sometimes asked whether
it has ever been of of use to me and
indeed it has because
a movie has been made of styron's
short story shadrach it's one of the
stories the middle story
in his collection
a tidewater morning
and the story is set in tidewater
virginia in about 1935
and they needed someone with a tidewater
accent so that the actors would know how
to talk harvey keitel who is a marvelous
actor
is the protagonist in the piece
andy mcdowell plays his wife
she already has a southern accent it's a
south carolina accent but it seemed to
work well enough
but uh keitel was from brooklyn and he
was having trouble with the accent and
so they asked styron they said
do you know anyone who has
the right kind of accent a tidewater
virginia accent and he said oh yeah jim
west
and
so don't you know they brought me up to
new york city and i spent the afternoon
with
harvey keitel and his voice coach
and uh i felt a little bit like a
specimen you know they had me tell funny
stories and they tape recorded those and
they
uh every now and then would shove a
microphone in my face and say things
like would you repeat that diphthong
please
um but i did all of that and i also
[Music]
i read some of the
lines from the script to try to get the
right pronunciation and intonation
so according to styron who saw parts of
this movie being shot down in north
carolina
his daughter by the way is the director
susannah styron
according to styron before they would do
a scene
harvey keitel and his voice coach would
go over in a corner and sort of listen
to the tapes and
get it all in his head and then he'd go
out and shoot the scene
the afternoon that i spent with kytel
before i left he was already imitating
me and it was really uncanny to me
how good he was at it
he he really is quite skilled at picking
up the accent
i liked him a lot he was a funny fellow
and very rafish and told some good
stories
but at any rate
he used my accent in the
in the movie
and then later on they needed somebody
to do the voice over they got martin
sheen to do that but again he needed the
right accent so they got out the same
old tapes and
i think he plugged them into his tape
deck and drove around a while and
listened to him then he did the voice
over so
i want you to know that when you see
that movie it opens next fall that is my
accent up there on the silver screen
that is
as near i suppose as i'll ever get to it
um
well people often ask me how i proceeded
with a living subject
i think i operated rather in the way
that boswell did james boswell as he
worked with
over the years to gather material for
his life of samuel johnson
boswell would come out of the wilds of
scotland and uh go down to london and
travel around with johnson and listen to
him and write down his witticisms and
bulmos
and i did the same sort of thing about
two or three times a year i would come
out of the wilds of central pennsylvania
and
visit styron either in connecticut
or in his summer home in martha's
vineyard
and
i would listen to him i would take walks
with him
i would ask him some questions but
i found out pretty early
in this project that he doesn't really
respond very well to direct questions
so i learned just to listen to be quiet
to observe and
every now and then i would excuse myself
and go to my room and write down some
things that i had heard which you need
to do in order to
get the uh the wording exactly right
um
but that's the way i worked i began the
biography 12 years ago i've actually
studied styron's writings for much
longer than that more like 25 years but
over that 12-year period i visited him
many times i had access to his papers at
the library of congress and at duke
university
and he gave me
permission to see everything that i
asked him to see and he never asked me
what i was writing
i think
he felt that perhaps my
version of what his life had been might
interfere with his own version and he
said to me once you know you and i are
working the same territory
so
he never asked to see what i was writing
didn't really seem terribly curious
about it which struck me as odd
um
i asked him about it one time uh and uh
he said that he had been written about a
great deal in his life and that uh in in
some ways was indifferent to the process
now so these were great advantages for a
biographer
i had carte blanche and
really to write whatever i wanted to
when the book was finished and the
publisher had accepted it suggested a
few revisions which i made i did ask
siren then to read the book
and he did so and he suggested
to me that i take a second look at oh
about 20
particular readings he thought that i
might be wrong about some factual matter
but it was strictly factual matters i
checked and
sometimes he was right sometimes i was
but he didn't ask me in any way to
revise an interpretation or to leave
anything out
and so again i think i had extraordinary
freedom and i'm grateful to stern for
that
i think he trusted me and
it uh i think was a pretty comfortable
collaboration they're not really a
formal one uh in that sense
um
what are the advantages
of working on
a living writer
well
the advantages are that
you have living witnesses to talk to and
often that was
one of the that was some of the most
intense work
that i did
very exciting to
do interviews with people
i had been used to working with archival
evidence and
you know a document will sit still on
the page and on the
table and be quoted
but
in living interviews you can't always
control what will happen
it's really a fascinating sort of thing
to do
but i suppose the greatest advantage was
that i got to be first i got to make the
first interpretation
most biographers are working behind
other biographers and so they need to
either react to what those biographers
have done or sometimes disagree
sometimes it's wonderful to have
somebody you can disagree with
and make your own biography a
revision of what's gone before but i
didn't have that
i had to figure it out as i went along
um
so that's sort of an advantage and a
disadvantage you get to be first you get
to be the person the others must react
to and there will be other biographies
of william stein i'm quite sure already
there are two other people who are are
working on biographies
um
but on the other hand it can be a lonely
feeling being out there without anyone
to have gone there ahead of you
um it's also wonderful to have access to
that kind of material as i did in the
archives but for a living writer much of
that material has not yet gone to the
archives and so you have to go out and
scout up a lot of it on your own
you have to find the people who have the
letters and the documents you have to
find the manuscripts
and it's been a great advantage to me
to
be able to find that material and then
channel it to styron's papers at duke
university
by the way i should mention that there
is a wonderful exhibit
of those manuscripts up at duke
university right now it'll be there
through the end of april and a great
many people have already seen it and i
hope that others will
as well
well what i'll do i'll um go ahead and
give a reading
from the biography just read a passage
for you
and
then you all can ask me questions uh if
you like and i'll answer as best i can
i mentioned a little while ago
that um uh
with uh with stein one of the things i
did when i would visit him is i would go
with him for walks this is a habit that
he has
and so
to open the book i decided to write what
i call a preamble and
i did mean that pun
in which
we take a walk together and i describe
what the process is like
if one wishes to know william styron one
must walk with him
that is to say one must go with him on
his daily walk for exercise
it's a ritual that he rarely misses
usually he takes the walk alone though
sometimes he goes with his wife or
friend or visitor
the walk covers between four and five
miles
unless the weather is bad in which case
it's abbreviated
preparations for the walk began around
three o'clock with the calling of the
dogs
their two dogs just now both females a
golden retriever named tashmoo and a
black labrador named dinah
tashmu is sweet tempered and shy
dinah is brash and adventurous
styron is devoted to them both but is
especially fond of dinah who amuses and
exasperates him
he summons the dogs by hooting at them
baby who come to daddy who come on
the dogs attuned to the schedule
are ready
dinah appears dirty and panting
teshmu who's been resting
trots over to styron and waits
an old coat is spread over the back seat
of the car and the dogs jump in
styron and his guests settle into the
front seats
styron starts the engine and puts the
car into motion
styron almost always drives to the
beginning point of a walk
he has explored and made measured off
many walking paths
near his two homes and he rarely takes
the same walk two days in a row
the paths themselves are far from
automobile traffic but one must drive
through traffic to reach them
styron operates the car skillfully he
drives impatiently and a little too fast
on the way he announces the location and
direction of our walk for the day and
then talks baby talk to dinah who licks
the back of his head and bites his ears
while he's driving
styron arrives at the starting point
sets the dogs loose and begins the walk
he takes the first half mile at a
relaxed amble to loosen the muscles
then he settles into a steady pace that
accelerates the heartbeat and gives the
lungs a workout
though 72 years old styron can outwalk
many men 20 or 30 years his junior
including this one
he walks in a sprattle-legged gate
slightly slow-footed and leans forward
from the waist
the exercise is good for his bronchial
troubles he clears his throat and blows
his nose frequently on these walks
especially during the winter
the conversation on the walks is good
sometimes styron talks about something
he's been reading
an editorial from the new york times
perhaps or a memoir written by a friend
but other times he mentions critics of
his own work clearing his throat and
spitting out the names of unsympathetic
book reviewers with great vehemence
sometimes he does wonderfully profane
riffs on the republicans
he likes to discuss politics and during
the reagan and bush administrations he
would vent his irritations over their
dastardly behavior
styron does most of the talking during
these walks it's satisfying to listen
for he's a good talker
the dogs provide diversion
tashmu the golden retriever
stays close by styron her head at his
knee occasionally she leaves to sniff a
bush or lap water from a pool
then she returns and falls back into
step with styron
dinah the lab is a canine pinball
tearing through the woods after
squirrels and rabbits seeming to bounce
off trees in stone fences
if styron cannot hear her he becomes
worried and begins to hoot for
if she does not come he grows angry and
calls her harshly
dinah come here
she returns
when it suits her muddy and grinning
then sets off again in a few moments
the walks vary according to the seasons
from early october until june of each
year styron and his wife rose
live near roxbury connecticut this is
rolling hilly wooded country sparsely
populated and quiet
the walks here are best during the fall
when the leaves are turning and the
southbound geese
pass overhead
honking and beating their wings
styron often takes his walks along the
shepaug river a tributary of the
husatonic
unless he has a guest he frequently sees
no other human being on these walks
the styrons spin june through september
of every year at vineyard haven a town
on the island of martha's vineyard
and here the walks are more lively
styron must dodge tourists on bicycles
and motor scooters as he drives to the
starting point of the walk
he curses as he accelerates and swings
the car to avoid them
some of the paths around vineyard haven
lead through quiet leafy woods but other
walks take us through republican
territory
enclaves of well-to-do stock brokers and
attorneys from new york and boston who
have weekend places on the island
one of the walks up through an area
called west chop
leads through a tennis compound for the
wealthy
the courts are usually filled in the
afternoon with middle-aged women playing
doubles
often a cocktail party is about to get
underway and we pass plump sunburned men
and brightly colored golf pants
escorting thin women with carefully made
up faces
styron is a strange figure among these
well-turned-out professional people
he wears rumpled khakis and a
nondescript shirt his hair now almost
white is long and windblown his shoes
are dusty
many of these people seem to know who he
is but they do not speak to him or greet
him
the walk is sometimes circular but more
often it leads to a halfway point where
we turn and retrace our steps to the car
the dogs now wet and tired are told to
get into the back seat
tashmoo cooperates but diner refuses to
get in until she has made styron angry
and caused him to shout at her
the drive back is pleasant
our chests and backs are sweaty and our
legs tingle from the exercise
the rest of the day will be laid out on
the return drive
there will be a period now when styron
will go into his study to write
then he will reappear around 7 30 or 8.
dinner will be ready around 9 o'clock
one is free until then to read or take a
nap
at times during these walks styron
speaks about himself about his
upbringing in tidewater virginia his
education in prep school and college
his stints in the marine corps
often he talks about his father who died
in 1978
sometimes he tells stories
of his travels to france or india or
russia or mexico or he talks of academic
life and says how glad he is to have
avoided it
one listens carefully for styron is
articulate perceptive and witty
one adds a comment occasionally and
sometimes carries the conversation for a
hundred yards or so but styron does most
of the talking
if one has taken these walks over many
years and has listened to these talks
before one knows by now that styron will
have revealed very little about himself
and what he has said
his words will have been sharp and
penetrating but he will have given no
real glimpse of himself
his ambitions and desires his obsessions
and fears his fantasies and dreams
to someone accustomed to the talk of
literary people this was at first
surprising
often such people are free with their
inner feelings and almost confessional
in what they say in conversation
even to virtual strangers
styron does not show himself in this way
he is among the most private of authors
on a few occasions there is seemed to be
a hint of fear or a note of longing in
his voice
but perhaps
one has only imagined these things
perhaps after all our walks have only
been for exercise
william styron can be apprehended and
understood best through what he has
written
his novels and other fictions are
immensely and painfully self-revealing
and it's always been a curious relief to
turn to them in the weeks and months
between the walks
perhaps styron is too private a man to
be approached directly
still
one can undertake the task
one can go on the walk observe and
listen
so that's my preamble
and
i hope that gets people going into the
book
i should should warn potential readers
that this is a southern author and we
have to establish
who he's kin to so there is a chapter of
genealogy in the beginning sometimes i
felt like a little old lady in tennis
she was at the card catalog you know at
the historical society writing all this
up but
once you get through that chapter
and
william styron is born i think it moves
along with a little bit a little bit
more momentum but we did have to say who
he was
who he was akin to
well let's see if uh if anyone then has
questions i'll i'll try to answer them
okay you've described how styron didn't
interfere during the writing process of
this what has been his attitude since
the book has been finished
well
after styron
read the book in typescript he he told
me he thought it was a very good
biography that it was quite fair and
that he hoped someday he would meet the
man it was about
um
i think there's a certain element of
truth to that that's to say biography is
a kind of
synthetic
genre
and what you do is you invent a
narrative that
fits the available facts that you have
but
sometimes
you don't have enough facts to to fill
it out and so there's a certain amount
of imagination that goes along
with it
as a matter of fact
after styron had read the book uh he and
i were at dinner one night he was giving
a reading down in richmond and i was
introducing him and
a very nice young man who had taken us
to dinner
uh asked me i think he was trying to
make conversation he said
if
if there was a a place in mr stern's
life
where you didn't know what happened
what did you do and i said well i just
made something up
and uh styron who i i got my laugh that
way and and uh styron who was sitting
across from me at the dinner table said
uh
yes actually those were the parts that i
enjoyed the most
so uh that's not literally true
but
there was a certain amount of
as for any biographer a certain
synthetic quality to trying to put
together the narrative that would fit
the facts that i had
i do think that styron is uh reasonably
pleased with the biography there are
many things revealed about him in there
many many private things
he has told me that there's a certain
melancholy quality though that uh you
know seeing your life encapsulated this
way between uh
between hard covers
uh lends a certain note of finality i
suppose that he
may find a little melancholy but in
general i think he's uh reasonably well
satisfied
other questions did you find yourself
identifying with darren while you wrote
this
well i did um
as a matter of fact it's a danger many
biographers speak of that it's a danger
that
will will come upon you
when you write a biography and you
really have to guard against it
actually what i found myself doing was
using the persona of william sarin that
i had created to
promulgate some of my own ideas
styron's politics and mine are
reasonably close but they don't match
exactly and so sometimes i would find
myself
for instance putting things in his mouth
about academic life that really
are my ideas
i did that and it felt good
but
later i would i would go back and read
those
passages and i would realize that uh
that was not right that was not correct
those were not his ideas so
uh i tried to guard against um that sort
of thing
i will say that um styron and i are
friendly we're on amicable terms but
we're not by any means intimate friends
and so
there's always been a certain distance
and formality in the relationship which
i rather like and i think he does too so
no i didn't identify with him
more i think than is average for any
biographer to do
other questions
now
one of the biggest challenges that i had
in
writing this biography actually was in
blending together the various voices
that needed to be used there was my own
voice as
narrator i suppose or biographer
but i had styron styron's voice also
that i wanted to to blend in
i think that's one of the things that
basel did awfully well in his biography
of samuel johnson is uh he blended
uh johnson's voice in i found with
styron that i really had many different
voices
to work with there was the voice from
the letters
sometimes a youthful voice
sometimes the voice of someone looking
back over a long time
something that had happened to him in
his youth
there was his voice from his own
writings both his fiction and his
nonfiction his own memoirs and
reminiscences about his life
and um
then there was his voice from interviews
these are both
the kinds of interviews that are
published and you can quote that way or
interviews that
i had on tape i didn't do a lot of that
i did three long interviews
which are in the
oral history collections now at columbia
university
but um uh
i did have that voice as well to work
with plus just
the the voice from casual remarks that
he would make to me from time to time
and i would later write down
all of those voices are different
and
so often what i found myself doing was
writing a framework and then letting
starring himself reveal himself
through what he said rather than to act
as some biographers do and you know sort
of hold the subject up like this and
and in an expository fashion explain uh
what the um
person is like i tried to work rather
more as a novelist
and
let the character
let the subject reveal himself to the
reader
i wondered if you
found any answers thought about
the ways in which starring sort of has
his
desire willingness to be risky in terms
of entering history and
taking history on
fictionally um and it it strikes me that
the siren has taken uh great risks in a
you know a decade that um is this very
suspicious or decades when people
already very suspicious about the ways
in which history is fiction and who's
speaking and why they're speaking
did you
find any answers
for why styron
was willing to do that
and wanted to
it's a good question um
yes i did find
uh
one
salient answer
starring is cantankerous
uh he's a person who likes to
uh i won't say be confrontational but
there is that quality in his his fiction
that he wants to
write difficult novels his novels are
uncooperative
uh they're hard to teach for that reason
because they don't give the answers that
students expect to find
i think he's paid a price as a matter of
fact for taking the kinds of chances
you're talking about he has been a
controversial author
of course from a biographer's point of
view that's wonderful because it gives
you a lot of things to write about to go
back to
samuel johnson
there's a quote from johnson that goes
approximately this way
for the shuttle [ __ ] of fame to be kept
aloft it must be struck on both sides of
the net
so it's wonderful when you have an
argument going on
the two big arguments about styron's
writings center around the confessions
of nat turner on the one hand stein's
audacity in
attempting to enter the consciousness of
a black slave rebel
[Music]
over a hundred years before he wrote the
confessions of nat turner before styron
wrote his his novel
and also
his um
appropriation of history and his
alteration of historical fact about the
net turner rebellion in order to make
that the literary work it became
and then also
with sophie's choice to again have the
nerve to write about the holocaust
from the point of view of a white
gentile
now he did set certain boundaries for
himself there he never actually entered
into the death camps at auschwitz
and his subject was sophie who is a
polish catholic rather than a jew
but still styron caught a fair amount of
criticism for those
uh
uh
experiments too
i think he will be remembered for many
things
as a writer but maybe you have hit on
the most
important one that is his willingness to
cross boundaries
to cross boundaries of race or ethnicity
or experience
and to try to embody
those big tough
questions of our century
in his novels
okay
um you opened by describing star as a
southern writer and then qualifying a
little bit by talking about newport news
as not being old south
i'm curious as to
what makes him still be considered a
southern writer he hasn't really lived
in the south for i guess for 50 years
and except for lie down in darkness
which clearly comes out of a southern
tradition the other novels don't
seem to be as much the works of a
southern writer yet he's referred to
that way so is there something about his
writing that
makes that or is it just the
happenstance of his birth
i think actually it's undoubtedly my own
prejudice in this manner
now um
you're right uh he is a southern writer
who has moved out and beyond his his
southern roots
uh i think the influences that have
worked on saren have been
at least as much cosmopolitan
particularly his periods of residence in
france and in italy
and his experience in europe generally
i think styron understood early in his
career that
if he stuck with
exclusively with southern material he
ran the risk of being seen as a
parochial writer
a regionalist and he really isn't
so you're right
i do think though that
the experience of his first
oh
15 years particularly in newport news
and then his education which was in
southern universities
has had strong influence on him and he
returns to those subjects even in
sophie's choice and set this house on
fire which have uh long parts of them
that are set in the south and then of
course the confessions of matt turner
and lydon and darkness are both uh set
in virginia
well if there aren't any more questions
then
i have a lot of practice now in signing
my name so if
if you all want me to uh i certainly
will thank you
[Applause]
hey nancy
thank you all for coming
oh well you can just take one of these
is what you can do if you want to
um
huh yeah yeah i gotta i gotta find my
pen though i don't have a pen anywhere
i'm an author without a pen
oh thank you very much thank you
apologies
like
that it's a daylight savings time today
and that's why it was a little late
that almost threw me for a little too
i've over the years had numerous uh
flubs when i forget to this is the first
time i've blown it is that right yeah
they're going faster
in a minute tony horowitz and carrie
allen mcrae the authors of two new books
discuss how the legacy of the civil war
continues to affect american society
about books airs saturday nights at
eight eastern and pacific time and
sundays at nine pm eastern end pacific